[Music]
do
madrid civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
we are
live in madrid spain that is el retiro
beautiful park where people go and play
lots of chess lots of street chess visit
it if you're over there
over in downtown madrid that is palacio
de centonia
the host site for the 2022 feed a
candidates tournament those are the
beautiful doors that the players enter
in daily everyone enters in daily to go
into that room right there
a playing hall where the chess on the
board has been entertaining fans around
the world
via the many live streams on the
internet
i think the chess is going to continue
to deliver here in madrid as elmira
kripchenko and i hello then we'll
continue to deliver here it's day three
how have you enjoyed the first three
days to this point elmira
well the first two days i guess they
were really intense i think
i guess i'm looking ahead too much yeah
yes filled with a lot of exciting chess
and
a lot of brilliant ideas but i think at
the end of the day they were grueling
for the players and the commentators
so i'm looking forward to the day three
and maybe to the free day maybe the rest
the weather's nicer today so let's hope
it continues that way for tomorrow right
we'll have a little more
won't be quite as hot outside for
whatever we can get up to on the rest
day right so well i'm looking forward to
visiting del prado yeah
all right well before we get into the
chest i wanted to quickly address uh the
situation that of course many have been
following around the world at this point
a statement has been released so the
world is aware that
grand master young lubric hammer did
test positive for covid i wanted to make
sure that everyone around the world knew
the story knew how that went down and so
for those who didn't see the statement
i'm going to go ahead and read it for
the fans now and then address some of
the questions that have come from our
community
during chess.com's commentary for round
two of the 2022 feed a candidate's
tournament
gm young ludwig hammer one of our lead
commentators on the broadcast began to
feel unwell and took a rapid antigen
test for covet
the test was positive
gm hammer was immediately directed to
isolate and all other broadcast staff
were also given rapid tests
all other staff have presently tested
negative
all members of our broadcast team and
all known contacts of gm hammer have
been informed of the situation and been
instructed to take appropriate
precautions and begin daily testing and
monitoring
we are presently working with feed a
leadership to assess risks and proceed
as safely as possible we will continue
to do our live broadcast with
appropriate masks and social distancing
but we will not be conducting player
interviews until it is determined that
it is safe to do so
we wish to thank gm hammer for his
commentary and wish him the speediest
possible recovery of course
so
there's the statement for anyone who
missed it and i think one of the most
important things i wanted to address is
i know that as that was going down in
real time it was sort of awkward and for
those who were wondering why weren't we
addressing it the most important thing
for us was to not provide information
until we had complete information
everybody was getting tested we wanted
to make sure that before we broke that
news that we don't know what might have
been the case once we knew that people
were testing negative we were taking
precautions we had contacted fide and
they were obviously taking their
necessary steps with the players and
their staff then we were able to release
that statement and of course make a plan
to continue the show as with anything
involving that type of stuff we're we're
being safe we're monitoring it doing
everything we can to keep everybody
where where they where they belong we're
doing daily testing and so the show will
continue and of course if anything
changes the community will be updated um
as appropriate and we will go from there
so
going from there i think it's time for
us to go back to the chess and say that
again we appreciate everyone's support
as we continue to move forward
with the action here in madrid and
on that note as we look at the standings
el mir let's talk about the first two
days of action right not just the games
yesterday but that's where we sit after
two games of play two leaders who drew
their game yesterday your biggest
highlight so far after two days of chess
well first of all the first day started
with a stunning two wins by yandy
pomnishi and fabiano caruana and then
they
faced each other yesterday so this was a
very interesting game a theoretical
battle but on the other hand everyone
had the feeling that this was some sort
of unfinished business you know we
wanted to see more
and i'm sure that players the first
thing that they did when they came home
they just analyzed the game through
they did that i want to i want to hear
their insights and like
i
really have a feeling that we missed so
many things well in this game in
particular so there was
another stunning game yesterday where
hikaru nakamura bounced back and he won
like a very beautiful game against um
timur rajabov
and
what do you think dany about this game
it was a very fine technical win well
you're you you got right into i think i
think it's been the talk of the
tournament right as we as we dive into
day two's results i think that takara's
win
is
the talk of the town right it wasn't
just because he won yesterday and day
two it was because he was bouncing back
from a loss so
as we let let's take a look at the
results specifically from day two and
and just talk about that because you
know
the only win was the win by hikaru over
burjabov scoreboard there will be
updated but uh the other games were also
exciting you mentioned unfinished
business nepam nishi and karwana uh
report versus faruja was also very
exciting a missed win that maybe will
who knows maybe we'll have some time on
the monitor to show how report missed
his win yesterday because many people
are asking that question so it's
something else we can get into
but i think again hikaru's win not just
that he did it but that he was bouncing
back from a loss a grind out victory
that had the internet talking and on
that note the internet talking about
hicarus when hikaro keeps talking and
doing great analysis but we also put
together a fun highlight reel of that
game as it as it had everyone tuning in
so on that note let's let our video
highlights of what went down between
nakamura and rijaba tell the story
after a difficult first round defeat
against his countryman fabiano carawana
hikaru nakamura needed to turn things
around with white against timor rajab
the bottom seed and by a few months over
hikaru the oldest player in the event
well nakamura has something to avenge uh
and you know these white games are
precious yeah so he's gonna want to uh
put pressure on his opponent but rajaba
is
infamously difficult to beat uh and the
stats kind of showcase that that even
though nakamura has the advantage in
heads up play there are a lot of draws
between them
[Music]
in his second berlin defense in two days
this time on the white side nakamura
avoided the famous berlin end game in
favor of a sharp known line that wrecked
for jabot's pawn structure but conceded
the bishop pair
tenuri rajaba feels that he might go
down to more than an hour behind hikaru
rajabob ever a dynamic player quickly
elected to sacrifice a pawn for the pawn
he managed to activate his bishop pair
at this point hammer was optimistic that
rajabov's counter play should be
sufficient for a draw
it might very soon be a one position at
one results
position meaning only higaro wins no
danny meaning that it's going to be a
draw
because i i do feel like
this end game down a pawn for rajaba it
really resembles what is called the
martial end game diving deep into the
position as rajab activated his rook
nakamura consumed an hour on the clock
and ultimately gave the pawn back to
elegantly step his rook up the board the
engine thought nakamura's advantage was
gone
but on a human level hikaru's active
rook and superior knight were difficult
to combat
in the time pressure hikaru soon snagged
upon
i think hikaru's gonna win this game
hikaru's advantage escalated quickly as
the players scrambled to reach the time
control and though rajab gained refuge
on the clock the resulting end game was
close to losing
although it was still so complex that it
baffled spectating grand masters now he
well he did it he did it so he
he will win this game for sure
in the final phase where java sacrificed
his bishop to push the h-pawn all the
way to h2
but there nakamura's knight halted it
attempted to round up hikaru's lone
remaining pawn and escape with a draw
hikaru's knight raced back to the
opposite corner to defend the pawn and
ultimately secure its promotion
okay we finally get 97
and
we'll
when wilbur jabhoff realized that
there's no way to stop this plan that we
highlighted
knight c8 and with v8
with no way to stop this plan rajab
resigned
though hikaru's loss against fabiano was
a major setback it was his hardest
pairing in the whole event and to have
bounced back immediately in round two
will surely lift the spirits of both
hikaru and his millions of
[Music]
fans a great a great recap a great
breakdown and
almeria was just a great game what was
the most impressive part of hikaru's
victory yesterday for you well i think
that they had to find so many difficult
moves at different points of the game
i'm still uh
surprised by this kingdom
he was struggling to find it and then
everything became clear you know it's
crystal clear after that that he's
winning but that was such a difficult
move to find
and uh well of course there were several
points at the game where he had to
neutralize the uh his opponent's counter
play just and to convert
his extra pound in a very technical
manner but this
this move will uh stay with me for quite
a while yeah
it was impressive and of course he found
many difficult moves how many difficult
moves will he find today we'll talk
about that as we preview round three in
a minute but first we jump into the
players hall as we see
fabiano caruana and young christophe
duda that'll be another very interesting
matchup today of course we know how many
people are already excited for the
farrugia nakamura match
dingley wren can he bounce back with the
white pieces against report
we'll find out
and then you see the uh
that's funny that's the matchup i think
of the day many want to see and neither
player there yet for ruja and hikaru oh
right on cue ollie reza the now 19 year
old he's so old look how mature he looks
now
he's so much older than he was yesterday
you know
well i think those two draws actually
you know make him grow he grew he grew
so much and
and uh we'll see we'll see what happens
when a 19 year old ferruccia takes on
hikaru and nakamura
we got to start there right there's
there's many interesting matchups here
we're going to preview all of them
quickly but farrugia nakamura almira
we're gonna have to really make an
effort to look at the other games
because i cannot wait for that battle to
go down well and as you can see they
haven't played a single classical game
against each other so uh you told me
that they've played millions of games
online yeah well not millions but yes
yes yes but an appropriate exaggeration
yes
well uh i think they um faced each other
in uh in a rapid game recently yeah that
was a draw yeah okay but i'm really
looking forward to to this game
especially that delirious zaful started
with two blacks yeah
uh and those were very difficult two
rounds for him so uh
i'm i think that he will try to
capitalize on the like with whites
that's a good point is if we needed more
story lines about this farouz nakamura
matchup it is the young ali reza
faruga's first white in his first
candidates tournament so we'll see how
aggressive that makes him play speaking
of someone playing the white pieces
though we have to jump from there to the
car want to do to match up because
the 3-0 lopsided score is definitely
something of note right given that he's
the tournament leader
thai tournament tournament leader right
now on mira playing someone who has a
great record against how aggressive do
you expect fabi to be
well as aggressive as he was in his
first game because he also had a very
uh nice recent reckon against hikaru
nakamura and we all know how difficult
it is to play against fabiano quran
because
well look at the game which was played
yesterday uh he used the novelty dubious
novelty but
he was counting on a surprise factor so
well i'm expecting no less today okay
one more one more prediction i'm going
to combine the two games together in an
interesting way and say that both ding
and rajabov have one game advantages
over their respective opponents report
and upon rishi but here's the question
if you had to pick someone who's going
to get a win before i pick the results
on chess.com's vote chess who would you
say is going to get a win
um
okay let me think a little bit i'm a
little bit surprised by
by this score timur has against yandi
bomnishi they played uh very little
games so yes
i think that maybe yanipam nishi will
try to play for a win today okay even
with black yeah okay wow
we see the first move being made on the
board by our guest of honor we'll find
out whether that was a troll or not i
think it was a d-pawn if i'm not
mistaken
um but okay
remember
everybody that uh here we go okay so we
have e4
on the board potentially but uh we're
gonna
keep a look at the playing home room
everybody you can vote at chess.com i
will do so as soon as we have a chance
in fact there we go on that note i'm
gonna i'm gonna dive right in we've got
this car wanna do the game i'm i'm gonna
pick the favorite fabiano we see that
okay i'm in line with 795 other members
but you have an insider's information
you're casting your vote you know when
you saw the opening i don't know i don't
know what the stats are but i'm also
going to vote for dingley run to get a
win i actually i have a feeling that
today's the day
that he starts to find his groove a
little bit
i'm going to predict a draw in the rajab
nepal mishi game okay so i'm going
against you on mirror that'll give us
something to argue about we're always
looking for things to argue about and
then we have for ruja versus sekaru ah
i literally don't know what to pick here
i'm gonna close my eyes and move my
mouse really fast and then click
what'd i pick a draw okay okay i picked
a draw i was closing my head i don't
know what to pick here i'm just as
excited as everyone else remember fans
you can vote all you have to do is go to
chess.com
events you can use the command vote to
get a direct link
so many ways to get involved just head
over to chess.com and cast your vote
remember that we are keeping track of
all of these standings throughout the
event and the top guessers the top
voters are going to take their part in
cash prizes as well as premium
memberships and how long do
we have and
until the voting is closed you know it's
like when the dealer says
it's about it's a i think it's move five
okay um that's right i should know
because i helped advise what the tech
should be and i think i said move five
because i think going to move ten are
you can already get a lot more
information but at the highest level
predicting a result before move five i
think is pretty safe
for no one to feel like they're getting
any kind of big advantage but uh
oh man i love i love looking at all all
four games from this view and just
like i said kid in the candy store but
oh we have a night of english attack and
carwana duda okay so that's that's how
they get my attention bobby knows how to
keep my attention when ferocious playing
hikaru and that's to play in english at
times i'm like like where where's
upper right corner look at that
we've got karwana playing an english
attack against duda who does not run
away from the night or for those uh who
don't know just how spicy that opening
is about to get it is it is going to be
a lot oh and he plays the h5 line which
of course prevents the g4 moves so it's
very important
caruana has played many battles against
many of the world's best players in the
english attack maxine bashed the grav
comes to mind as mbl rarely goes away
from his pet nightdorf but you could
argue that fabi is currently the world's
leading expert among top players in this
type of sicilian maybe before him was
vishyanan someone who played a lot of
these systems but that's going to be a
fun one yes but i also think that young
sister dude never
declines the challenge he is he's always
up to it so the only thing that i when
you're preparing against fabiano and i
know how difficult it must be like when
you prepare you have to uh prepare
against every possible move first of all
e4 d4 and c4 and a3 depends like if
fabiano is spotting a weakness so
basically you should do it uh in uh in a
retro analysis what is like my weakness
why i don't feel comfortable those are
the lines that i should look at i love
that point in fact i really feel like
that's an underrated part of prep that
people don't talk about is looking at
your own games and predicting okay he's
gonna go for this right or she's gonna
go for this because i have a loss in
this line right talk a little bit about
that is that something you do regularly
looking at your own weaknesses and then
trying to anticipate what they'll try to
go after well of course this is
something
that i do when i prepare against my
opponents and
also i'm checking well this is a very
difficult topic because not only you
have to look through your games to look
for the weaknesses uh through your
opponent games you're looking uh through
their second game sometimes okay if uh
their husband is a very strong players
then you have to look through those
games as well so that's why you're
prepared until six in the morning it's
uh that's why you're preparing until six
in the morning i gave up at midnight and
went to bed okay but all right no that
makes sense okay uh
so let's have a look at um at the game
between uh fears earlier
and uh
hikaru nakamura i think i think we have
to right we gotta we gotta go to perugia
and nakamura i've got the game pulled up
here we'll we'll quickly back up and i'm
just gonna show the opening real quick
we have a nimzo
a classical nimzo with queen c2
uh
if memory serves me correctly i believe
i've seen hikaru play this line
many many times and i'm saying that
a little bit just uh
you know
feigning caution because i know he's
played this many times in fact jeffrey
zhang versus sikar nakamura i feel like
we see this position on the board every
weekend in the rapid chess championship
and again that now that's an
exaggeration but the point is this is
well-known theory white is losing some
time with the queen
but gained the bishop pair and in the
process of course eventually hopes to
get a big center but but these lines are
very deep elmira in that we're not going
to see a novelty probably until mid 20s
as some of these games these games have
been played
and also this line has a reputation of
being very solid for black yeah but i
think that's uh that's why hikaru
uh well has made this choice three point
because let's get back just a little bit
uh before he cover played d5 i just
wanted to explain because here you you
also have an option of playing b6 and
developing the bishop
b7 right
so
well there's and there's um
d5 is the mainland as you said b6 you
can even play d6 as a move if you're
just immediately committing to hoping to
get e5 in a very close position of
course
if you just look at the the macro plans
of the position knowing that white has
the bishop pair black is often trying to
keep the position closed i actually like
the plan with g6 because it uh
it changes the character of the position
completely you know so you're you're
opting for the e5 and uh knight bg7 you
know this is a completely different plan
in this position yeah something like
this is not not super popular but again
this would just highlight a closed
approach for black given the white has
the bishop here so the way that a car
replaced though is the the most
challenging i think from like a
preparation standpoint because like you
said it's very solid and it means that
he's going to have a line
well prepared and
we'll just hop hop up to what was
happening in the game here
and i also wanted to draw your attention
to this move you know which might look
peculiar for our viewers like bishop a6
but it has a very interesting point for
example
uh black took on c4
and but gave up the center you know this
move has direct consequences so like
if white were given a choice at some
point they will play e4 and
grab the center and
e5 then you know and uh control a lot of
space so bishop a6 has a point behind it
so like if you play e4 simply i will
take on f1
and you will no longer be able to castle
exactly so it delays this uh central
advance
and that and that still might happen
because one of the
points to white's position is that
sometimes they're willing to play a move
like e4 anyway just to make sure they
get a big center with the threats but
there's there's another move here that
has been tried a few times and also
takes advantage of the pin knight this
idea is something that we've seen
be more and more popular okay ferruccia
doesn't go for the crazy the crazy g4
line i believe the last
person i saw played this was mohammed
yara and played g4
uh
in a game recently but those ideas have
become very very popular in in different
type of structures so it's uh it's very
important to keep an eye on on those
like g4 or h4 in different positions
it's it's almost the equivalent to this
all these g5s we've been seeing right we
see hikaru play g5 caruana play g5 it's
the the equivalent for white to play g4
with the idea of sometimes getting g5
you're prying open the king's side and
eventually
hoping to do some some very dangerous
things so i'm actually thinking like uh
of days like before the computers were
helping us to analyze the positions
since like movies like g5 or g4 like
back to my days you know what i was like
like probably you would
your hands would be
i'm cut off
you you went to that direction because i
was going to say and admit that i have
scolded many students for playing such
moves right especially when they first
learn chess you're you really teach them
one major principle which is what don't
move the pawns around your king it's
it's a you want to call it a soviet
chess school rule right you don't move
the pawns around your king because they
can't go back although modern chess now
begs to differ in a lot of ways and it's
it's i i find it's very interesting how
uh computers modified
our way of thinking uh and also uh the
way of selecting the candidates move
you know before this range was you know
completely different and
and now it's it's becoming more and more
bold i would suggest because we know
that the defensive resources are
uh
well incredible in in chess now so uh
it's very difficult to
beat any given opponent especially in
these tournaments
and and the players know that meaning
they all know that chess is hard to win
right and they see how computers defend
what seems to look like horrible
positions and so i would argue the
modern grand masters just they have an
attitude that is very stubborn right i
mean uh and commenting on a match
recently with johnny naradicki again in
our rapid chess champion weekend he he
went as far as saying in a position
where one player was defending that
grand masters in the 50s might have
resigned literally right but players
these days just don't do that right they
understand how tricky and how many
opportunities there might be for your
opponent to blunder
um
it's funny these two
well-known speed demons elmira just
seemed very calm today very poised i
don't know what i don't know what i'm
just getting this vibe like they're both
just
they're both just look at hicaro not not
even reacting to the move take a sip of
the joe
likely a a cafe likely a latte almond
milk no soy
if i had to guess it's a frappuccino
with almond milk if i had to guess
queen c2 normally i think that
black has well has a choice to continue
with c5 because this is um
a very natural uh strategic idea in this
position so
um
but i was thinking was g4 possible
before quincy like before quincy two was
played because i think for queen city
rook d because like now everything is
pinned
was it possible to play g4 here just to
specifically a little bit
and we should just show that playing a
move like like g5 after bishop g3 to
unpin and go take this pawn is actually
not a good idea at all i think it looks
very dangerous it's glorious and this is
to show how dangerous attack can be you
can make a number of moves here and be
better as white but even just a simple
move like h4 you start to launch the
attack black wishes he could play the
best move on the board which is pumped
back to g7 but he cannot
and so
it's again as elmira said this is modern
day chess that uh
this pawn
you wouldn't even consider a move like
this maybe 30 years ago but now you see
these tactics and you realize that
uh that pawn's not even capturable so it
it was possible amir um
the best move is i think theoretically
the bishop comes back to b7
um
so he's some uh so black simply allows
uh
white to play g5 here
yeah there's a if i remember one line is
to go like this and and now you just try
to play solidly right it's an absolutely
just nutty position
completely in balance bishops versus
knights where's hammer when you need him
you know bishops versus knights and and
the crazy crazy stuff he loves to
highlight hammer has a great series on
chess.com by the way about using the
bishop pair a video series so he really
loves the bishop here but
you uh
well i i would feel really very
uncomfortable in in this position i
think for both colors that's how
difficult it is you know i think that uh
white have terrible structure after
bishop f3 you know the position that
you've shown
but on the other hand you know uh
those powerful bishops open lines give
uh white very good chances for
building an attack in the long no long
round so uh magnus would win this
position with both sides i would lose
this position with either side doesn't
matter you see an isolated pawn in d4 so
it's a very easy target here
okay so that's why i think that uh ali
reza went for quincy too a more
positional approach like yeah he did he
played he played the super solid
retreating move and
note that this move prepares e4 that's
that's really the immediate idea
um
sacrificing the e pawn is very different
than the g pawn if if white were to play
e4 here instead of g4
black would
take on f1
and then immediately respond with g5
most likely
to go after the pawn as soon as the
knight is on pinned so just because you
can sacrifice the g pawn everyone
doesn't mean you can stack the e pawn
and that's why faruga brings the queen
back to c2 certainly i think that hikaru
will keep his bishop on a6 he will wait
for some
what do you think about c5 in this
position
yeah this position has still been played
in c5 as the uh oh we still have one
game yeah it's still
we we still have had theory here and i
after c5 bishop takes f6 was the game
dc
rook d1
knight d7 and i again
it was very similar but i feel like it
was after e4 it was
the same type of position but the king
was on f1
is a game i saw recently so this is um
it's very important also like even
though uh this game uh
there was an interesting point like when
uh white took on c5 even though like the
the shouldn't be on d1 it's like
sometimes black
doesn't recapture in c5 but play knight
g7 you know that's a very important idea
in this variation so just in case like
maybe later it could be also useful so
yeah just because black is clearly
playing for
the initiative here yeah yeah this is
very dangerous and that that example
right there is is a is a good showing as
to why you don't really want to be
taking this way with the king you'd
rather you'd actually rather take the
bishop and hopefully eventually find
some safety over here because
that idea of knight d7 just to show it
again
can highlight that if your king is
coming this way and the position is just
getting blown open
your king will never find safety even if
it reaches all the way to b1 right
there's just already too many open lines
too many opportunities for the pieces to
come over to the side of the board so
um so maybe c5 and e4 then yeah c5
e4
bishop f1 something like this
takes f1
i think how about you take on the phone
both brook and king i think are possible
i mean it's roughly equal kind of either
way just
and um
it's it's a very uh tough choice
actually for me in this position i'm not
sure like
um
because you don't want to play g3 king
g2 because your bishop is stuck there on
h4 so
that's a that's a really good point
we'll just show that real quick for
everyone that
the reason this is kind of awkward is
because
most the time you'd think this is the
way the king finds safety but the moment
you play g3 you might be trapping your
own bishop but sometimes the king can
actually just come right back to e2
because without the light squared bishop
on this diagonal for black the king is
surprisingly safe there and because this
type of position often leads to an end
game everyone you actually want your
king in the center so one of the fun
things i've observed about seeing this
line become so popular among the top
players is that
in in in blitz chess or when they're you
know maybe they don't take as much time
or they get out of prep too quickly i've
seen many games where white's king goes
from looking awkward and breaking
classical principles to every major
piece coming off the board basically and
then when the queens come off suddenly
white is actually doing quite well in
the end game because the king is is
perfectly primed for uh you know to put
on his shoes and and run for us run over
here so it's just an interesting way to
look at a position classically breaking
principles not castling but finding
safety because of black's lack of
opportunity
and always keeping an eye on the bigger
picture storyline of the position are
you quickly getting to an end game maybe
my king is not so bad here yes but um
the more i look at this position that
the more i like king of one and
look at the spin so what are you doing
in this position as black because e5 is
a very concrete threat yep
and
how are you going to parry it are we
going to play g5 in this position once
again
yeah no it's that's why the eval bar is
equally evil and right actually i think
that this might be already a critical
position all the players will reach it
uh agreed agreed and
real real real quickly we want to
hit the reset button and remind you
again of what the results were from
round two
there we see the man on camera and the
only man to get a win over there on the
left side of that results table again if
you missed a highlight video check it
out it's on all of our different video
distribution platforms which is just a
fancy word these days for
youtube twitter tick tock all that stuff
so uh hikaru got a big win now he gets
the black pieces against ali reza
ferrugia
and those were the results as we saw
them from day two
yeah and as we said the match-ups today
are are what we have before you now
hikaru
playing black against farousha playing
aldi reza perugia in a classical game of
chess for the first time in his career
i just i still can't believe i'm saying
that it's so funny um but this is going
to be a fun one
you know
elmira we see we see hikaru kind of
looking off to the side this is not a
position where either player is out of
theory yet this is just a position where
he's trying to be very deliberate and
clear about
about what line he chooses i think he's
really trying to be careful and he's
knee-deep in the weeds of his prep right
now in his head
well i think that
first of all of course kip hikaru as we
have seen needs to be very careful in
this position so
is he looking for another move which
well which looks a little bit artificial
because he played bishop b6
but since white also have lost has lost
a lot of tempers with queens so maybe
he's looking for bishop b7
maybe
like he needs to prevent this advance in
the center what do you think danny
yeah i think so i think that's that's
that's got to be a candidate move as
well um
and again amir's making a great point
because as artificial as it looks the
word you chose white's position is also
kind of artificial let's think about how
many times the queen has moved she went
here she went here she went here she
went here and now she's back on c2 right
so
it's
you know from a classical perspective
elmira there's a lot of features that
are very nimzo indian-esque right white
has the bishop pair white has lost time
with the queen and the classical nimzo
white is going for the big center
but the specific move orders and the
tactics to this position are so unique
in terms of modern theory and and that's
why actually this uh this opening is
very difficult to understand you have to
to play numerous games because also the
positions that
arise after this openings are very
different so you you could have
different structure in the um in the
center uh different ideas to master and
to use so for example how would um well
soviet players train at the time as we
can see now nowadays players they can
play literally like 1000 games per year
if they want to so they participate in
an online events classical events before
this was not even the possibility there
were not so many tournaments so what
would soviet players do or
the soviet school would what would
advice so then you study an opening then
you have a very tough sparring partner
and you would play like
10 20 games in this opening until you
have to feel the perfect feel of the
position and
the plans and their ideas but i love
that point i think that still goes on
you know in online and online settings
all the time right we know the players
can play in many serious games for money
and all kinds of stuff but i know that
many of them have anonymous accounts you
find a sparring partner and you're just
playing it's a great way to train for
anyone looking for advice i think so
many players spend
one too much time in the opening at
certain levels but let's say they're
ready to really start diving into their
openings they spend so much time
in the book of the opening or on the
encyclopedia when really the way you
start to understand a position is by
playing it right getting a sparring
partner and play just a hundred games in
a nimzo indian with both colors even
right switch colors and just keep
playing fastest way to really get get
the feel for how to master a pawn
structure master a plan in the middle
game and actually i was so surprised
because i was reading a lot of players
interviews before this event and that
was a very insightful interview given by
young sister dude
especially about his preparation and
like how much time he spends on his
opening preparation it was almost 80
percent like every day you know can you
imagine uh like how big is the knowledge
they need to uh
to oversee and like all the ideas and
all the opening ideas so uh 80 percent
of all of his preparation is devoted to
the openings i don't know what i spent
80 of my life on let alone 80 of my of
my chest preparation wow well
speaking of young christopher judo why
don't we why don't we back up to our
bird's eye view remind everybody that
all four games are in progress here in
round three of the 2022 feed a
candidate's tournament thanks for
spending your sunday with us no matter
where you are
in in the global world that is
this is going to be quite the day i feel
like speaking of young christoph duda
you mentioned him right we already
mentioned that him and fabio and caruana
are are also going to be engaged in a
very theoretical battle that of course
being a night of english attack
i say we head over to that game yes
let's have a look of course
okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna back up and quickly
run through the opening as soon as we we
bring that board up
and show everybody
how we got into this sicilian we had a
open night or
again the night or sicilian is defined
by this move a6 for those wondering
there are so many moves here classical
sicilian dragon sicilian chevron indian
sicilian
the night or
often often the the choice for those who
want to go into open sicilians at the
highest levels these days
first really popularized probably by
bobby fischer
and now is now is uh the staple for
attacking players as black around the
world right
you get you get all theory here in that
black is
kicking the knight and trying to develop
in a hurry because the idea is i'm going
to need to advance on the queen side and
get pieces there in order to get
pressure
on this side of the board before white
can really start to dominate with this
side but
what's funny is so now duda plays a move
that has
has become more and more popular over
the years it's an evolved idea where you
you make a big commitment it's a big
weakness to push an h-pawn over here but
you do it to slow down white's attack
because this pollinator 3 is supporting
g4 these types of positions have uh
have become more and more popular i mean
do you have any experience on either
side of the these lines well i don't
play the neither and
very little um open sicilian i wanted to
show you like there's sometimes like
when we are playing a four team in
france you know well there's a lot of
on stake so
once uh i played an open sicilian uh
against the very strong french player
mauricio back and uh mvl prepared me
okay so i just wanted to
come back to like just at the very
beginning like uh knight c3 a6
just at the very beginning and uh
like i think like here uh mvl you know
like i had to work up the courage but so
like we prepared for for a while and i
had to play h4 okay so let's have a look
at this move so you know there are a lot
of interesting ideas here and especially
at the time this was not uh the
variation which was analyzed that much
even at the top level so you know i
managed to uh to have a winning position
but if well eventually the game ended in
a draw but uh i really liked the the
character of the positions it's you know
that where
um
it's a maxine giving you the special the
special prep yes i'm jealous i'm jealous
i've spent i spent a lot of time with
maxine and he never never gave me any of
his inside night or
well actually of course i know how
dangerous those attacks could well could
be so h5 is a very committal move but i
i would say that in the modern theory
it's a very necessary approach yeah here
we've got a uh a comment from homssoon
in twitch chat bobby is about to wipe
dude off the board i
i think i can't wait to get to the live
position we're taking our time to sort
of tell the story of how we how we got
to it and uh hearing elmira's story is
great but i don't know that i disagree
with that comment
i think if anyone is going to wipe
someone off the board in an english
attack it is caruana uh upe uh yippie
yippie my predictions ding carwana draw
draw so those i think that was kind of
what i predicted actually i think i
predicted ding wins carwana wins and
that both farouza and nakamura as well
as
uh rajab and de palma she would be a
draw so i'm right there with you that
was that i think you stole my you stole
my votes there um i just wanted to show
here daniel that for example most of the
knight of players they want to play e5
here but you know but if you play e6 for
example because you change the the
structure right then you simply continue
with g4 yeah you're just all in here of
course so that's how interesting it
could be simply after like
how many seven moves which were played
in the opening so uh it makes a lot of
sense and for those wondering what what
are we doing with these aggressive pawns
or obviously you look at the live
position you know that one of the
characteristics of the night off is is
white is almost always putting his king
on this side of the board the queen side
as we see fabiano did which means
black's king either stays in the center
or goes to the king side so that's
that's how we explain moves like h4 or
as elmira said if e6 is played you're
just all in and these are usually not
the type of moves you can play in in the
neglect of your own development but in
positions like this that are going to
become so sharp
white is just all in to create as many
threats on the king side
uh as you can be so
f3 is played to support g4 this is the
more cautious way elmira than than your
h4 that maxim gave you
and a traditional english attack when we
say english attack we're referring to
this structure and the idea of an attack
here
e5 knight b3 bishop e6 and again h5
after bishop e3
so as elmira said this is
this is a necessary move if you want to
slow down white's attack but it's also a
huge a huge commitment because
eventually
if white is able to orchestrate this
anyway you're going to have more
weaknesses here than you otherwise would
have had if the pawn had stayed stayed
put
uh and also because it's a commitment
white can sometimes play a little more
positionally which we've seen fabi
already already do in the main line you
can you can start to change to the other
weakness in black's position which is
this this open square d5 and try to get
black to part with this light square
bishop so that's kind of what happens
here kenya just
one more idea just before uh black plays
h5 yeah maybe we can uh explain uh a
very important idea in this opening so
what would what will happen if black
plays d5 simply because you want to
break through in the center i think this
is very important to show
so
you simply take i think knight takes
knight takes and here well you're facing
a dilemma how are you going to take
because
white is going to play queen 2 and long
castle anyway yeah so this is so 2 here
let's say and knight c6 i think
uh you're simply a castle long and i
wanted you to have a look at this
position
so i like
white as i had in development
and
this position looks very very dangerous
for black
yeah and if the bishop moves often white
will simply slide the queen over
unleashing a discovered attack and then
looking to execute over here on the dark
square so of course and it's one of the
advantages of the move f3 as well so
because you have this queen of two
you have this square
no it's a and it's a it's a basic point
and so for advanced players who are like
yeah yeah i know i play the sicilian i
know i can't play d5 here but i think
it's a super instructive one for for
most viewers because when you played e5
here
you've made a huge commitment right you
you did it to gain time
you're kicking the knight in order to to
speed up your development but don't kid
yourself you've made what what could be
classified as a positional blunder if
you're just talking about the pawn
structure because of how weak this
square is and in sicilians when you've
made that commitment usually what you're
looking to do at some point is to play
d5 to eliminate this positional weakness
on the board so
from white's perspective as elmira said
white is always making sure black can't
play d5 tactically it's in fact there's
like a saying that like if black can
play d5 and he doesn't get blown off the
board
then he's equalized in like almost any
sicilian right and you have to watch out
for this of course and i i i want to
tell that another justification of
playing the e5 is just that in many
positions this night on b3 you know it's
well well it's considered to be a bad
night yeah
yeah it's not a night yeah it's not in
it so uh well
i think it's once again it's a very
interesting position so let's uh see how
fabiano continued so this is all still
theory and again we were just setting
the tone as to why black played h5 why
you can't play d5 here comes the knight
to d7 and as we already know black is
trying to accelerate everything he can
on the queen side of the board
before white's attack gets going
and now you see this move knight to d5
this is a a very common approach when
black has wasted a tempo to slow down
your attack you switch gears and focus a
little more on the light square
positional weaknesses
also this is a very interesting maneuver
because now as you can see white
well
at some point can play knight a5 and
knight c6 right on that note we just saw
fabiano do it that was uh oh no yeah no
right interest and
so we're getting to i love how we i
don't know why we've really we've
slipped into this like really
educational mode i'm having a good time
but the whole the whole reason 985 was
coming is because what happened when you
put the knight on d5 is you traded one
outpost square
ie
you traded this outpost square
for a new one on c6 and so
knight d5 is is very often
followed by some idea of knight a5 to
get a knight here on this square and
it's even worth parting ways with your
with your dark square bishop as car one
and did so because your your goal is
very simple i'm going to put a knight on
c6 have a positional advantage from now
until kingdom come and uh black has to
play very very slow plans to kind of
eventually re-maneuver and get his
pieces on better squares well this is of
course a very concrete sequence because
uh fabi when he played knight d fight of
course he anticipated that he has to
play bishop b6 because the pawn on d5 is
hanging so he has to give up his bishop
and then he of course he plays uh queen
knight a5 but he has to be careful as
well so at some point there always be
tactical motives to take
knight d5 and for example if the rook is
on c8 and uh
win a pawn you just did it again you
said 95 and then rooks let's keep doing
this every time you do it you look into
the crystal ball but i'll just highlight
real quick of course you cannot play
knight d5 right away because even though
that distracts the queen from the knight
and that looks good you would lose your
rook in the end
so you can't get away with that on that
note right as elmira said it
christopher plays rook c8 so now if
something like knight to c6 is played
this knight takes d5 is already a
possibility for duda given that if you
take here knight takes the knight can
take back and save itself
and if you take the knight
black wins the knight back on c6 and is
ultimately up upon so
carwana will show what what his what his
prep is here there's there's a number of
different options here for white still
um
and and don't be surprised if at some
point there is some sort of weird
compensation that fabi goes for right
where let's say that knight does take on
d5 and maybe white even loses the pawn
right you take back and and your knight
is lost somewhere whether here on c6
even in a position like that if you just
if you just visualize it just going to
make some random weird move just to show
and it is good for black in this way
but even here you can already see how
the computer feels by just getting to
the point that a move like bishop d3
right
and now you see the effects of h5 the
move that i was highlighting earlier as
yes you slowed down my attack but in
every road that leads to rome you will
have long term problems from here on out
i have this type of threat you don't
have a safe place for your king even if
you want to because there's always an
idea of checkmate over here and by the
way i might still get g for it
of course this is a very important
element while you're assessing your
positions just okay let's have a look at
the board uh well we cannot compare
queens rooks this is okay but
one piece that we have compared is the
bishop you know so how would you feel
about white bishop and black's bishop in
in those positions so very often uh
white sacrifices upon in order to get um
this very active bishop and to get my
direct attack on the black's king
because
are you going to castle here i'm not
sure no it's funny if black could play
one maneuver and this is a common night
or maneuver again i guess we're doing uh
this is like a night or master class
here um um and if anyone if anyone is
considering or wanting to know more
about these types of very very
complicated lines sometimes you see the
top players bust out 30 moves of theory
and you're like well why that move why
that move right so a lot of the context
we're providing is hopefully giving a
little bit of as we said the story to
the position if black could play a
couple things which is the pawn on g6
and then just put the bishop on g7 there
are so many variations of other lines in
the night of english attack where black
will actually do that he'll again i'm
not going to do it here because it won't
white is already playing g4 and this is
trouble but if black had g6 and this
rook was gone and the bishop
re-maneuvered that's a long-term plan
black will often go for to kind of
return the favor eventually you push
this pawn and you go for attacks on the
dark squares but it really highlights
how dangerous dude's position is in that
line elmira because
that type of thing is
is uh
is it's not happening here right black
is not gonna ever have the time to play
for this and g4 is coming very quickly
so
these are the types of positions that
you shouldn't be surprised if we get
yes maybe a computer can play those
positions as black and we'll see how
deeply dude his computer prep goes you
might he might be just playing with the
computer say but it's very dangerous
even even up upon there and once again i
think fabiano uh
has explained the way he prepares so
very often he would go maybe even for
worse position or devious one but where
he knows all the plans and where he
knows like where he's like one step
ahead of his opponent yeah we saw this
yesterday uh knight g4 was a huge
surprise for yann nipomnishi
and uh well he had he was like
one hour ahead on the on the clock yeah
at some point i think so
and kudos to yon again if you missed
that game uh we had a great highlight
video of nakamura or jabba but that game
was also very interesting um you should
definitely check out some of the parts
of the broadcast because
because jan jon into playing very well
despite being surprised and despite
bobby being up an hour on the clock so
so in this position we just have to
give a verdict is knight d5 is a threat
for example is black is threatening to
win the bomb and
or
uh sugar should white do something
well
we're gonna find out i think bobby's on
the clock here for for a good reason
because he's a big crossroads right now
but
one game has had a massively exciting
development and that is back to our our
very featured matchup and for ruja
versus nakamura we've had a
we've had a whoa we've had a full peace
sacrifice here that's exactly what i was
thinking about how well how do you deal
with the pin you have to play g5 after
e4 so your car went for this variation
and then uh earlier sacrifice simply
sacrificed the piece
this is again one of the positions where
like the eval bar saying this is equal
everyone is just the computer saying i
haven't had enough time to figure this
out because this position is absolutely
wild uh
you know what you know what i mean
sometimes you look at it being equal you
think oh it's just equal but this is
this this is the definition of unclear
exactly exactly but i i was just trying
to figure out first of all
just to have a fresh look at the
position so uh let's get back just a
little bit he took with the rook you see
that that was not clear shout out to
akilah from chat saying hikaru ali is
going to be a bloodbath uh i'd be
surprised to see a draw it's funny so so
we're gonna we're gonna back up i i both
agree that it's a bloodbath although i
wouldn't be surprised if this is one of
those 35 move like force known lines
that they both know so we'll see time
will tell but all right almeria take us
through so queen c2 we were predicting
c5 the card
yes for the most typical plan
disposition e4 right bishop and you see
ruka fun i was not sure yes about this
capture so rook or king let's see and
then g g5 because e5 was a major threat
yep e5 is a threat because the knight is
pinned and that's a problem shout out to
twitch again i mean it seems like white
will get the piece back soon here with
e5 we're going to get to that in just a
second and find out but as elmira said
e5 was a threat now so ricardo says
i'm not going to let that happen
but
here we go g5 it's a standard sacrifice
i mean if it is possible so if it sounds
so
knight c6
and
and not e5 yes well he can win the piece
back by playing e5 of course but then
uh
well a huge tactical line probably so
well this is not over 94. you have to
move back
well where
i don't know where i want to go
i want to go somewhere that comes over
here yes exactly quincy three is a very
nice move so maybe knight f5 and you're
covering the g3 square attacking the
queen
that's very important so where do you go
now
yeah and that's the thing is that
when someone sacrifices a piece in front
of a king you think they're the ones
that getting an attack but just to show
how dangerous this could be if the queen
goes to the wrong square
black is taking on d1
and black is the one
quickly quickly coming to these open
squares with the queen and the knight uh
actually saving a piece here right
because you've unpinned the knight and
now now the knight can find safety so so
the queen has to be very careful and
stay close to home probably something
like this i'll just play it but you you
have another possibility you can also
take on the six just you have just at
least two uh to show
is a very good motion because that
actually highlights the overwhelm of the
queen she's overwhelmed to guard both
the pawn and not allow rook takes d1
right so this is this is actually
probably bad because after rook g3 f
takes c7 you know the position seemed
very unclear to me just if uh if you
move your queen to e7
back okay
just here if rook takes d3
after xc7 i didn't know how to evaluate
this one
so rook d1 king d1 you know the whole
question is can plaque get this pulled
back right exactly so queen b7 is a very
precise move in that position
okay let's
get back
uh so maybe
not e5 namely that e5 what was played
quincy
first came back to the board
everyone
as much as i am distracted by the
beautiful palacio de centennial behind
him i did look at his facial expression
he gave a little bit of the hikaru
raised eyebrows like okay i don't know
if that was just again
that's why people love him he he's an
emotive player and who knows what he
really means with his facial expressions
but
if we're taking it at face value he kind
of showed a little bit of surprise
that's all i'm saying and um
anyway this is awesome right this is one
of those games where
despite the e-bell bar being close to
equality don't kid yourself both players
are one step away from that e-bell bar
giving you a heart attack and go they
are literally one step whether it's
forgotten preparation a miscalculated
line from this game being over right and
that's why this is going to be a blast
you know i was just smiling because i
was thinking well compared to poker
chess is a game of complete information
right but what we're coming down to is
just to uh speculating about the face
value right right
the face value no it's true if we're
taking it at face value and the
speaking of the complete information
that's that's one of the things that the
eval bar has helped us right sometimes
you know it drives you crazy when the
computers are announcing something that
nobody sees
but
oftentimes it also now helps helps paint
the story where for many years you're
looking at a chess board and
with you know with no real idea right
and now we now we know very quickly if a
mistake is made and so let's look at
hikaru and uh try to analyze it from a
poker player perspective you're the
poker player so okay
let's say so
what is he thinking at this position
after quincy one okay there is a 50
chance that you know that my opponent
has analyzed this position and you know
uh well i'm falling into it okay
there is maybe
20 let's say that he's bluffing okay
probably 20 is already like i think too
much at this point but okay let's say so
um
from our perspective we should leave
ten percent that hikaru forgot his
preparation could it be possible
i
i'm i'm looking at his face as you're
talking i don't know i mean so what you
said 50 i'm walking into something my
opponent has knows
twenty percent he's bluffing okay so
we've got thirty percent less left so
maybe twenty percent like this is like
he forgot about his preparation so this
is hikaru like
and we have uh 10
for um
and then there's you're forgetting
there's there's five percent that he's
singing an abba song at his head
okay dancing queen
enemy
that's what that's probably and maybe
another three percent that he just
literally doesn't care those are all the
options okay so there we just evaluated
all the options but
he uh he looks on a more serious note of
course he looks worried
so it all it increases like that's uh
this is all
the chances that this is an opening
preparation
i don't really see a lot of worry on
hikaru's face but i i think he
appreciates how critical it is and the
other argument that backs up your point
of view is one we haven't talked about
yet in any of the games which is the
clock hicaro is 30 minutes behind for
ruja
so regardless of whether whether the
speculation of of hikaru for getting
prep or whatever is true
he's clearly he's clearly less sure
about what to do than perugia right the
clock the clock doesn't lie as they say
right
first of all it's uh this position uh
is so complicated and once again uh we
have at least to explain a few possible
moves because e5 is still a threat and
why did uh ali reza played quincy one
because well he wants to keep uh
the queen elias on this diagonal and he
wants to play queen f4 for so e5 is the
threat queen f4 is the threat
uh first move which comes to my mind is
e5 for black because it parries both of
those threats but um
it looks very dangerous as well so how
do you continue after e5
yeah well let's let's look at this
because i agree i think that the more i
look at the position and we spend a lot
of time talking about the non x's and
o's the more i think that e5 almost
feels like an only move i mean there may
be other options in fact the position is
crazy enough
maybe you can take on d4 and look for
other ways to stack the piece back but
let's assume then you know i'm like uh
young ludwig no i'm like
now like it all makes sense to me rook
f1
prepares prepares your idea f4 after e5
so let's say d5 then f4 is coming and
it's going to be devastating the real
county one is coming to play via d3
that's why queen shivan not only it like
it it leaves the rook free
so for anyone else and the queen is also
going uh to the king to queen side king
side beer e3 queen of three queen g3 i
love this idea i mean the you can't you
can't play queen e3 be careful but you
but you you have other ones to get over
the knight is not on default of course
and the rook taking on f1 is really is
really huge because
possibly even before
rook d3 we could analyze the move f4 and
i i'm not sure it works but i'm gonna
forget the engine here for a sec okay i
knew i knew you were gonna do that eval
bar i don't really care i was just
trying to show that this may not be this
may not be so simple i mean the pieces
start coming to life
and
well you have to protect
the knight by rook g6 i think that's the
only move here
but maybe we should prepare it so let's
see e5 knight d4
so e5 knight d4
e5
okay
okay queen e3 here doesn't work we have
knight c2 we have to bring another piece
to the attack i think your idea rook d3
was actually really awesome and
oh man this game is going to be awesome
real quick elmira you know what else is
going to be awesome
oh please tell me our last quarterfinal
for the i'm not a gm speed chess
championship uh coming up next we have
paulina shubalova taking on national
master james canty you need to tune in
to chess.com on june 20th at 10 a.m
pacific to see this match yours truly
already went down i don't really want to
talk about it but uh eric rosen eric
rosen defeated me this quarterfinal
matchup the winner will take on lawrence
trent in the semifinals and as we said
rosen already beat me in the semi-finals
on the other side of the bracket so he
is waiting in the championship for
whoever comes from the left side so tune
in to kante versus shivalova while we
tune in here again to hikaru and
whatever he whatever he's thinking about
in his head well please don't shoot me i
have to share a secret you know that
i've never played in those tournaments
not even once i think we invited you
though no i've never like i've never
like ever are you not are you
confronting me on camera that's not the
question of
the invitation it's like because i
thought that you need to qualify
i just didn't i just didn't know how
like uh it's like it wouldn't be the
first time i've been confronted by a
co-host of us i was teasing um we can
invite you next you want to be invited
next year we'll just do it right now i
don't even know like what is the system
of this so it's like yeah i was looking
oh okay
agreement instead of handshake you're
invited next year okay this is like
every year i think every year okay all
right so everyone here
our first two competitors confirmed for
the 2023 i'm not a gms cc right here so
um oh i'm not the gems this is like you
you can't be a gm of course okay i'm
fine i was perfect
i will never be a jammer
um all right so but i like your rook d3
a lot because
f4 was too aggressive according to the
computer but this move as you said
brings in more firepower
yes we still haven't solved how the
queen comes in because of the fork on c2
but we'll figure that out at some point
but let's say if you bring your rook on
g3 well there are so many ideas uh like
even if you
where are you bringing your king
the king of fate
then bishop h6 or queen g5 like it's
it's so dangerous
yeah i
i don't know i'm so glad i don't have to
figure it out
because i'm not sitting in that chair
only hikaru does
oh my god
like now that's uh
well we understand the subtleties of
this position
uh
i
start to understand why hikari is
feeling very worried you know that's
what that's the feeling that i got and
uh
if not if i
then uh okay let's we we did we have a
look here at knight g4 or king like rook
d4
there are several possibilities in this
position
real quick first we're going to have a
look at that comment from twitch does it
caro just hate having pawns in front of
his king
that's actually funny uh obviously
referencing the the
first set of games round one where he
moved the pawns in front of his king
against fabiano
uh but uh i don't think hikaru hates
having pawns in front of his king i
think he just plays
he plays exciting chess and uh well as
he said he plays for the fans so i feel
like russell crowe screaming in the
middle of the uh
of the uh whatever it is
the arena right are you not entertained
someone photoshopped hikaru's face on
top of russell crowe's body screaming
are you not entertained and you get a
one-year diamond membership hit hit me
on twitter as we take a break
uh
pretty soon here
hit me on twitter with that photoshop
first fan to get me hikara's face on
russell crowe's body gets a one-year
diamond membership that's the kind of
day we're gonna have here so we're gonna
leave you with the bird's eyes view
elmira and i have so much more to dive
into when we return but it's round three
of the 20 22 affiliate candidates just
on the other side of this break we will
be back in a moment
right on your phone
you don't even need to download an app
just open any mobile browser and head to
chess.com events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more
try it for yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
this club is called amigos del retiro
friends of the retiro the retiro is uh
the most big and important park in in
madrid it's a very important park in the
city because it's right in the center if
you want to play chess you don't know
the place this is a maybe best one in
madrid
[Music]
is
m
[Music]
the defending champion jan napomnishi is
back at the candidates affecting his
second straight bid to challenge for the
world chess championship
one of the more experienced players nepo
brings to madrid an aggressive style
that is both challenging to face and
entertaining to watch
two years ago nepo made the most of his
debut in the candidates with a round to
spare he won the event in convincing
fashion
that's all he needed yon napomashi is
the 2021 world chess championship
challenger
that victory led nepo to a world
championship match with carlson and also
secured his return to the candidates in
madrid this year
despite being one of only two players in
the field to have won the candidates the
expectations for nepo are not
particularly high this time around
however his confidence from having won
here before in addition to his years of
competitive experience may offer him a
shot to turn some heads
if nepo should pull a major upset and
face magnus carlson again the two know
each other well
nepo has competed against carlson for
decades ever since the two prodigies
were 12 years old
[Music]
this is going to be a real-time
breakdown of danny wrench's games all
time on chess.com uh that's cool
oh
in the last month i am playing 83.12.
i'm less accurate than them in every
stage yeah and that that stains a little
bit okay do the more game review okay
yeah thanks a lot okay so tuesday sucks
i gotta stop like cats on twitter oh
it's because it's final tuesday
look how many blunders there were back
in december 2020 and now december 2021
1600 don't look at this number
look at look at this number
best let's go to
uh tactics
mates
probably need to work on these ones yep
every single rook fork that has
presented itself to me i have found no
one has a higher percentage of rook
forks than i do
that's correct
these are literally the night forks that
you i missed knight d6 it you saw it
just now what is wrong with me
i could have done here and then taken
this pawn and i'm winning because my
pawns get held together that's probably
the coolest part about this feature like
these positions against pets
rook there for rookie two
and he plugged his maiden one
oh my goodness i'm awful
[Music]
[Laughter]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
[Music]
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
speaking of queen isabella and the
legacy she left behind
there she is right there riding a noble
steed the lady herself
at one point maybe the most powerful
human being on the planet when she uh
influenced the changing of the rules and
gave the queen her powers as the legend
tells it's not even legend it's it is it
is well documented fact also well
documented fact
yonda palmishi is a very good chess
player
and oh hey buddy this is right there hey
there hey there man
his eyes his eyes pop up of course we're
going to be looking at rajabov and
nipomnishi along with dingley ren and
richard report as well we know we
haven't looked at those games here we
can see again a snapshot of all four
games but for good reason almira
ferrugia nakamura
that game that game's going to be lit by
the way you know talking about queen of
isabella and uh the um how
powerful the queen became on the
chessboard you know first one to
understand this uh were the italian
masters you know the renaissance so if
you well there are a few games which we
have left but uh they were crazy
attackers they were sacrificing
everything so here a perfect
illustration you know this is exactly
right from the renaissance era the roman
reigns
peace sacrifices were were aplenty right
uh discussion on whether paul morphy how
would he have done in the candidates
oh my god those questions are so
difficult
um well i really think that the masters
of that time they
did not stand a chance in the modern era
i
i was it was a bit of a troll i've been
sort of well documented as saying that
paul morphy was
about maybe maybe a candidate master
level whatever and i i exaggerate on
purpose because it gets a lot of the
hate from the fans i love it but the
uh the truth is i agree i think that um
the level of understanding is not only
so much higher but
it's it's not even the same game in some
ways you know um but we do love to see
peace sacrifices and some some artistic
maneuvers on the board well it's not
even the same game because also how
physical it became yeah so it's uh like
we've been here only for two days you
know players have in order to qualify uh
they have to complete 14 rounds you know
and each of these 14 hour rounds are
well i could compare them to win in a
grand slam so they have to win 14 rounds
like to play a tournament 40 rounds like
they're playing 14 grand slams
so
in order to qualify for the match yeah
how difficult it is given the the
opposition strength yeah no it's uh it
is a professional sport right not
something where uh you have amateur
enthusiasts maybe playing beautiful
games but it is a completely different
different game different lifestyle
different culture yes because we're no
longer talking just about the game we're
talking about
performance yeah in order to perform at
such level there are so many like uh
well elements that should be taken uh
into account yeah
well right now hecarim is taking a lot
of things into account um head in hand
because he is trying to work his way
through what is a very very complicated
position with no more pawns in front of
his king
ali raza perugia has sacrificed a piece
and ikaro is now down
roughly 50 minutes
on the clock by the way
shout out to everybody who delivered on
twitter it's funny i told one of our
amazing producers working hard behind
the scenes shout out to the crew that
hey if anybody does a good photoshop
we'll show it on screen well i don't
know that we can show all the ones you
did i checked my twitter for like
30 seconds before we're live and there's
already
there were already like easily 25
different versions of hikaru nakamura's
face on top of russell crowe's body
so i'm always so curious to see those
because well another secret i don't have
a well a social media account so i'm
living in another that makes me so happy
stay away from social media but i'm
curious to see like what is the
masterpiece yeah well we'll probably see
at least at least one or two and i will
i will do my best to give away as many
diamond memberships as i can only one of
you is getting a one year but we'll
throw some monthly diamond memberships
at you thank you for your photoshop
thank you for tuning in
playing along with us here this is going
to be an awesome day um
well
i guess i guess we should
we should
weigh the options really this is uh
i mean
one mistake in this position or
well will be fatal this is over yeah so
let's
we'll let's step out
and and pay off looking at some other
games real quick because i don't know
when hicary's going to move and so i
agree with you we should analyze it at
some point and try to figure out you
know what's going on but right now why
don't we let hikaru do the work i'm
really good at that we're gonna let
hikaru do the work and we're gonna we're
gonna just quickly back out and look at
uh first of all rajab off napashi is not
going to get much attention from us and
the reason everybody is just look at the
board there is this game is is i expect
the bishop to take the knight and i
expect this game to be
a rather um bloodless affair if you will
the opposite of of varus nakamura um and
even caruana judah because that's an end
game but i expect that one to be a very
long fight of an imbalanced endgame
bishop versus knight so i have to admit
that you were right about this game so i
i you were you said the promise you
would win and i took a draw i could go
four for four today i said that he would
go for a win you know that's like uh
well this position is uh well way too
simple yeah and it's no disrespect and
understood i mean if you're in for jabba
shoes everyone you just lost uh a
devastating game to hikara nakamura a
very long game yesterday and sometimes
as we say as the soviet chess school
would advise never lose two games in a
row that's kind of the rule right stop
the bleeding right away uh because
because that's how bad things happen
rajab even with the white pieces is
probably also okay with a peaceful
result on that note
so the only other one we haven't looked
at is report
and dingley wren
um
that that one
that one's gonna have some some
interesting stuff to it so maybe we hop
over there give that one a little bit of
time
as we wait for some action in caruana
duda and furusa nakamura yes let's have
a look at
the opening
we'll go look over here my apologies i'm
i'm slow right now on the uh
on the switchover
there's my mouse sorry took a second to
get that get that back my apologies all
right what what do we think about let's
let's evaluate where we stand
um and then we'll maybe back up and see
how we got here well well it looks like
a gruntful to me anyway
of course but i think it's like i was
trying to remember if i've seen um
richard uh
play this uh
this opening because well he loves very
much the king's indians sometimes also
the name so you know so uh well
maybe a rare greenfield but okay let's
have a look at his preparation obviously
first we gotta have a look at his
suit today you said he looks like it
looks like a rock star with the long
hair i feel like he's about to go seeing
seeing lead vocals for leonard skinner
you know and i'm in the front row
wearing a tuxedo t-shirt just partying
i'm out of my mind right
we're never mind okay we're gonna move
on all right um
we have we have a grown field by the way
the reason elmira and i said that you
wanna let's paint what the storyline is
from here in this game because why did
we both quickly say it was a grunfeld
it's because we have a big center versus
the two on one majority so
what's the general sort of battle in
these structures that both sides are
playing towards no but it's so strange
like you have a big center versus a
quincy majority for me the main aspect
of the grinfire is the bishop of g7 in
the center you see that's like how i
would characterize it
that's right
you know i mean of course the gruntfeld
the griffith definitely defined by the
female but for me i mean okay so it's
funny we both looked at it to me the
immediately defining factor is the
central majority versus the long-term
endgame advantage maybe of this
two-on-one of course but well sometimes
uh oh yeah this is not the type of
position
which we usually have on the board so uh
let's have a look um let's look at how
we got yes how we got here
okay it was a grunfeld as elmira said
the grenfell is defined right here
because you can you can play bishop g7
and this would be
maybe maybe a more traditional king's
indian for those who play that
but the grunfeld is with d5
black sacrifices a center pawn giving
white
the pesky majority
i know i know it's not the proper way to
say it um
but
but what compensation is black getting
for the big center
well first
first of all we should explain that uh
black almost always starts to attack
this center by playing c5 it's very
important
and then bring all the pieces into place
so let's say this compensation is
sort of the dynamic play which black is
opting for almost everywhere
and one of the uh leading specialists in
this opening is maximum
once again again
an mvl reference a night or expert in
the due to game and a grenfell expert in
this game the same so
those are his two pet openings yep
and also it's it also shows how easy it
is to target his preparation for example
like uh
i was interviewing quite a lot of strong
players
about maxim especially like before the
previous candidates
and almost all of them told me that he
has a very narrow
repertoire which is also his strengths
and his weakness because he knows these
positions he's like he feels them very
well but it makes it so easy to prepare
against him for example
we were talking about the preparation
for the candidates you have a team of of
people who is looking to get
to the games of your opponent and they
would say okay this is the weakness this
is what we are going to concentrate on
and there are very little surprise value
from from maxim yeah and
very often i well he would be targeted
in a line in a particular line and
where computers
will improve
what's interesting i mean i i want to
unpack that storyline of mvl a little
more because i think that uh
it's been a topic that robert hess and i
have gotten into a lot you know the last
candidates and and of course when we
talk about maxine
whether it's time to kind of change that
right he's one of the
uh
the
the last musketeers or last of the
mohicans if you will that he's uh so
many top players are defined these days
by their flexibility by the fact that
they're evading preparation uh looking
for an original position as early as
possible or as fabi said right trying to
even give your opponent a small
advantage but surprise them maxime is is
old school in that way right he has his
systems and he sticks with them
but i wonder if uh
do you think do you think that that's
something that he might be adjusting at
some point well he's certainly i think
adjusting it uh already and you know
i've seen him playing different openings
you know so he's like
testing the waters if uh if i can say
but uh i feel that
when he's playing the grunfeld and the
knight of this is he's in his element
yeah you know he i think he simply loves
those openings
i i agree and it is important to play
chess when you love it so let's all
right let's talk about the opening he
loves so we can get caught up here the
the moot b6 was played this is still
kind of well known but after rook c1
bishop b7 bishop b5
then i just
won
more question like when b6 was played
uh it would be legitimate to ask why
can't i take on c5
you know just to show it you know
because this is uh well a very
interesting option i think the thing is
here like you
you're also looking for a dynamic play
so you do not capture yeah at this
position so i don't know like i cannot
remember if night day five for quincy
seven one of these i think this refers
to avoid the queen trade and then you
have both knight a5 knight e5
on the table at some point
the idea is that of course if white
takes another pawn this and i think that
this example actually uh perfectly
illustrates the spirit of this opening
yes because very often you would
sacrifice upon but you will always get
the uh
the dynamic play your pieces are very
active and uh
the positions are very interesting yeah
and so here you see black long-term
compensation a weak c3 pawn on a
diagonal and a file a weak a2 pawn over
here you have rook d8 knight a5 all
kinds of stuff so this is definitely in
the spirit of the grunfeld white white
doesn't like those positions in fact
often often kind of wants to parry the
threats of black's pressure by just by
just buckling down and holding on to the
big majority
bishop to b5 we were we were still in
opening theory here
rook c8 slightly less common than
i guess knight a5 immediately and e6 i
know i've seen e6
several times but rook c8
and after queen to d2
cd cd and queen d6 so this was
perhaps the first sort of new move in
the game for black
it makes sense you're bringing the queen
up so that you can put the rook on d8
this is just a normal way to continue to
increase
pressure but this is a very unusual idea
i would say conditions
why not uh let's get just back a little
bit because
richard is still thinking so well the
live position is is queen d6
position rook d1
offers the queen trade that's what i
wanted to say the idea behind queen the
six is probably to play queen before
actually so
uh
because otherwise it seems very strange
to me
well let's let's highlight of course
of course white could take on b4 and the
position still close to equal and that
that would maybe give us a chance to
just talk a little bit about the dynamic
i first noticed when we came here which
to me was the defining characteristic of
the grunfeld white has the center but
black has a two on one and so
in some ways
if the pieces are coming off the board
and black feels that that white isn't
getting a big advantage with the pawns
the long-term idea is that black
whenever you have a two-on-one majority
in an end game
in theory you should be able to get a
past pawn and pass pawns eventually
maybe become queens so this is just sort
of the long-term positional feature
and usually with the pieces traded it
actually helps black's pieces just sort
of poke at these pawns that rather than
them being a strength like they would be
in a middle game when you've got a bunch
of pieces on the board in your queen
maybe they become a weakness too or at
least something you have to defend so
anyway of course white's still fine but
that's just high level one of the things
that could be going on here
in the game
dingley wren refused
to trade queens
put the lady on d3
and there you have the current position
well while dingley red may have refused
the queen trade he did not refuse an
interview
from our own dina velankaya yesterday
and uh so we're gonna take a second and
and talk to dingley wren about about him
getting into the candidates about his
his choice of chair which is by the way
again a dynamic take a look he's got a
shorter chair than richard report
we're going to listen in now and see all
the things that dina valencia and
dingley ren talked about yesterday
ding thank you for joining us please
take us through your emotions during the
game
oh well it's uh
it's quite going but
quite interesting
i think at some point i thought i was
better but
he played
a very good muluk b1
i think that's a
very good idea he found
so
it looks mamamoo g5 is not that good but
i don't know where i went wrong
it turns out my position is slightly
worse in the
final final position i think
but but i don't know how to
process for white at least comparing to
yesterday yesterday i played i think one
of the worst games recently
but today i feel
much better i think
the joy is a quite good result for me so
you're going like between inc after a
loss it draws a good result
uh yeah especially after yesterday's
defeats
and do you think for your opponent draw
was also a good result judging that you
had the three times repetition
afterwards
at first i thought he is slightly better
since
maybe he can try for more but
i don't know
all right on another note uh we were
wondering
what were your first thoughts
when you realized you actually
could be the candidates that you
actually had a chance to
to be in the candidates what were the
first things you thought about well at
first
they told me that i only need to play 30
games
to
to qualify
even if i lost all the games i can still
play candidates but then
somebody told me that it depends on the
average
ratings so i need i not not only
need to play 30 games but i need to get
quite good results
so i feel
not i'm not sure if i
i'm going to play these games but after
in the end
they convinced me that i had good choice
chance here so i just
so you didn't accept immediately but you
had a thought
yeah but in the end i
i take the challenge yes do you feel
like having played so many games in one
month now that you are 14 games to play
in the candidates it's in a way even
easier than 30 in one month
no the candidate is much more difficult
comparing to the 30 games i played
yeah
also
the over the board games are not
similar to the
games played on the internet it's
totally different games different things
which ones do you prefer
no i might prefer
play online
yeah it's
[Music]
it's more relaxing
all right
my final question to you it seemed that
you changed your chair today are you
satisfied with your new chair
yeah i like this kind of simple
and
normal chairs since yesterday the chairs
was
uh
yeah
when i looked back i cannot see what was
going on
after
so
also in the last candidates i i changed
chairs i forgot homes after the first or
after
at the beginning of the tournament so it
was a good tradition yeah yeah
all right thank you so much and good
luck for tomorrow
that was
that was a great interview how do you
not love dingley wren
well i'm
i'm always smiling this like he's such a
sweet character and so then are you
happy with your chair i first of all i
am happy with my chair as i well
documented when fabi came and uh did his
interview in round one i feel much
better in this chair than i than i did
the last time i was in a chair for a
long time during the world chess
championship so it's funny i want to
unpack one thing he said about the
sharon shout out to chad we love dane
you love ding and and we appreciate the
love
he said he can't see behind him with the
tall chair what is what that's that's
that was an interesting point about that
is that something that that that you
have an opinion about i mean do you want
to see behind you when you're you're
playing it's a it's a very interesting
observation like well if i once again if
you want to drive in the historical
parallel you know i was reading a lot
about the um the japanese society so
whenever you will be seated and
especially if you would be a warrior you
would you would have to control almost
everything you know so
this uh
this observation brought the memories of
everything i've read about uh those
situations so not but i think he wants
to have a look at the games or for
example if you are walking
maybe the chair does not allow yet no
sometimes maybe the chair does not allow
you to see the clock
and you don't see if it's your move or
not you know so maybe there's some
uncomfortable feeling about this
other things he said that were
interesting there uh dina obviously
asked him about the experience um the
feelings he had when he found out that
he might have a chance to get into the
candidates um of course everyone who
followed that story sergey karjakin's
spot was was not was not his anymore and
dingley wren was told he said at first
that it didn't matter it didn't matter
if he lost all the games he's in because
of where they set the rating mark mark
as long as he plays 30 games but then
they changed it on him said the average
opponent matters
what do you think about that
well i i really think that it was not
easy for him there were so many
requirements and overall he couldn't
play already during the pandemic
and
i think he was simply happy that he was
able to qualify after all but
there was another question when dina
asked him that's like if he would prefer
online versus live now and he's uh well
his uh reply actually surprised me a lot
you know because i'm sure he's going to
say over the board chess
didn't surprise me did you did you watch
the hikaru nakamura dingley rent
speeches championship that was
i mean and he said in his interview that
that was probably like the most fun he's
ever had playing chess
wow but that's exactly the point you
know it's like you said that it's less
stressful yeah but on the other hand uh
well
well fun versus shot for the title
it's fair
you know but i think that obviously
there's so much that is evolving and
changing right i mean online chess
whatever small prices were in it 10
years ago it was it was seen as it was
right now you're talking about large
six-figure sums and our global
championship more than a million dollars
in prizes right so i think that you know
the convenience of playing from home for
pretty significant prizes you know is uh
is is definitely
a big part of how these professionals
look look at their chance to make a
livelihood to earn a living going
forward right and you know that i'm not
in any way saying that he wanted the
speeches championship title i i'm i'm
that self-aware chat okay i'm not being
that biased to our events but i'm saying
like he clearly wanted it it was an epic
match i would say that in everything
that happened in the during this this
big chess boom in the pandemic you think
of the nakamura carlson final in the
champions chess tour first year and then
you think of the nakamura dingley run
match and and that match was just
absolutely just crazy awesome so now
well i understand this but i have a
completely different perspective i think
that uh well i look at chess
events like the sports event not even as
an esport event so for me
uh well
this hall is a stadium you know you have
to be a
in a special place in a particular mood
and certainly not at home in your
sleepers you know it's like playing
playing four or six figures okay it's
not even a motivation for me well you're
about to play in your first i'm not a gm
scc next year so we'll see how you feel
about that falling to that point
and i agree these are you know it's the
coliseum as we said it's it's gladiators
they're here right this is the arena the
stage is set um and there's obviously
you know there is no replacing what we
see before us i mean
this is uh the oldest and most popular
sporting event maybe in the world
actually i mean it's been around forever
right so i'm not arguing that but i
think i think it's fun to see that he
gave an honest answer like he actually
enjoys playing online more who knows
what that means for his future but
okay uh
we're having a great time we hope you
are chat thanks for thanks for playing
along again this is round three the 2022
feed eight candidates really just
underway we're gonna have several weeks
ahead of us here in madrid uh the
weather cooled down a little bit just
for the record in case you can get the
memo um rajab of napomnishi i know we
could head over there but you see what's
on the board that game
is right now a matter of formalities um
there's there's no world where that game
isn't ending in a draw we will keep an
eye on dingley
uh report but we've had liftoff moves
have been made several of them in furuja
nakamura so without any further ado
we need to head over there
and dive into what hikaru played after
the move queen to c1
uh so we left it in this position here
hey carlos spent let's see how much time
this is this is very not nakamura like
carl spent 42 minutes
on this position that you see on the
analysis board before you
this is very important he's spending 42
minutes uh on
what move is this
uh he was on move 18 18 so like
there's the positions is still very
complicated
and it announces a very very uh
difficult time scramble
yeah and if he doesn't speed up you're
right he's going to be not only
defending a position where his where his
king has no pawns right the emperor has
no clothes but he's not going to have a
lot of time to do it so this is unless
there is a com like uh a concrete way to
liquidate you know so let's see we we
had three opportunities here rook d4
knight d4 and d5 so he went for rook d4
uh white took on d4
yeah so
again if you're just tuning in we looked
at e5 as a main move which would have
stopped queen f4 and kept it maybe
closed it also stops by from playing e5
but knight d4 and rook d4 were both
options
and hikaru chose rook d4
after takes and knight takes
white had both e5 and queen f4 here but
ferruccia chooses queen f4
uh
i have a feeling that after e5
black had queen b7
ah
very nice
this knight is lost and then queen oh
greedy
i don't know if it's stronger just i was
playing on plane but maybe queen even
quincy too yeah just take it so they're
okay both are possible of course and
this position is probably i thought it
was stronger for a second because i was
reminded of the fact that queen e3 is
not possible but bishop is free but
bishop e3 is so yeah black should just
take the pawn first
all right but rook takes d4
knight takes d4 was was met with queen
f4 instead of e5 sankaru is
so attacking the f6 knight then i don't
have six and i simply want to get it
back into matu
uh
and then i was thinking carl is about to
make his move that's what i was going to
say because he was leaning over although
now he has
well he has certainly uh
planning on this sequence removed so
yeah
that's yes it's also a small surprise
for me here like he's still taking a
moment yeah to reconsider yeah
so
well and i think that pretty much
confirms that he's out of prep even if
ferrous isn't right not because
but let's have a look maybe he wanted to
make knight c2 here
and something is not working but what we
we have to uh if you go here there's
knight takes e4 with chuck
exactly so maybe this is a very
interesting continuation
and and even though white wins the piece
back this would this would make
hikaru very happy
simplifying the pressure
and uh kind of getting out of dodge
there so white will probably
play
[Music]
like can get two i can go back maybe 94.
yeah so you go
but now i can get out
this disposition so
i can save my night
can you play well check and take on e4
or you cannot look at that idea
takes and if the king moves no no this i
don't like yes
even this might be a little better for
white but yeah
so perhaps knight c2 is a move that
is rather forcing again this is um
do we have something else knight c2 king
d1 yeah again if if king e2 there's a
check back and we assume that that's not
what ferruccio wants i think d2 there's
94.
so this this is kind of forcing
check and then queen a4 can you play
king c1 instead that's
ah
duh
oh in the rook okay about that so you
can't so actually you have to go to b1
because if you go to the d file i have
rook d a
or knight takes e4 check actually so
it's a very straightforward line so
here's something yeah so this this whole
line might actually be what hikaru is
calculating and that's why i didn't want
to stop because even though we got to
the end and assumed that this is not
what fruition wants this position is is
maybe a little better for white right i
mean you have a
a traditional bishop versus knight
imbalance and the reason i say it's a
little better is because typically the
bishop is a better minor
when there's pawns on both sides of the
board so maybe you just should make a
move you find a square that's safe
your bishop is well positioned
to put pressure here your bishop is well
positioned to help these pawns advance
i mean it's close to equality but
well
i'm not so sure
let's say rook d8 here
taking the open file for the moment but
then simply king c2
and you see what i wanted to underline
is the structure
c5 b6 a7 you know already where i'm
going because i want to exchange the
rooks and then simply to go for your a7
pawn this is a very long term plan of
course
and if you bring your king there i have
my passer
a the h pawn yeah no that's why i think
that the same game has so the the plan
in this position is to exchange the
rooks yeah
so this is probably the most important
element i don't know like if you can do
so but uh
yeah and and the reason you want the
rooks traded not night for bishop is
again as we said the bishop is a
slightly better piece than the knight in
a minor in a minor endgame where you
have an outside passer so this king this
king can never go too far this king
always has to worry about this pawn
becoming a queen
whereas white's king
is darting up the board as fast as
possible
to go win
some of these pawns on the queen side
or even uh through c4 and if you play a6
i will always have b4 and then
i don't know maybe attack the b6 bomb i
don't know how exactly to
to find my way to the seven pound but
this might be very very dangerous
yeah so the chorus got to be calculating
and then evaluating oh no if you play a6
then i'll play a4 a5 that's
some point i will simply
go for this pawn so there is no easy way
to
hold these pounds
at the end of this line you're saying if
a6 is played you play a4 i will
play f3 at some point bring making to c4
and then i will play a4 a5 yep and win
the pawn
and yeah this is a tough end game and
again sometimes people don't get excited
when the queens come off the board but
this is this could be a very very hard
position to hold because of what we're
highlighting white's plan is so clear
and it's not like black is just going to
sit tight i mean he'll activate as best
he can but the point is
this is a this is a deadly advantage
sitting at the outside of the board
outside past pawns are a a huge
advantage in games like this and the
knight is the worst minor piece you can
have in terms of dealing with your
opponent's past pawns so
wow that's actually why hickory is
thinking uh because
at this point he's trying to evaluate uh
an endgame
yeah and so yeah that's what i was going
to say is that you have to calculate
and then you have to evaluate
right and so you can calculate all these
forced lines like we're looking at but
then what at the end of it
uh one way or another you have to
visualize a position that is not right
in front of you
as if it is and and makes them make some
key decisions right like what would be
your plan in this position how would you
hold the knight what would be the moves
and and that's often that's where the
the best players you know pay their
bills right that's what they do better
than everybody else is visualize and and
understand the correct strategy for
positions that are right in front of
them
and this is also a perfect illustration
or answer
of the question like how far
well these players can see
so it's not only
a direct line a direct calculation it's
also like that what you just explained
that they need also
to
evaluate the position to assess the
the end game and to understand simply
like 20 moves later
what is
how is it going to be yeah
yeah and that's
uh kaidanov
sorry what no no i just wanted you to
have a look at because you were you you
know his facial experience expressions
very well
and he
once again uh
looked puzzled
well again his work is cut out for him
and what i was about to say because
we're talking about this evaluation this
sort of visualization thing cut out of
always called it the essence of the
position there's the there's the
concrete
and then there's like the essence right
the nature the uh
and
he's he's not struggling even maybe
right now with which line he wants to go
for but he's really trying to make sure
that he doesn't put himself into a lost
ending right because he could he can
eliminate the pressure of the live
position right and feel better about
himself but if he goes into an end game
like we just had on the board he may be
in for an even an even harder task so
so what are other options instead of
knight c2 i think
let's look at an option that keeps the
queens on the board yes just queen g7 of
course so
because because now you're threatening
knight c2 and the king can't escape
so let's say that white
no bishop f6 threatening mate maybe
okay you can't take with the queen
actually because now there's now there's
a simple move and how do you stop
queenie too
that's actually
no i wanted to take the bishop simply
threatening well queen g5 queen g7 and
queen g8 for the month so like
wait if you play queen you can't move
the queen
queen b5 then there's this right so now
you have to come up with a forcing move
like knight c2 no it's like if you
if you move your queen you're uh you
free the d7 square so
yeah i just assume there has to be some
maybe yes but for sure
there is
but you need to
quench a seven because at some point you
can take the rook you will take the
bishop maybe and take the rook is it
possible
sorry you will take the knight okay
yeah
maybe you could have also maybe you
could have also taken like bishop d4 and
then queen j8 i'm i'm not sure there's
like so you can take d4 here no no yes
here
and then you have this check so okay
okay so what that means is bishop takes
can't be followed by queen b5 and so
again we're back tonight to c2
and if king e2 is there perpetual now
you have a check first
queen b5 no that here maybe go here
you'll take on d4 iso
right
or are you running no no no
but where queen there's no discover
check
king g2
i wanted to take on d4 and play rook
d1 but
if you take i mean like
doesn't seem like it's a huge advantage
i actually feel like the right idea is
to keep the mating net and just run the
king there's no there's no wind
oh then then you're completely winning
if i don't have a discovered check
let's say yeah
but why don't you play queen b5 check
first
so queen d7 bishop takes knight c2 king
up okay you're probably right all right
queen b5 jack is probably better and
after king d2
[Music]
but now i can run king of faith king e8
king d7 king c6 i mean just in case well
if you can run then why not take the
rook
okay take
let's find out computer says huh
computer says it's okay
we just have a draw
yes queen g7
okay queen g8 so
can you take on f7 then queen king c6
queen is six
where do you go now okay let's have
this position is absolutely amazing as
wild as it seems this is not outside of
the realm of possibility right because
how deep does ferocious prep go
everybody
look at by the way he still is an hour
and 50 minutes which means he's clearly
still
uh just you know right now this is just
like dress rehearsal for him we do
rehearsal before we go live every day
farouja isn't even playing the chess
board yet everybody he's remembering his
preparation at home
how would you evaluate this position
because i'm thinking like can you take
the the knight on situ but then queen c4
quincy ford so you exchange the queens
but you have this avalanche of puns so
i don't know that you would play queen
c4 i think that white probably wins in
the same game so how to yeah this is
just like this is complete
so you're just yeah yeah so i think you
have to find a way to get a perpetual no
but maybe you can take on f2 now can you
take it
yeah wow hikoru has but queen f2 i
wanted to play king b3 and then maybe
threatening mate at some point okay this
is this is so interesting if anyone's
sitting here wondering why hikaru is
thinking so much if variations like that
king walk to b5
don't tell you what he's thinking about
then
then then i don't know what will but
let's let's tell everybody again
uh how hikaru got to the candidates how
people view his chances how it maybe
turned the chess world upside down when
he did so qualifying at the fide grand
prix of course
let's uh let's bring up another one of
chess.com's player profiles and let you
know one more time again
a little bit more about the man hikaru
nakamura
[Music]
in qualifying for the candidates hikaru
nakamura ratcheted up the level of
interest in what is already considered
the most important tournament in chess
with millions of followers as a popular
content creator hikaru brings along his
sizable community while also attracting
more casual chess fans
although once ranked number two in the
world most believes nakamura's best days
competing in classical chess were behind
him
that changed when this japanese american
grand master leaned on his exceptional
calculating ability to win the fide
grand prix
the unexpected victory earned him a bid
into the candidates for the first time
in six years
a five-time u.s champion hikaru has
stayed sharp of late by dominating in
speed chess formats nakamura is
currently ranked by fide in the top two
in both rapid and blitz
[Music]
a chess giant on twitch and youtube
ikaru brings a special buzz to a
tournament that already holds the keys
to becoming the next world champion
and there are certainly those who have
yet to rule out hikaru from catching
lightning in a bottle here in madrid
and
speaking of the coffee cup i mentioned
earlier we actually have
confirmation not that it may be a
vanilla latte with almond milk we have
confirmation of someone who ordered it
for him and that my friends is the name
of chris littlejohn
hikaru's second right there look at the
smiley face first of all we appreciate
that shout out to you starbucks barista
for putting a smiley face on it but i'll
mirror okay
all right speaking of the news we're
breaking here chris littlejohn is
picking up coffee for hikaru on his way
to the venue
uh
chris is chris is actually known as
ricardo's second um there's there's a
lot of discussion about chris little
john being carlos second because he's
he's not a grandmaster right not not a
well-known player in the community many
of the players we're looking at in this
hall throughout all the candidates they
have they have very strong grand masters
working with them as their seconds and
the teams that you have are often
part of what influences what we see on
the board so what we see right here
everybody in the game
by the way it looks like we had we had
this line with knight c2 and queen d7 so
he car does go for the engine what we
see purusha doing here on mira while it
is for ruger playing the moves this is
probably work that was done by him and
his second and the team gets a lot of
credit for that talk a little bit about
how important
these players teams are how they choose
them and a little more about that of
course i think that a choosing a team is
probably one of the most important
things in the modern chess era actually
right now i'm i'm writing a very
interesting book written by yam tim and
you know about the candidates uh in
curacao in 1962
uh this book is called the the battle of
the mines which shook the chess world
you know
at that time uh you had also two
american players bobby fischer and paul
benko and a lot of soviet players and
the tournament was so long but there was
a final story that i found out from the
book that at that time we will come back
to to the modern era that you had teams
you know soviet teams the american teams
and very often you had seconds which
worked
for many players
but
story goes that bobby fischer was not
very happy and there was a food with
paul benko you know he was he was even
late he was late for the flight he came
just at the beginning of the first round
and what they were arguing about you
know he was not happy that they had to
share a second arthur bisgard at the
time so
he
appealed to the american chess
federation they had to have a verdict
and they said that
well yes he was right this guy could
only help him you know and
can you imagine yes in battle over
seconds the battle over seconds so now
of course the leading chess players they
have the right to work and to choose
their own seconds and very often the
second is also a friend
someone well who
who can support you through difficult
times as well you're probably someone
who
shares
a lot of views with you so not only
chess views you can have interesting
conversations with
so um
we still don't know
who is
supporting feroza here we don't we don't
know it's like so
here as you can see uh the work has been
done very thoroughly
uh probably which has given him a very
uh
well a better end game in which actually
so he's working his magic now probably
at some point he will start playing so i
don't know
uh at what point um
because there is a result
in the books which was a draw
as as predicted so the players are
you know discussing what they had for
dinner last night maybe what they'll do
on the rest day because they didn't have
a lot to talk about
on the board but uh
but okay this this
this
they're they're talking about some sort
of moves here in fact they've just been
told to stop talking by the arbiter
which is kind of funny so but back to
the discussion about about seconds
talking about ferrous we were talking
about fisher
uh you know there's there's going to
continue to be a lot of talk about bobby
fischer throughout this whole year uh
because as many people know this year is
the 50th anniversary of the fisher
world championship match but i
wanted to remind everybody that bobby
fischer was also one of the youngest
players to ever play in the candidates
uh because we're going to be focused on
this ferugia game we see on the right
side perugia by the way glanced at
hikaru when he chose to take e4 with the
queen so we're going to i can't wait to
dive into this will ferruga be showing
preparation that's about to earn him a
victory uh but
elmira told a great story about how
bobby fischer fought for outfit
bisquiere to be only his second and
bobby fischer of course one of the
youngest players to ever compete in the
candidates uh before before ultimately
years later going on to win the 1972
world championship so okay
back to this game yes we were talking
also how uh elijah is reminding us of
bobby fisher you know that yeah reminds
us of fisher
uh
they're they're both now two of the
youngest players ever to make the
candidates
uh for ruja pausing and looking and
you know he's
it's he's obviously going to be feeling
confident because he wouldn't have
played this quickly if he didn't know he
was playing toward his prep uh the eval
bar and our analysis tends to agree with
him elmira that white's going to have a
lasting edge here
if you're hikaru though
i mean this is the first time you've
gotten up from the board in like an hour
and a half right i mean you're up on the
board like finally you've gotten
yourself out of the craziness that was
this this attack on your king
um
he's got to be feeling a small breath of
fresh air even though he now knows he
has work to do at least he didn't get
checkmated i guess
but i'm pretty sure once again that he
knows every plan and this position so
um
you mean ferrous everything yes of
course so he
let's remind everybody both real quick
because i think no no of course because
their knight of six was played after
bishop before you know just oh yes we
want i wanted to show this because white
had two options of playing bishop b3 or
bishop before maybe both are very
natural squares so
um
bishop before was also i in the b8
square at some point you know so
if they were saturated then you can play
bishop b bishop a7 oh i like that a lot
so
it's funny because
again real quick context what all we
were saying when we were when we were
speculating that this end game might
occur we just we just sort of randomly
put the bishop on e3 and only
highlighted later that white's long-term
plan of course is to trade the rooks
because once these major pieces are off
the board white has plans to infiltrate
with the king but for rouge shows again
just how deep this prep went we are now
in move 25 and he was still playing
instantly and played bishop before what
is the difference as elmira pointed out
well now
in lines where eventually the rooks are
going to be traded you have to deal with
f2 first but eventually let's say these
rooks are traded
this bishop is already in a way more
dangerous position
something like this occurs
this bishop already threatens to start
to poke at these pawns right and it's
not to say white's just winning but this
is very irritating when your bishop
starts to attack pawns that are all
stuck on a color complex
just i i'm sitting here just like again
we don't know who his team is and he's
going to be the one who gets credit
because that's well deserved if he goes
on to win but farouza is showing that uh
that he came super well prepared for
this battle versus nakamura
now taking his first real think of the
game at this point with an hour and 45
minutes on the clock to 27 minutes for
hikaru
and will he be able to convert this
small
the small advantage we see but i think
elmira and i would would say i think
from a human perspective
this is more than a small advantage this
is this is gonna be a tough position for
black but i really like uh he covers
move knight f6 first of all because like
he will always have the possibility to
play knight d5 and to close the d file
very important maybe to support his own
pawns if they would move like c4 you
know c4 b5 a5
something i like so let's can we think
about this advance
so
okay so knight f6 i'll just make a
random move to show what all mirrors are
saying so knight to d5
[Music]
and
bishop goes somewhere somewhere yes
let's say
c4 then b5 and then a5 and simply uh
to transform
those spawns which we were considering
weaknesses into
like the huge army
so you see this is this is probably the
way to play this position yeah i like it
a lot in fact he also spies this d5
square again if we were looking at the
position when they first transitioned to
the end game
while the knight was on a central square
it's not the most stable central square
right why because one it's not protected
by a pawn also white can play f3 and
kick it out so this is actually a really
heads-up play to re-maneuver the knight
to the most stable central square
available one it's on a light square
which means the bishop will never be
able to attack it two is protected by a
pollen and three it's safe from attacks
from white so elmira you uh
point out something really instructive
there i think knight f6
i think knight f6 is a fantastic move
coming after a long song
yeah and it pays off i guess that he
spent
so much time by by the way so again we
said he took 42 minutes on move 18 that
being hikara which was rook takes d4
he took 42 minutes in this incredibly
sharp position where he's worried about
getting checkmated before playing rook
d4
then jumping ahead
on move 20 two moves later before
playing knight to c2
he took another 15 minutes which is also
a very pretty long thing
to play knight c2
and uh now he's on move 25 which means
if you look at the clock he has 15 moves
to make before reaching move 40. and he
has 27 minutes 27 minutes so
so okay all right
i'm really impressed
you know when you're faced with such an
opening novelty and probably you know
that was the case yeah uh
to
find
probably
every
move every single move that hikaru
played was uh was the strongest in the
position and also to find this uh
strategic idea of plane knight f6 and 95
once again that's it reminds me of
yesterday's game yep
no it's
he's uh he seems to be playing well
right i mean carl just feels on form
right again because if you're just
tuning in you missed the first two days
yesterday lost to fabiano carwana you
can see the scoreboard but it doesn't
really tell the whole story i think carl
played pretty well in that game we all
felt that way fabi was just better right
but but but hikaru played great he
doesn't let it rattle him he beats her
job off
now he seems to be on form here
defending clearly very good preparation
from the young 19 year old farouja right
and uh
and all right well we're we're wondering
what's going to happen in this game
today but if you are wondering what a
higher what hiring a chess kid coach
might look like for your game wonder no
longer we've hired a feed a master james
canty to start doing live lessons for
our own scholastic extension website
that's chesskid.com
chess kids summer clubhouse
is starting on fridays at 6 00 pm
eastern don't miss it chesskid.com
and chess kid tv you can tune in every
friday to get some official official
lessons
all right
we've got three games still going one
game in the books as you can see it has
already ended in a draw between javoff
and napomnishi so much ahead we're gonna
dive again dive again
into caruana duda right when we come
back that's one that has been neglected
for too long so don't go anywhere when
we've returned it's more from round
three defeated candidates in madrid
he goes for it wanna play chess online
or learn how to improve join us at the
number one chess destination in the
world chess.com with thousands of people
playing at any moment you'll quickly
find a game with someone at your level
whether you're a beginner or a
grandmaster chess.com makes learning fun
and easy sharpen your tactics with
puzzles and enhance your strategy with
our lessons by top masters learn from
your own games with our easy to use
analysis tool chess.com has everything
you need to take your game to the next
level signing up is free and easy join
chess.com today
[Music]
the oldest player in madrid at age 35
timur rajab is competing for the third
time at the candidates and for the first
time in nine years
once ranked in the top five in the world
raja qualified for the candidates two
years ago but was unable to compete due
to covet concerns for this year's
tournament fide offered raja a wild card
which raja accepted
[Music]
born in the same azerbaijani city as
former world champion gary kasparov raja
beat gary kasparov at age 15. in fact he
has never lost to the former world
champion
one of the peak achievements of
rajabov's career was his victory at the
fide world cup
in that tournament he defeated the top
seed ding lyren in the final to qualify
for the 2020 candidates tournament
in madrid raja hopes that he can lean on
his experience at the candidates to post
some impressive performances even though
expectations for him here are not as
high as they once were
the feed day candidates is the most
important tournament in chess
taking place every two years the
candidates qualifies the victor to
challenge the reigning world champion
and a world chess championship title
match
the 2022 candidates will feature eight
of the world's best chess players
they've all earned their spots through
two years of fierce competition they now
head to madrid spain where everything
will be settled over the board
one of those eight spots is always
reserved for the previous world chess
championship challenger jan napon mishi
would love nothing more than a second
chance at the throne but he has to get
through seven other great players in
madrid first
two spots went to the top finishers of
the most prestigious open chess
tournament in the world the feed hs.com
grand swiss ali reza faruja won the
grand swiss turned the heads of everyone
in doing so and has become the youngest
player in history to cross the 2800 evo
rating barrier he would become the
youngest world chess champion of all
time should he win the candidates and
ultimately the world chess championship
match
fabiano caruana joined him taking the
other spot from the grand swiss the u.s
number one and third highest rated
player in the history of our game is
also the only person to never lose a
classical chess game to magnus carlsen
in a world chess championship match
two of the spots were claimed by the
winners of the dramatic 2022 fide grand
priest cycle
grand master hikaru nakamura is a former
world number two a blitz and bullet
chess legend and the most popular chess
streamer in the world
he was joined by gm richard rapport the
hungarian number one is one of the most
creative and dangerous minds in the game
today and nobody is looking forward to
facing him in madrid
fiji awarded one of the eight spots to
the wild card invite grand master tamer
jabba
raja missed the 2021 candidate cycle in
consideration of covet concerns but as
the oldest most experienced player in
the field he's looking to use that
knowledge and punch his ticket to the
world chess championship title match
and finally two spots go to the top two
finishers of the world's largest
knockout tournament the absolutely
grueling feed a world cup
young christophe duda the polish number
one punched his ticket by ousting none
other than world champion magnus carlson
in the semi-finals of that event
judo would ultimately defeat karjakin in
the final to win the world cup
however karjakin due to suspension from
play by fidei sees his spot go to
china's number one grand master dingley
rent
dingley rent takes the spot due to being
the highest rated eligible player
according to the may 2022 fee day rating
list
so that's how each of our eight
competitors earned their bids to madrid
inside the palace of santona it's about
who can sustain the mental endurance to
secure the coveted slot as challenger
for the world title
but we're not sure who that will be just
yet we do know this
we'll enjoy watching every minute of the
candidates with the chess.com community
as we see how the most important
tournament in chess plays out together
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
back here the 2022 phoenix candidates
from madrid continues
we see richard report
very focused
playing the black pieces in this
grunfeld versus dingley run
we uh
we're waiting we're waiting for him to
make it we'll definitely keep looking at
that game i know we've been putting a
lot of attention of course into
nakamura's defense versus farouza as
well as
the uh the car want to do the game
which i think uh
i think we actually should get back to
the car want to do the game we haven't
looked at that in a long time um
but uh
amir how are you feeling dude
they didn't see us we were jamming
spanish guitar i mean a mirror asked me
in my wildest dreams who i play guitar
like probably more jimi hendrix than uh
santana okay a little classic rock um
but uh what about you play any
instruments
well
in my while these dreams i told you
already i'm singing so you're playing
the guitar and i'm saying i'll play
guitar you sing lead vocals yonder
palmishi will be partying in the front
row
um and
all right what do you think danny are
they because this is something i was
thinking about last night the chess
players and players in general are they
the rock stars of the modern era chess
players chess players and the players
you know it's like i think uh
any kind you know of like esports right
athletes
you know so they they are the rock stars
of the modern era yeah totally i mean i
mean there are still i think rock stars
i guess musicians whatever i mean you
think of taylor swift you think of
justin bieber think of any like huge pop
star but i mean yeah i mean they are
rock stars i mean especially in our
world and uh
because i think this is uh something uh
which is very much well valued now
this expertise you know to play games
to to have an expertise or any kind of
sports this is probably
is more important now yeah
that's i think it probably is going to
be even more important uh in the years
to come because it's also this
phenomenon which we're talking about
like the gamification of our society you
know you can observe it in any
professional field so i guess that's so
that's my question i i think that's uh
soon you know richard airport will enter
a building and you know there will be
millions of fans you know i i certainly
hope so and i do think
chess especially is
as modern technology right the internet
and you know here we are with a
broadcast and you have you know you
didn't have camera feeds like this 50
years ago right so technology i think is
helping to make
all gamers
but chess players may be the original
gamers the original gamer rock stars
right even more well-known to all kinds
of communities right their faces are are
seen more often so they're more
recognizable and uh and yeah i think
technology is likely only getting better
right and and one interesting thing
about what we're able to do now is i
think we're able to see more up close
more of the emotions more of how they
feel in ways that you know you studied
the great chess players of the past but
unless you were lucky to visit them in
person you never saw the live reaction
you'd see pictures of tal or bot finnick
in a book right but you didn't you
didn't feel like you knew how richard
report would act if he's better in an
end game right and so those are some of
the great things that we now see i agree
it's a great point so i didn't really
think about that way but but i had well
i had another um
thought because it's not only that this
was for me there was a greatest shift in
the way we like what are the things
we're worshiping or appreciating
so that's why this is one of the virtues
of the expertise that we are actually
looking for you know uh
so the
this kind of intellectual battles you
know so this is something which well
which public eye is more interested now
and
so that's why like i was thinking that's
uh in years to come
you know we will be covering this in the
stadium you know i i don't
maybe they're too far ahead right we've
got we got big plans for next year for
lots of our live events so i'm playing
the tournament well um we do want to
switch back over to karwanadu we've got
the live position up
here and i think we should we should
dive into
what's happening with with fabiano
and uh
and young christoph duda um
[Music]
because so much as so much has happened
they're in an end game a similar
imbalance to what we see in the game
between farouz and nakamura bishop
versus knight at the beginning we had
quite a complicated middle game like and
now we have
a very interesting end game
so let's see here you well for sure you
have to keep your bishop first of all
that's first thing
comes to my mind so assuming you're
assuming you're still playing for a win
if you're fobby because the first thing
i look at this is i mean at some point
we'll back up i want to analyze and see
what happened but
i don't think white's any better in this
end game i mean the uh
the knight is is well placed the king is
more active than the white counterpart
there and uh
i think long term you look at the bishop
and you think of your three-on-two
majority and and you assume that white
will have some way to maybe manufacture
a past pawn
but uh
that's very strange let let me tell you
how i look at this position yeah
let's say
all i say is the chain of the bounce
which is
on the white square so f7 g6 h5 which is
already you know
and a6 b5
there's always a possibility for me to
play a4
and you know so and to win those bounds
i can always play g3 so your knight will
not have any squares
so you have b3 or g3 here like if you
play knight six knight to f4 so this is
this will not be possible as well okay
so
now i'm trying to find out how to
proceed i certainly want to keep my
bishop
so in this perspective you know of
winning all your pawns so bishop e2 or
bishop c2 i don't know yet but maybe
let's say bishop b2
and
let's say if you want to play uh rook d2
rook d2 just to to show you something
and to play king seven and to exchange
the one rook just in case so maybe you
have the possibility of playing uh rogue
d5 later or
c4 i don't know like
c4 now i don't know is it possible maybe
start with c4
i see four before c4
no nice c4 i want to
uh
[Music]
to activate my bishops but maybe it is
not possible in a very direct way so
okay then king c2 is probably you have
to play here king c2
yeah i hear you and again i i
i think um
i've played a lot of positions actually
with both sides so i i certainly agree
with with everything you're saying and
evaluate white's long-term chance of c44
but i feel like the specific dynamics of
what dude has been able to do here are
are important though because
the knight on c5 is not going anywhere
and that knight completely prevents
white from executing the majority
advantage but then maybe bishop c2 we
start with bishop c2
because what i want i want to keep the
rook so let's say rook g2 rogue d2
and k7 because black wants to trade this
rock so
i want to play king e7 and first of all
rook g6 maybe there's a threat or just
and here uh what do we have do we have
more than
rookie 2
or
[Music]
i don't want to play b4 here because he
will play knight d6 so um
maybe you're right one second well the
point is you you can't do the things
that you would want to do with a4
or c4 if you ever played b4 of course c3
is just
horrible weakness and
black isn't without counter play right i
mean i can't actually play f6 and g5
right away because
the bishop is spying this pawn but you
know i i have f5 ideas at some point i
have f5 f4 ideas to kind of take
advantage of the fact that these pawns
are separate
so i mean
i don't know and again i'm typically
biased toward the white side of these
positions and as i said i feel like
fabiano is you know the best prepared
player on the planet in these positions
but look at his time
look at his body language
and you just look at what's on the board
like i i fabi did not get what he wanted
to get in this game can we have uh yes
can we have a look at how yeah so we
achieved this position read in my mind
so on that note
if if we're right that bobby didn't get
what he wanted let's see how we got here
rook c8 was played knight
so he played knight to c6 right away
um
but then we were looking at knight g5 in
our analysis so
yeah i wonder
okay so i can't question fabi's prepper
theory to be better but again even in
the lines i was looking at where like
it's better when you have the queen take
on a5 versus c6 so sometimes like if you
can come up with another plan that
improves your position i mean i i said
h3 which probably wouldn't have been
good because like h4
but knight c6 is interesting he took he
took a lot of time on knight c6 that's
my point he took more than 20 minutes
before playing knight c6
which is not suggestive of of
preparation maybe like uh let's have a
look because you could play no you could
play c4 in that position just a second
because we should understand what he was
considering c4 protecting the bounce
select and you can also take knight c4
and how is this position
looks better for
white than what fabi did according to
the computer although i don't really
trust the computer compared to their
prep at the stage i mean i mean not that
i don't think that white's better but i
there's there's surely surely he knows
this move and i don't know what he what
he didn't like but
but even though even though maybe a
different queen move like uh btx4 and
maybe queen a7
a7
i don't know like b7 b7 b7
but now then
it's okay
there are three
possible modes so a7 and
yes because rook c5 is also coming here
yeah
well but my point is i guess that
while we well we don't necessarily know
what the
what the move is yes of course knight c6
really didn't seem to get anything
um
he goes for this this transition
where he's down upon immediately but
gets it right back
um you're in an end game where
all the dynamics we've already
highlighted are are immediately true
bishop versus knight
three versus two for white on this side
of the board we do it wait wait wait
danny so
here maybe that was the moment where my
idea was possible
could you play a4 here
maybe that was the only moment where we
could play a4 but
yeah you're right maybe maybe he missed
it
blackened
you want to defend
i don't like uh b takes if you take
bishop takes
you can't play b4 because bishop takes
and then i'm trading the rooks and
this end game is
and
what if i take
take on v5 take on b5
and then something like
bishop e4
maybe i don't have much here either but
at least
c3
okay how is this position
yeah i mean i i i think that white has
similar chances as in the game you have
these two you will certainly play before
in your next move with black so and
exchange the spawn so
yeah but here white could even play
before unlike the other position where
the c pawn would become weak you can
actually do that and fix the whole
iceberg so this is a very interesting
idea yeah i like your i like your point
i think you might be onto something
really important if a4 was possible
but maybe this position is still very
equal
and i think it is and i think even in
the game as we see what happened by the
way bishop f1 has now been played and
the rooks have been traded on d2 so he
he decided to play bishop f1 okay
let's see what's the difference between
bishop b2
and bishop c2
why why did he decide to uh
to place his bishop on this particular
square
i wonder if a couple things one maybe
there's ideas where the knight comes
here he didn't want the bishop attacked
and the bishop defends this pawn so
that's a possible long-term thought
and if and if he likes the bishop on
this diagonal and we just eliminated e2
because of that idea
then that kind of solves why he went to
f1 right
and we're
we're guesstimating but this is more
than just us playing guess the move
everybody we're trying to understand
what fabi thinks is the long-term
strategy for white to have an advantage
as i said i don't know that white is i
mean the position is equal right but
if judah doesn't keep the pieces on the
right squares
in theory white's majority will come
faster because 3 against two is a faster
pass pawn than four versus three and if
this knight ever moves you're going to
see this a4 shot
so i think that's why you kept the
bishop on this on this diagonal here
but still i mean let's be honest like
well let's say king is seven here still
in this position just wanted to see like
king is seven
uh let's say if we bring our king
also king c2 yeah
uh
are we trading rooks here or is it
dangerous with black or are we keeping
the rooks that's what i am trying to
understand
yeah i don't know um
i don't think black needs to trade rooks
that would be my argument
is that you can simply stay like you can
simply sit and and if my rooks are on
the board my night stays on the board
because you can't kick it out and so
i would argue that while we see okay we
see due to lean in and he's going to
think here
but i would argue that uh we've seen
we've seen a lot as far as how they've
managed this position i don't think fabi
is feeling that comfortable but but okay
bobby was feeling comfortable elmira
yesterday when he caught up with our own
dina bill and kaya
uh they uh they talked about bobby's job
with napomneshi uh they also talked
about whether fabi's cat watches his
matches
unfortunately they didn't get into what
fabi's favorite recent horror film is
probably watches a lot of horror movies
for those who don't know it but they did
get into some fun talk so let's see how
that interview went with dina and fabi
as we wait for duda to respond to
carbona's latest
thanks for joining
when you saw nepo took a pause in the
way god surprised
what was happening in your mind did you
have like some kind of confidence boost
well i knew that knight g4 would come as
a surprise um
i don't know if many people have
analyzed this move it's a novelty
i played the position myself against
wesley so in a
blitz game or rapid game i forgot and i
played knight h7 which is a common move
and knight g4
is borderline losing
um it was a huge gamble it's not losing
it's probably not even very bad but it's
it's definitely a very dubious move um
but i was kind of counting on the
surprise factor
and i also thought that he would go for
what he did which which is the most
natural way uh putting his knight on g3
and everything and then he shocked me
with this rook a3 move i didn't didn't
see that one coming
so that was like a cold shower for you
uh well you expect at some point that
you're going to be surprised and that
was the moment when i had to start
thinking very hard
but i thought my position was very good
at some point i thought i was much
better
but i couldn't find the way to exactly
coordinate my pieces because i'm up a
lot of material but he has this very
lasting initiative my king is weak
i thought there should be some way to
prove an advantage but i just couldn't
find it
so now you're waiting until you get to
the room to find what was the right way
to finish him off
i don't think i'll check the game
all right
then let me ask you something that is
not connected to the game
you're not even 30 and yet you are here
the most experienced player when it
comes to the candidates formats do you
think there is some kind of uh
um good thing about it
i think it's a sign that chess is
getting younger and younger
i mean i used to be the youngest player
in tournament or one of the youngest and
and now i don't feel that way anymore
um
i feel like one of the more experienced
players
but i don't know if experience counts
for so much in this type of event
um
you know like for example jan last time
he won the candidates on his first
attempt so it's not
you know always that experience matters
the most
that makes sense and it's the first
candidates that you're playing with uh
vladimir chuchilov
what is it different about let's say
having him aboard
well i've worked with
a lot of different people and everyone
has their own approach
so vladimir has his approach and i i'm
kind of used to it because we worked uh
together quite a lot in the past
about i think 10 even 12 years ago we
started working together and then we
stopped for a period and then we
restarted last year
uh so we we kind of knew each other
quite well uh personally and also in the
chess
sense
so it wasn't let's say a big adjustment
to start working with him for this
and my final question
how is your cat
my cat's doing very well
he's uh he's really young he's he's
turning too soon
um but he's doing well is he watching
your games live
i don't think so
would you
like him to be watching your games live
um yeah that would be very good all
right thank you so much fabian good luck
for tomorrow thank you
amir do you have a cat
well i have a dog oh you have a dog yes
are you so you're a dog person there's
dog people well i didn't know that what
kind of person i was okay like because
we got the dog only recently and now
that i think about it it's like i'm a
real chess player my dog is like black
and white okay i didn't think about this
before well it's funny dina asked him
whether he would want his cat to watch
him uh we know that the ponch meister
lavonne aronian's dog is a legend he
watches all of lavon's games okay so did
you know that no i didn't know that yeah
the the pawn the ponchter ponchmeister
so anyway but you know you were you were
talking about fabiano yesterday that
obviously he's he's kind of a calm guy
sort of reserved in nature right uh
but you know a little bit of a different
personality on the chessboard right of
course and you told me that he just you
wanted to talk about this and we missed
a question i think by robert hess the
other day so like that he's watching a
lot of horror movies
this confirms my feeling that you know
there's a dark side there's a dark side
of bobby
called him a serial killer on the board
yeah exactly but it's like it's how you
feel you know you feel there is
absolutely nothing you can do it that's
there's a death sentence waiting for you
so like like it's very it's a difficult
feeling he's he's he is he's a difficult
guy i can say uh you know more
complicated than meets the eye and him
and robert him and robert stayed up late
more than they should have i had to
discipline them and send them to bed
because they were staying up way too
late watching just like random netflix
horror movies like
in fact the lower the rating the better
they would just find a movie to watch
and and in the airbnb that we got for
them in uh during the world championship
so yeah there's a dark side to mr
caruana right there
those movies are probably fun to watch
because i think the best thing about
those movies is the commentary you know
you provide while watching so yeah
like watch out watch out
well we've uh we've had a lot of angles
to look at the players i saw hikaru
shaking his head a little bit ago um
i think as we wait for fabi to make to
make his his next move i think i think
we probably have to head back to the to
the game of the day here as soon as we
can and go go on over to uh
to hikaru
position
versus versus farouja
that's really where the action's at so
like i'm looking at the plan he's chosen
so he like we knew that he would put his
knight on d5 but after bishop t2 he
played f5 maybe we should have a look at
this position first yeah it's a critical
move like f5
yeah we we left we left the position
by the way hikaru was shaking his head
but he it seems okay and by the way i'm
looking at time
yeah he's not that much lower than he
was so again i i know i i observed the
uh the dramatic kind of like hikara was
frustrated with something um and he was
showing it but we left it after after
the the very nice knight of six retreat
that you were applauding elmira you
observed that farouza played h4 so fast
he was probably still in preparation
even now
and then knight d5 bishop t2 like
until this everything's like i was well
we were not looking at f5 immediately so
i was a little bit surprised but then uh
of course it explains that he wants to
bring his king on f7 and then the rook
to the h file yeah
tell everybody why you think this bishop
d2 is such a nice retreat from ferrugia
well
nice retreat first of all it seems very
natural to me because uh it keeps all
the options so you can always go
this
like both the diagonals are open so
and it's a square that i think could
quickly if this knight ever decided to
leave could quickly go to a very useful
spot helping this h-pawn advance up the
board right so you've just got a ferruja
playing playing a flexible small edge
f5 from hikaru
g3
king f7
here comes the majority this is this is
actually a very dangerous thing and it
forces uh the response from recaro
because if you allow g4
and white has two connected past pawns
uh we talked about that in one of the
games yesterday that you simply cannot
allow something like that you make some
sort of random bad move and and white
gets
either h5 first or g4
excuse me this is a this is a position
that and how important it is to start
with g3 once again maybe we can show it
oh yeah that's a really good point
because when i saw the three on the
board i'm thinking okay how smart yeah
this is okay i knew that he was
preparing that g3 first not f3 first if
f3 first black plays f4 yes it might
seem faster
okay but uh
but but there's a rule in chess
what's the rule that happens here
well um
i had i had to set you up because you
know all the memes of on passant right
not at all like like oh i mean i live
like you know i still live in the world
where like my uh my virtual persona is
virtually non-existent personally
well then i will i will educate you real
quick because there's probably some
viewers out there who i mean literally
i'm sure there are viewers whether they
admit it or not in chat who literally
don't know on poisson
okay and and we get more support tickets
written to our team on a daily basis
where they literally say like
you got to fix your site there was this
bug his pawn moved like a ninja and took
my pawn as if it had only one square but
you can see it it moved two squares
but it but his point like people just
don't know it's i'm not even making fun
of disparaging it's it's a rule that
that a lot of people don't know and it's
so a bit of a bit of a meme that
is real but actually like uh
just one historical overview that was
not always there it wasn't always of
course
actually like i find all these questions
quite legitimate
so it's like it was unwanted also i
think uh to make chess more dynamic yep
and but i can't understand it's but it's
i've told that story many times that the
story goes that originally the pawns
could only move one square of course
and and as as theory evolved and they
started to understand that the best way
to play was to be aggressive there were
there were stories legends tale of like
games on the street would start with
like pawn in front of the king pawn in
front of the king and then pawn in front
and so when you start doing that
obviously in casual games you're just
going to move the pawn to the center and
like it literally was born out of the
fact that they naturally changed the
rules to evolve with the understanding
of the game but what that affected as
soon as they gave the palm the right to
move two squares was this you know it
affected positions like this where if
your opponent works super hard and gets
a pawn advantage like this
you can't just let them move by you
right that would be unfair so they
invented the rule on passant to say that
you can capture the pawn in passing as
long as you do it on that turn if you
don't capture it right away
if you make any other move
now you can no longer take it won't let
you because you missed your chance to
play on passant right there
so there you have it everybody that's a
quick little history lesson here
and okay that's why of course uh
ferocious started with g3 was designed
it's very important yes
g3 f3
okay bishop g5 once again so protecting
the pawn
rook h8
stops g4
and then after c4
we stand in the live position where
ferruja is he can play g4 but well he's
weighing his options because
uh
hikari just played c4
so g4 is possible and here he does this
of course yeah this is
this is this is going to be a wild game
i mean whites i'm thinking that maybe
you should
keep the tension
you don't have yeah take and maybe he
should proceed with my plan you know b5
if you played c4 then maybe you should
go for b5 yeah that makes sense
leave the tension
play b5
then you have a5 b4 and black's whole
plan is to create some sort of counter
play because the one advantage that
akara has right now amira is that while
this looks really dangerous it's very
pretty with the two pawns the pieces are
kind of in each other's way right this
pawn can't advance as long as the
bishop's there but if this bishop moves
the pawn falls so you'd have to play h5
first but if you play h5 there's ideas
of rook g8 and then maybe if the bishop
moves you can win the pawn
we have
bigfoot pronouncing himself uh in the
twitch chat hi danny i was born in 1879
and ombasan wasn't a rule then i think
wait
please please don't
patronize us elderly you were not born
in 1879
young man
you are a young dutch lad and we all
know it um
well i think this would be
more funny if you would use like uh
before the french revolution you know
it's like playing with the umph song
like
be more creative people okay be more
creative if you're gonna troll us
back in chat um by the way we do love
you chat thanks for being here again
only one draw uh in the book so far only
one game has finished here in round
three of the 2022 feeding candidates it
was a a bloodless affair not not too
much fight from rajabov and de palma she
but the opposite of what we have here by
the way elmira is on fire today can we
just give her an applause chat everyone
give elmira some love here because i
feel like she has called more moves
today than she than anyone did in the
first two days combined so yeah and
again we were just highlighting that
well there is one table which is you
know which is free so maybe all i can
try my luck to go to the plane hole yes
today's the day to buy a lottery ticket
as we say that in the states because
it's an irresponsible way to spend money
americans love that um anyway
the um
then i had another idea because now i
want you to force to take on g4
we need like you know this is the battle
of the ideas because okay
we clearly understood that hikaru is not
going to take on g4 so how to force you
to take on g4 okay
that's very important
like either playing rookie one i was
thinking and then uh
my threat is to take on f5 and to play
rookie five just very simple threat so
does it force you to glitchy there just
to show everybody rookie five would come
in and double attack
so
how do you parry this threat
another one was like
way more simple rogue d1 i also forced
to take on f5 and to take your knight
that's a good point too rook d1 just
threatens to undermine the knight by
capturing here
so there are two possibilities and um
this is the battle of minds you know you
have you we know the plans and so i want
you to take on g4
yeah and if f takes g4 everybody the
reason we want to push this is because
the moment we have clarity it's a lot
easier for white to just get this bishop
out of the way
and push him baby start pushing these
pawns
although
again hikaru hikaru's pieces are well
placed for defense the knight is
centralized the pawn defends the night
the king is in a good spot so
with time this is this is an unstoppable
advantage but
but if black has time you still have
ideas like like a5 you still have ideas
like b4 coming and so
then but then maybe like
i i'm trying do i have rook g8 i'm
trying to find the weaknesses because
now i can play rook d4 play a4
and go for the c4 bomb this is also
possible yeah undermining this to get
this
the part of me feels like if you start
going for ideas that aren't just pushing
the pawns that black will be happy like
don't even know how but i mean okay like
yeah like
even just like protect and before but
but maybe rookie one is more accurate
yeah i don't know one instead
so let's say i force you to take on g4
well if
i don't want to take on g4 you're making
me do it i don't want to
but can you play some ah you can play
rook
rookie
but then if i take take take there
i'm not sure that i can exchange trump
c3 i want to play rook c8 and c3 but i
guess i'm too slow
just to show the idea to make sure all
mirror is right because i'm not totally
sure she is but i guess the eval bar
says yeah danny
elmira is always right okay you win so
and again i can't go to e7 because that
loses tonight so
okay so elmira does have a threat um
what if i play rookie because
even if it's not good i just wanted to
show that if the rooks are traded and
you don't have two connected passports
this is not a bad end game for black
right you can
like everybody is holding look at this
such a beautiful display of night on
white squares yes and have a look at
this night now like my kink cannot
finish right it's a wall it's a wall
yep it's a it is a brick wall here all
the squares are guarded between the nine
and the pawns so
so rookie eight is a very interesting
one i'm sorry
press the play button by accident okay
one rookie you want to play but can i
play simply rook e5 here
i still want to force you
why not
rookie 5 yes
but now if you force me now your rook is
not ideally placed so now i'm a little
bit like let's go like this is this is
this is not oops this is not like an you
know okay the same rookie four because i
don't want you to like
okay
i'm
looking for c3 maybe it was possible as
well okay i'm afraid like
yeah the rook is in a very awkward
square
okay rookie four now that i understood
because like
it protects the g4 pound as well so or
rook d4 for that matter in our previous
version so i can play now h5
i mean no no just it was
here
let's say you took on g4
i don't know which line you're it
doesn't matter it's whatever line it is
where my rook is on the fourth file yes
let's say because i played a5 or k4
because i protect the g4 pawn and i can
play h5 here so maybe you can play c3
yeah i want c3 or b4 i don't even know
though so
all right this this is exactly the type
of variations we might get into let's
let's back this thing up we're uh
we're eagerly awaiting to see is
farouza's prep finally done that's the
question we are on move 31 elmira and uh
it's already moved 31 okay the the young
man has an hour and eight minutes left
compared to hikaru's
uh
car was 20 minutes so
but
this is this has been a uh
a great display of whatever whatever
farouza brought here to madrid
as far as preparation again you don't
know anything about who he's working
with his team
well we know for sure that he worked
with the ivan sokolov like a very strong
grandmaster like and probably
uh who was trying to come contribute
more to
this overall yeah overall understanding
of the game yes chess but um
we all know that also that uh fearuja
didn't play
for a while
so he simply disappeared he didn't play
online he did i know i wanted him to
play in all these online events but he
hasn't played anywhere he played in one
grand chess tour event and that was
interesting of course so that didn't go
so well by the way so maybe the
adjustments they were trying to make
during this preparation
uh well
didn't work out immediately so let's um
yeah it looks good in that suit though
just pointing out
he's uh
he's grown a lot too a growth spurt
um
he's a tall kid for those who don't know
and magnus carlsen has designed him as
probably as his
i don't know if not his challenger but
potentially someone who would challenge
him yeah for the world title yeah of
course magnus's comments were um
were all the talk right and of course
magnus has made a couple statements sort
of since then kind of clarifying since
that initial interview that was given
after the world championship
uh but yeah it obviously put a huge
target on ferocious back but as he said
many times he doesn't feel the pressure
he feels uh
feels nothing but fun and love and joy
for the game
so what i want like to say so if not
this cycle
maybe the next cycle but he's well he's
going to give it a shot
because like when i'm thinking about
bobby fischer like he like
he's why curacao why was so much
interested in this candidates because
first candidates as we've seen he was
one of the youngest player to qualify
ever the youngest was
magnus carlson then bobby fischer
so he was playing his first candidates
when he was 16 and then another
candidates in curacao you know where
they had to face a lot of
uh soviet players but those were the
tournaments where you had to face
players four times yes here you have the
double not this easy double round rock
exactly so
important is available he
uh didn't play so much that was on his
first retreat from the from the chess
scene so this tournament like had a huge
impact on uh fisher's psychological
emotional uh state
so i was very much interested so you
know how
he managed to recover from this yeah
which leader also from him winning the
candidates and playing the match against
spassky yeah
well he and he did
recover of course play the match but
also like this retreat you know helped
him you know maybe also to work on oh
on many things like ferocious did now
just
after
playing the world blitz and the rapid
championships so he decided not to play
at all and to prepare for the candidates
well faruga may be following suit then
from fisher deciding not to play to
prepare for the candidates but uh
right now hikaru is trying to figure out
what to do against this young man so
while we take that in
one
i know we you called rook d1 a lot has
been made about ferugia uh being
whatever it is the next challenger to
magnus carlsen
similar to bobby fischer
i say carlo thinks about what to do
against ferruccia we're going to take a
closer look at this rising superstar
[Music]
considered by most as the rising
superstar in chess ali reza farouja
makes his candidates debut here in
madrid
the only teenager in the tournament
ferruja is the youngest player ever to
break the 2800 rating barrier
born in iran but representing france
ferugia strikes fear in his opponents
with his array of surprising tactical
shots
[Music]
alireza qualified for the candidates by
taking first place in the fide grand
swiss he also followed up that
performance with a strong finish at the
european team chess championship
coming in with heavy expectations
farouza has a more than reasonable
opportunity here to become the youngest
winner in candidates tournament history
with that the teen prodigy would take
one step closer to potentially knocking
magnus carlsen off his championship
[Music]
perch the ferrugia
2019 feed a world rapids silver
2021 world blitz bronze
really the grand swiss was
the most important term of his career
one because it's the reason he's here in
the candidates and it was quite the
tournament to win right the field there
obviously we know fabian caruana got
second um so it was a very strong field
and it was also the tournament
that made him the youngest ever player
to break the 2800 barrier right which
again these are the records he's
breaking along the way youngest to 2700
youngest to 2800
third youngest ever to play in the
candidates right so
when you're crashing through the uh the
record books like that
that's why you get a target on your back
from magnus carlson
well it's it's a very interesting
thought of course i think magnus carlsen
broke all of these records himself but
fearuja broke the
2800 barrier
and he broke magnus's record so this is
for me it's very significant you know so
um
i actually wanted to say that after his
crown swiss result you know it was
followed by his absolutely stunning
performance for the french team he won
the gold medal on the first board and
then they think his performance was over
three thousand yeah so
it shows
it's quite a unique performance i think
so i've never
it was really his first performance
representing france in a meaningful way
right so he's my teammate now he's your
teammate that's right um
nbl was on board two all of a sudden
right exactly well
we're also like the united states is
going to have like an incredible team in
the forthcoming olympics i think in
india but this time uh
for the french team um
both uh ali rezafirjah and maxima
schiller graph declined because like
feroza felt that it would interfere too
much with his current schedule and
we don't know like if he wins the
candidates or not you know there are a
lot of preparation is involved so
uh
both players are not going to play in
the french team at the olympia
it's interesting from perugia but it
makes i mean right now everything for
ali reza is about
it's about the candidates about what
he's doing in this game as white versus
hikaru um
and it's about him potentially winning
to become
winning the winning this tournament to
become the challenger to the title and
here as we see him
come back to the board sounds good this
actually shows how focused is well he is
on well
on this side
his goal and i know from conversations
with the family i mean ferruccia has
one goal
that is it he i mean it every and that's
why he didn't play in so many events in
it's why he uh
why he's been as maybe you said
reinventing the different aspects of his
game working super hard
in secret right with whoever he's
working with and right now him and his
seconds whoever they are have have been
putting on quite the show just given
that
he he has a huge advantage uh well okay
sorry he has a huge advantage on the
clock
uh the advantage on the board i think
more and more as we get into this what's
becoming a race of an end game i think
we have to give hikaru some props
because he's
he's made this quite the game given how
how quickly furushov was playing
but we guessed pretty much correctly you
know like how the game would proceed so
he forced him to take on g4 he forced
hikaru to take on g4 he can't play day
five everything is pretty much logical
so but how do we continue once again
yeah so we need to protect the g4 upon i
think in this version we suggest the
trunk g4
and then h5 but maybe
uh there is another option
how did you play after rd4 did you play
rook state here
on rook d4 we suggested rook c8 yeah but
farouza may i wonder how again i'm just
sitting here looking at him he just
seems so confident i feel like he's
still recalling something from memory i
don't know but by the way recalling from
memory my predictions before the round
started elmira do you remember what they
were what i said dingley wren would be
able to do this round is white
well he said that he will be able to win
i i did i said ding i said dingley rim
was going to win and if we take a look
at that board
it's actually the one with the uh
the highest potential to become a
decisive result at this point well we
left this game for a while so what
happened after
queen before 23 he kept his screens on
on the board yep
and then he went for h4
it's the alpha polynomial
alpha the alpha pawn is not the a pawn
the alpha pawn is the h pawn rushing up
the board in any fiance structure you
have this position where
h4 h5 by the way we're referring to
alpha zero for for those who don't know
uh the uh
the google google's deepmind project
that rocked the world the alpha zero
papers and we saw so many games with
this pawn just in a legendary way just
rushes up the board either to pry things
open or sometimes just to put itself on
h6 and and cause long-term issues to
black so
um yeah there were some games like
completely crazy where like uh computers
push their phones to h6 and then maybe
like
62 moves later you know they're like
winning in an end game because the the
h7 pawn is fixed
or there's like or like out of nowhere
all of a sudden you have to worry about
checkmating ideas that didn't exist you
know in an end game where the king is on
the back ring but okay like you said
let's back up and see how we got here
real quick we'll we'll do that because i
think we left on let's see queen b4 was
played queen g3
offering the queen trade
queen d3 to avoid it e6
dingley run had still been playing very
quickly to this point by the way but he
spent
uh let's see about 15 minutes on the
move h4
here comes here comes the pawn
bishop g5 is played
now that that's the interesting part to
me it's it's
it's a report who goes for the first
really big transition here he sacrifices
the exchange and that's actually what
the computers didn't like so that that's
that's kind of weird i mean
we'll catch up to certainly black has
some compensation in a live position but
but let's have a look then yeah but did
he have to stack the exchange before x
like
calculating iteration what
comes to my mind is that like let's say
a black has put its pieces on perfect on
a perfect square let's say the bishop on
g7 the roconson c8 the rook is on g
bishop is on b7
knight is on c6 so
i'm not questioning the queen d6 queen
before my nervous so now everything is
at the right place
uh and
things move bishop g5 is actually
questioning the stretch because are you
going to play f6 here because if you
play rook fj8 at this moment you're
you're probably planning to sacrifice an
exchange yeah and f6 doesn't look good
right
so that's what i wanted to explain
probably
richard already anticipated the small
bishop g5
and he wanted to sacrifice because i'm
not sure that he's the
kind of player who will make f6 here
yeah no it's fair and again
you're right that
i think you were what you're going to
get to is like a chess principle and you
have this like dynamic factor that all
of your pieces are on their best squares
right you can't make them better and so
in theory there's like this whatever
dynamic tension theory that there should
be something in the position before you
can make concessions or consider
remaneuvers you should always consider
concrete ideas
before you start moving your pieces
around when when in theory they're on
their best squares so report believes in
that theory and also
what i think is where i had another
thought that sometimes it might be not
the best move
but sort of a gamble right you know
first of all you know that this move
well would put your opponent in a very
uncomfortable position sometimes there's
only one
way to refute this strategy all other
moves maybe
bring you to a very unclear position so
you
i think you should always be ready to
take this to take this gamble so and i
think uh
this is where richard rapport excels
yeah i think he has a feel for those
well maybe intuitive sacrifices yeah and
even if it's well from a mathematical
point if you're not correct
yeah that's like almost like a
towel plate you know and
i really like this idea because i'm
pretty sure but when he played rook d8
he was planning on playing knight d4
well well so here's going to be the math
speaking of the the mathematics which
may not be correct but there's a lot of
tension in the position black is going
to end up with a pawn for the exchange
right so with black this is very typical
you give up a rook for a minor piece but
you get a pawn to go with it so if
you're doing the math
that's five versus four because the
brook is worth five
but again i i like my mirror's point
because that's the math quote unquote dr
evil quotation figures the math right
but
the activity of the pieces the squares
they control the threats they create is
what humans have to solve because they
don't have the eval bar
um and from the practical point of view
once again if you're not losing on the
spot right so maybe this this decision
is justified
right so a4
and after king g7
this is this is where we stand
where dingley wren is on the clock down
by about 15 minutes roughly just under
30 minutes
but i'm not so sure once again this is
so easy like
you were telling me that the computer
well of course
he loves the material advantage at times
so um
how are you going to continue there
you're not going to take on d4 because
then you will lose the e4 bomb because
i'll take rook d4 and yeah we'll just
show that real quick if you take black
is going to take with the rook
e4 is going to fall black will then have
two pawns for the exchange and look at
this bishop this powerful bishop on b7
and stuff yeah you don't want to play f3
because this will leave all your dark
squares very weak so the moment you're
playing pause in front of your king and
your opponent has a couple of bishops
you got problems so okay let's see so
we're not going to see knight takes d4
it's very hard to find a move here i
mean
what i like about bishop b5 once again
that you cannot play rook c7
it's uh it's a very subtle move so you
keep well you take the control of the
dark squares but you also
uh
control the c7 square and the rooks
cannot invade the seventh rank
yeah
and what is this bishop doing on b5
this is this is such a good piece you're
right hits this defends this the dark
squares are unchallenged the bishop on
b5 feels awkward
it's funny the computer still loves
white the computers are smart enough now
to understand dynamic pressure so there
must be some approach here for white to
kind of maintain the balance with the
material edge or the computer would
already be saying black is better i
don't see many good moves for white
though it's really hard let's say like
the very direct approach something which
looks completely um dangerous but
f4
then yes
we will just show the danger
in one move like i probably take only
two queen a two i can take on d1 take on
f4 i was gonna say you just take right
away i know i wanted to take one g1 okay
take anyone because you don't want the
trade that way you want to take care and
then take okay and let's have a look at
this position now this is a total
disaster
so you you cannot proceed in this way so
bishop
is staying on e5
yeah
all right
well
i'm gonna i'm gonna check what the
engine thinks beforehand rather than
afterwards on a rare occasion because i
want to understand what's going on here
so as we look up okay look at this
engine suggested move what what i cannot
see king of one
king of one
and
maybe from a tactical perspective it's
just getting the king off of
checks
but that should tell you how hard the
position is so that that explains
everybody why
what we're doing is talking about
rapport's pressure reports sacrifice
reports you know dynamic feel for the
game right even though the email bar
says that dingley ren is better
that's just such a hard move to play to
avoid the tactics that are that are
coming and
king of one
you know i guess the point is that it
just like now it's like you know
if you do this i can take these yes
maybe you can take the rook if you make
some other move maybe i'm just slowly
untying my pieces play like queen e3
you can even consider things like f4
when the king is out of check
maybe not right away but
knight is no longer taking e2 a check
that's sort of the point so
okay if dingley wren finds king f1
i just by the way
if he doesn't fight such a computer
movement
but if he doesn't find king of one we
might be talking about dingley wren
potentially losing
his second game with white in the
tournament again he has a huge advantage
here computers say so mathematically but
from a practical point of view
i agree with you this is so much easier
for black to play
so what a story that would be if okay
one it would prove my vote my vote uh
using the the chess.com vote tool wrong
so i'd be greatly disappointed in that
let's consider the real issue here
my prediction
um but for dingley renault mira that
might be his candidates tournament i
mean you don't want to call things early
but if you lose with white twice
before the first rest day
i
i don't think you win the candidates
tournament like
you're just calling it you know
so this is
this is it then this is the critical
position of the game
and
[Music]
yeah you saw him just make that sort of
uh
shuffle there in his chair and kind of
look over his expression was with that
of frustration
what move are we now on like in on the
game oh because he's he has only 24
minutes left yeah it's moved 21. so he
still has 18 moves to make
and he has this position
19 moves to make i'm sorry 19 moves to
me he hasn't even made move 22 yet so um
yeah this is this is why you just saw
him sort of you saw right there he just
glanced over at the clock right there
right
he's uh
man
he's visibly showing his frustration
which is just not the dingly wren that i
mean you and i were talking in in the
first round despite ultimately losing to
yonda panda she just had what a cool
cucumber he looked like is it cool
cucumber or cool yeah cool cucumber i
think well as a i don't know a cool
cucumber no but the thing is so it's not
that i had this feeling that it's not
easy so as you can see that
well the top seeded player in the event
like one of the strongest players in the
world
is looking for a solution here yep
okay let's have let's get back maybe to
um
nakamura if we all have a chance after
this game so yeah we will for sure i
think i think we're probably going to
head out to our bird's eye view when we
can take a look at all three games
and uh have a super quick break before
we dive likely likely fully back into
fruit nakamura so maybe not quite yet
but but soon we will um before we do
that i want to remind everybody
that the chess.com global championship
our first shout out to our biggest event
ever of the day
open qualifiers are going down every
saturday and sunday through july 31st be
a part of history on chess.com it's our
largest tournament you can go to
go.chess.com cgc 2022
become verified sign up to play for cash
prizes and of course you'll be playing
in an event that you'll get to say you
play in the same event as
massive massive superstars the best
chess players in the world
joining at the round of 64. uh 32 of
them directly invited so
as we said these are the four matchups
of this round one of those games is
already in the books that was the draw
there in your lower left
but we're going to take a very short
break when we come back our matches are
pushing into the time control period
that means the pace for round three of
the 2022 candidates is going to heat up
so don't go anywhere we'll be right back
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing the
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chest puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kit helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kit is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
stranger to the candidates fabiano
caruana stands as a pretty popular
choice for winning it all here in madrid
fabi won this prestigious tournament
four years ago in berlin
in his challenger match against magnus
carlson caruana came just one end-game
moment away from his first world
championship
i wasn't
wasn't playing my best chest today and
buying this so
i think played
played very well
soon to be 30 karwana's chess resume is
matched by few in madrid
born in miami with dual citizenship fabi
became the youngest grand master in u.s
history at age 14.
a decade ago he made history at the
sinkfield cup
winning seven straight games on his way
to a 2844 rating the third highest of
all time
precise calculation and deep knowledge
of opening theory are fabi's calling
cards the italian-american used both to
great effect in the fide grand swiss to
qualify for this event
caruana now aims to become the first
player since vishy anand to win the
candidates in non-consecutive years
but perhaps more importantly fabi looks
towards another shot at the world title
this club is called amigos del retiro
friends of the retiro the retiro is uh
the most big and important park in
madrid it's a very important park in the
city because it's right in the center if
you want to play chess you don't know
the place this is a
maybe best one in madrid
a
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chess or mini
chess variants and with any starting
position you want
club arenas are the most flexible
tournament format on chess.com try one
out today
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years
spain's capital plays host to the
candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
[Music]
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
miss amigos
we are back here in madrid i see chad
loving the miss amigos and uh my friends
that is el rotiro beautiful park
where lots of chess is playing i think
elmira and i might take a visit to el
ratiere on one of these break days maybe
we throw down in some chess who knows
all i know is that guy's throwing down
right now on the board ali reza ferrugia
has so far been playing
kind of the game of the day although
miss amigos dingley wren found king of
one i saw chad go nuts for that that was
hilarious anyway i am here with elmira
scripchenko international master danny
ranch
we are we are really just beginning what
is about to be an epic journey here in
madrid i know it's day three we're
looking for the rest day i see you
saying danny i'm exhausted with your
face i get it i know what you're telling
me but we're really just beginning and
we have a lot of fun ahead
well we need some fresh blood you know
robert robert we're
the already winning
us are holding it down promise to me
that robert is going to be here you know
he's coming robert is robert is on a
plane
but king f1 like king of two king of one
you know something we were talking about
by the way this has been an awesome
addition speaking of the man dingley
wren coming back the chat went nuts they
love their man dingley wren we said this
is an move humans don't find it
and he found king of one it was wild we
see hikaru also trying to find as many
engine moves as he can for the rest of
the day because this is going to be a
tough end game to hold
and uh so this is our mothership
we have so many screens like so many i
know this is this is uh we're surrounded
by technology it's a little bit bright
under these lights anyway uh dingley red
right there i know we we we're going to
get more into of course the uh for roger
nakamura match don't worry but we had to
come back to this one because the hype
was real dingley
it's funny we didn't cheat elmira for a
really long time we were looking at the
position not wanting to see why the
engine thought white was better because
we were having trouble playing any moves
and then i turned it on because we had
to find complete information to not
leave people hanging and we're like okay
there's no way he's going to find this
super weird looking move but turns out
dingley wren is maybe more machine than
man
i'm absolutely stunned once again this
is such a difficult move that's what i
was trying to tell like hikaru he found
king of two so king of fun you know
these are the squares the the mysterious
team is used to be mysterious
yeah so um but is it all over now okay
let's say he
he found a very difficult move king of
one
uh
what is the threat
that is a very good question
once again do you want to i'm not sure
it's funny because you know we said how
black has all these pieces on optimal
squares i think that's also part of the
problem is i don't see a way for black
to improve his position without risk too
and king f1
kind of exposes that right it's a really
subtle move that says hey like if you
just show everybody if you start making
trades okay well actually that move you
can't even make a natural trade but if
you
you know if you make some sort of random
move white will slowly start to untie
queen e3 gets off of the file it
threatens to take the knight it
threatens h6 check
if you do a6 you know you're trying to
attack the bishop
okay the computer believes there must be
some there must be some move that king
f1 is also threatening that we were
why would well first of all you cannot
then pin once again because knight two
is no longer possible so it means that
maybe you can well you can do something
i remember when we looked at king of one
elmira that it was i don't have it in
front of me anymore not looking but the
computer was suggesting queen e7 i think
i just figured out why oh crazy because
there's a threat i didn't realize that's
the threat okay rook c4 of course and
then that makes sense as to why king f1
is actually really strong because you
remove the check
so that's
it suddenly all makes sense
king of one threatens rook to c4 that's
the idea
so does it force black to play queen
seven
and then you get off
okay and each six is even
possible on the next move okay queen is
three
alberta
we
we need to get over to the caro game
he's getting low on time really okay
let's have a look i think we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna back this thing
up
and uh also remind everybody of time
control in the process so great great
cue there from the production team
because 60 minutes are added after move
40. but guess what you got to reach move
40 first and hikaru nakamura is in a bit
of a tough spot over here
against aldi reza faruja and the
position is getting sharper and sharper
but how did they trade the rooks
we're going to find out we are
definitely going to find out how they
traded the rooks in a minute but let's
let's let's evaluate this position first
before we dive into analysis because are
we are we moments away from perugia
getting his first victory at the
candidates this is
first of all the last move probably was
bishop d8 and he's trying to fix black
spawn
even if black plays a4 he still has the
possibility to play b4 and to make this
breakthrough if you take on b4 play 3 or
c3 so the king maybe cannot move away
from those bones
yeah
but but a4 is not a move you want to
play when
your opponent has a dark square bishop
because even i don't know if this is the
best but even like this okay yeah
compute this is like
now you're just stuck right your pawns
are completely frozen
on light squares and but on the other
hand you're losing the palm
what do you do you have to play a4
yeah i guess that's why he i guess
that's why he looks so frustrated
because
what you're saying is you if you if
if you don't put your pawns on light
squares you lose a pawn and i simply
come back bishop d2 and i'll protect all
my panels and i'll bring my king and
this is an absolutely winning end game
so a4 is forced
yeah ikaru
he is
and it's very important that the knight
is staying close to the f4 square so he
can play knight to four and ninja to
keep the pounds from advancing g5 juice
you have to keep the knight over here to
help
um so a4 let's have a look let's say he
has to and then let's say for rouge is
going to play bishop a5 no i was
thinking about the immediate g5 that's
why i was yes just bush let's say okay
how do you
because if you play knight the f4 then
i'll play king of seven because we
that's what i wanted to say if you play
knight f4 i will bring my king you know
king c2
and then king c3 came before okay but i
want to highlight that because that's a
super instructive point that almira is
making if this knight says hey i'm going
to help out
the knight no longer holds the blockade
so principle of two weaknesses is a very
important principle when it comes to
converting end games and game advantages
which is don't ever get focused on just
one advantage focus on the other side of
the board
and that's actually that's actually just
that's it right that's just like mind
blowing that that's the problem so that
was a really important point
so g5 as elmira said oh sorry so it's
black
g5 as elmira said probably has to be met
by king of seven because if the knight
moves
it's over
and once again even if you're well
keeping my bounds from advancing like
even king g6 and if i move my um my
bishop you cannot take on g5 i will
always play h7 okay so you're getting
this kind of i'm going to show that
point real quick because what amir is
saying here is that these connected past
pawns are a huge event even if you put
this bishop
on a on a random square this isn't even
what you want but just to prove the
point
you can't take the pawn because the
moment you do this pawn is gone and
that's what happens when you have two
connected passers is this pawn is
actually never hanging
and and uh
he carries about to get under five
minutes
look at that view of the clock
five seconds and he's under five minutes
remember no increment for him elmira
this is real time pressure danny i was
thinking but then if this is true with
the bounce on g5 and h6 maybe he can
push
h7 g6 now and get to this master g5 king
f7 can i play h7 and then g6 maybe i'm
losing everything here i'm not sure is
this some kind of took song
i was worried over your bishops yes this
was my thread okay this is huge i
managed to trick you but i'm not sure
maybe this is losing all the pounds so
these are all the reasons why we're
seeing a very very distraught hikaru
right now he's focused
not not dejected yet i would say he's
not like you know
but but you know you know he's looking
at positions like this because what what
we're seeing is that you can't take the
pawn because of the queen you can't even
move the knight to go get the pawns
because bishop f6 check sacrificing to
get a queen
so you're essentially
frozen to the king side
but unlike elsa you can't let it go when
you're frozen okay and the thing is like
did you get that disney reference oh god
you know my kids were killing me
this one
but and now i was thinking so in the
like
this is my um like imaginary like
position you know this is the position
which i would like to get and bring my
king
so is it possible now that i bring my
king to e5
somehow well not even that like you
don't need to because you can't you
can't keep me out the whole time like
you're you're completely frozen
you're your knight can't move because of
bishop of six
so white has
i mean i don't care how long the journey
is eventually no you still can't play
like king h8 king g7 this is like your
possibility so if this king gets to h5
then there's gonna be threats
actually it's funny because even there
if you get check and check
it's not so clear so okay hicary looks
like he was about to play pawn to a4
unfortunately for him regarding how
regardless of how tough the position is
what's even tougher for hikaru is that
he now has less than three minutes on
the clock you see ali reza purusha
pacing like a shark in the background
great whites like to circle their prey
before they before they eat their the
fish right great white sharks
and ali raza purusha is uh
what is it donna
donna
da
and just like that
we've made a jaws reference that you did
not see coming on a chess broadcast
check that one off on my bucket list
for how many years have you planned have
you been playing on this one like most
things that come out of my mouth it took
like zero uh zero thought i don't
usually think about it so it was just
impromptu
uh but a4 was played i expect g5 to come
from ali reza he plays it
basically faster than i can say it and
uh
you know again if there's one person who
i look at who could lose with black and
i'm not going to count them out at all
it's takara nakamura he's already shown
he can bounce back but really this is
about ali rasa for ruja getting his
first victory at the candidates
and uh showing why showing why people
fear him and what victory would it be
this game is
absolutely incredible just sacrifice a
piece
then a hikaru transposes it to it well
to a complicated endgame
and
well
ferruja knows well he simply knew all
the plants i think
yeah he knew
so h7 king g7 g6 we like we analyzed
this like i don't think that
there is anything else in this position
i don't think you can do any i mean this
is we might be watching the beginning
the beginning of a historic run if the
youngest player in the field also
becomes
uh the number one player in the field at
the end of the tournament uh this this
would be a victory that catapulted his
his uh path to getting there not over
yet still some opportunities to maybe
miss evaluated defense but the more we
look at it i like almira's line i'm
going to show it again h7 king g7 g6
let's say let's say you just kind of
play fiddle like this no but i wanted to
bring the king just yeah no
and and i'm just showing that like even
if you just you know kind of sit tight
like
you can't really do it do i move the
bishop first i don't know i mean or do i
well i didn't think about it i just
really okay what happens if i play can
get two
if you just run yes
oh okay you can't let your knight have
force before okay
but okay what about what about king to
e1
king one
yes and then king g7 and then
the reason i want bishop g5 by the way
so just to go back was because it guards
f4 and you still can't move the knight
so if we want to do that earlier maybe
that's a little more accurate now i can
play king e2 and it's faster than going
king e1 so yes so that was my idea but
then
wait wait wait but then
maybe we could use the this moment to
play before maybe that's the last moment
like when your king is on f3
they're even here
well it's
farther from the sea pond like before
and i want to play c3 but
i love it just to show just to well
but maybe this is still
it's still winning somehow i don't know
how
so how is it winning
ah you bring your bishop to deforest
check probably maybe oh yeah like or
even
e5 like okay yeah this is it or or you
can go to d4 like you said oh no but
that would allow this okay
but if you play here you're winning
okay by the way guess what we have on
the board h7 ali reza ferrugia is a man
on a mission and
wherever he wherever he got some of this
helpful prep from and maybe it's all him
maybe he's just on a solo adventure one
man one cheese one pizza one night
sometimes you order a pizza for yourself
and one year older and one year older
have you ever ever eaten a whole pizza
by yourself on a night i don't think so
okay well then that makes only one of us
um but he is on a solo adventure right
now
well but i do have a strange habit like
because like the peak of my intellectual
activity sometimes it's like about two
or three a.m
so like i'm making well i make myself an
omelette oh really yes wow
you and i lead very different lives
i am in bed at two or three am or i am
an unhappy guy i will tell you that um i
i go to bed at 9 00 p.m
you know wake up at the crack of noon
ah no kidding look at this c3 c3 look at
that counter play i actually wait and
ricardo stood up from the board like he
okay wait hold the phone everybody we
were anointing ferugia but something has
gone wrong here
holy bejeezer snaps wait a second
we went for this line and we were
predicting it
g6 but
but the advantage was maybe bigger but
okay hold on c3 what's the idea he's
trying to get everything off the board
as quickly as he can
you know amir i have to highlight
something or my my normal commentator
partner in crime will yell at me we have
to we have to think very macro about
this and point out one thing if somehow
these pawns get traded and this knight
can sacrifice itself for both pawns this
bishop is the wrong color corner of the
a pawn
so
what that means everybody if you imagine
all the pieces off the board and white
has a full piece advantage and a pawn if
this king makes it to the corner it's
actually a draw so
so c3 is has an outside shot at
at like just a show like so take take
shake and bake you bring the knife back
and if and if somehow you know you find
yourself okay you can't do it because as
we've established
this wins
king moves we get a queen you can't
allow this check but if you could find a
way to get rid of these pawns you might
actually still have drawing chances if
you're hikaru
like
like how
oh wait that allows 904
oh god look what have i seen there on
this screen oh my gosh what has you done
vic that is a subscriber alert that i
was not ready for
like i saw yon's face frowning at me
earlier but they changed it out i i can
defend myself about that video if you'd
like an explanation
for that i will only do it if it comes
back again
but well i was all i wanted to know like
that was the last move of the time
control
oh
i think we need to back up to the bird's
eye view because um
[Music]
it makes me wonder as exciting as this
game is and we don't want to leave it is
what's going on
in the other games there it is yeah as
far as time goes
um
[Music]
caruana and duda have not reached time
control so that's one we could check on
um
and report and dean have also yeah this
is the game this is the game i mean
report report and ding are
are engaged in a battle
to the death and they still have 18
moves to make and that's not so much
time to do it i somehow suspected that
um richard will go for this line because
let's say i wanted to show you that if
knight is too quincy like let's say like
a little bit big then queen e4 you want
well somehow to well you want to take on
g2 i just want to take and if i take
queen g2
where do you go then queen g1
maybe it's not the perfect square then
like to give something like bishop
before
so you're running for your life you see
i just wanted to
show bishop e4
now
or maybe queen of two first then bishop
before but you know it's not so easy
once again even if you have this those
two rooks
well obviously ding agreed with you or
he would have gone for this but
i'm kind of surprised by okay that we
just saw it again so
that was a video i made for tick tock
not too long ago
do you tic talk you don't social media
no okay so
there we go we've got another resub
there and john likes it all right well
shout out to all of our youtubers you
cannot influence me you know that's
similar take this
on social media just yet unfortunately
that would be a bad thing for society
not because of you but because
one more person not using social media
is one more good thing happening in this
world but in all jokes aside thank you
to all of our subscribers we do
appreciate your support really i have
not made a call to subscribers and thank
them in too long i feel ashamed
that is
my god those crazy alerts just got me
back in my body we really appreciate it
you're subscribing really helps support
the shows it makes this thing happen and
we we do appreciate the love and support
so it means a lot
um
and now and now you get entertained
every time you do it with the new the
new gif alerts that the team has come up
with so
all right
but then okay let's say dink he didn't
go for the complications he he went for
queenie two
okay now i see this
queen e2 let's say i'll take on d1 and
why i cannot take uh ah because he will
play f f3 so rook d1 okay rookie one
rook two one i cannot take on e4 because
with the bishop
because he will probably play f3
just to show you
this this might be about to get nutty we
might almost have to say i don't want to
disable it because we love the support
and you're all amazing the hype train is
real
all of the subscribers but um
you are distracting us from very serious
feeding candidates chess right now
chess.com focus on the feeding
candidates look at this move elmira good
call wins a bishop okay so you cannot
win this phone
then
let's have a look
okay so yeah you can't let's rewind so
here
yep
is this so easy this one okay rook to
seven is coming your way as well so
and
maybe not immediately i will have queen
bee one i don't
i have to find
a useful move here
i don't know elmira the more this game
goes the more i'm feeling a four for
four day
predictions i need hikaru to hold a draw
if i'm gonna go four for four on my day
today
um and i cannot play bishop d4 because
you will play queen c4
but queen e4 also doesn't work right
not because of that but because no
because you simply take and then take
one followed by f3 we win a piece
uh so rook d1 has been played
and once again yes you have to make a
useful move here so uh
by the way we skipped past it because we
i was distracted by the by the
subscribers but i i meant to argue with
with you you know we love a good
argument i meant to argue with you that
he i think i think he might regret this
by the way i know how scary that was but
i'm
i'm wondering that that he doesn't that
ding lee wren doesn't miss his chance to
win this game because
i feel you and it's scary but it's but
it's not winning
right
well it looks scary of course but there
are like here you have so many checks to
worry about in the time trouble that's
one it's a very important factor
okay i get it yeah it's the more i look
at it and the more i see how pesky this
bishop is on the dark squares
what a fascinating position you're down
an exchange and a rook but you're right
this is this is hard to play and and
despite what uh
wow thank you for all the gifted subs
coming in seriously this this is awesome
we appreciate the love um
sorry get a little overwhelmed here um
a6 has been played on mira
a6
what can we can we take it it's a pawn
you know richard's games remind me like
of the
uh of korean series like you were
talking about horror movies on netflix
but i've been watching some of the
korean series and i think that they are
really the masters of how
of the scenarios you know whenever you
know you feel that how will it go
further this is richard game you know
you don't know which oh uh like it
doesn't listen to this
well
there are a lot of like korean select
nominees
they just
they are masters of uh
of writing you know the scenarios of
like of keeping the drama alive so i
think like okay how will go further hope
they knock off the character of the
series and you know they push someone on
the cliff you know so that's richard
games 94 92 86
so the point is every time
every time something dramatic happens
yeah i get it and
that's what he just did i guess he
sacrificed the queen side pawn in order
to take e4
what's funny is he doesn't want to take
this pawn with the pawn because that
would
that would bust a lot of things open but
but at some point if the king isn't if
the king is not going to come under fire
i mean you can consider taking this pawn
there's not a lot of pieces on the board
anymore right
let's see first of all okay let's take
on g6 take on g6
because i'm afraid of losing this pawn
he might play queen h4 and can you take
uh ah if you take on b6 i take on a4 is
this the plan
yeah this is this is going to be a draw
okay so this is
something to avoid of course
um
what do you do here
or maybe we can keep the pawn on h5 but
i'm
i don't like
queen h4 there so maybe it doesn't
matter
[Music]
we need to maybe as far as move numbers
go just reminding you we still have a
pretty long way to go to move 40.
uh we're on move 26.
so just
there's there's time right 14 minutes
for 14 moves but it's not an eternity
for dingley wren so he has to he has to
be focused
don't let this time pressure get worse
so can we play queen e2 or k1 you know
there are several moves
i know a lot of people are are yelling
at us still i mean we know farouz and
nakamura are playing we're not hiding
under a rock but just so you know
perugia has not moved since ecaro c3 so
we're not missing anything in that game
at this point remember you can go to
chess.com events open up the games on
your own choose your own adventure if
you're ever unhappy with uh our choice
but we are very aware of the three games
still going the fobby game too is
i was so excited when i saw my english
attack but it i wonder what happened
there i'll catch up catch up with bob
when
when we can um get him to tell me more
than he should but i've been getting him
to do that for a while but it says it's
now it's a very interesting end game
you play the f4
you have this powerful knight on c5
yeah
and if i'll manage to push a4 a3 then i
will sacrifice it on b3
like that so but okay it's some
long-term
plans for those who'd like to we'll
we'll do it was one nod to the advanced
players in shadow mira was pointing out
an idea where
black has a4 and can sacrifice the
knight and the pawn might not be
stoppable
on the queen side there
likely not likely not something that
will happen but you've got to watch out
for it if you're carbona
and actually by playing f4
fabiana is trying to get some squares
for his king he wants to play king d4 so
it's important maybe not to take
one f4
young system do they still think and so
but maybe he can take play king d6 and
then
um
he played rookie one okay like
completely we have to go back to the
disney run
uh
richard report game because
i think we even played rookie one
doesn't look like he has a a totally
clear plan
on what to do here that
the rook goes to e1
okay that actually it stops black from
taking the pawn so you got to find a
safe square for the queen let's
just say you move the queen somewhere oh
but well okay but then now then you can
take i think queen d4
yes
you need to protect your bishop
and to protect the pawn at the same time
so what can you do here
queen b5 maybe
danny let's try queen b5 and then you
can simply move your bishop somewhere
like f6 knight f6 yes maybe bishop d6
bishop c5 is also a very nice sight i
changed my mind as soon as i almost did
that i think both are fine but bishop d6
bishop c5 actually looks
it's a spice you know
looks very dangerous to me so you
well black
certainly can hold this position
so maybe it's not all over it
no i think actually it was a very
resourceful uh def i i told you i
thought that maybe dingley red would
regret queen takes d8 i understand i
mean we i agree it was a hard thing to
go for but
this just doesn't if this bishop gets to
c5
and these pawns are traded we already
said you had a pawn for the exchange so
again the math is four versus five which
is
you know at that point it's just just a
single point but in reality the bishop
is is a very good piece it's gonna be
very hard for white to win
he plays queen d4 by the way amira
predicts it
again yes but it's all over it i don't
want to lose my bishop or my father's
probably the only move in the position
you know there's nothing
like surprising about it
it's like when you're defending um
you're doing so great today you're all
over it
i see a lot of love for you in chat by
the way
elmira is a great commentator
thank you so much like
a great singer
kidding that was that was from me we're
talking about maybe karaoke on the rest
day because almira likes to sing
well
we have a date
karaoke yes we are going to sing
we don't know that it that it exists yet
in madrid i'm sure they have a karaoke
bar
i'm sure they do does the robert sing
robert actually like contrary to what
you may not know everybody robert robert
is an aficionado of modern pop music he
knows like every like
like the other day i heard him singing
driver's license by olivia rodrigo you
know that song like i'm like what are
you singing he's like that's driver's
license you ever heard that so he yeah
robert actually does like to sing he's
more of a bathroom singer doesn't want
anyone to know well i am sort of a
shower singer yeah exactly
all right so queenie two is played the
bishop is on pre that means it's
attacked you gotta find a safe square
queenie um is better than queen b5 okay
understand because you might um
tickle the queen by playing rogue d1 if
bishop d6 then rook d1
yeah okay
so um
then
bishop f6
yeah bishop f6 now right rather than d6
i'm a bit afraid so let's see bishop d6
if you want to play bishop c5 but then i
will play let's try it bishop d6 bishop
d6 and then rogue d1
i don't know i don't know what's
happening but that's what i was planning
anyways seems more problematic
because one thing to note on here is if
the queens if the queens are traded
before yes this is the the queen side
has been simplified i think that could
be risky right like takes takes and now
this is absolutely lost yeah totally
because you can no the thing is that
whenever you will keep your bishop on c5
i will find a way to play
and you cannot keep it on this diagonal
since this
this is absolutely lost so to visualize
everybody even if the bishop gets here
the rook is you know on c7 or c6 or
something and then you can play a5
because the pawn can't capture so
this is and it's very important that you
cannot play bishop d4 so like frog d7 is
fine and then i will bring my king so
yeah so rook d7 can you two get this of
course this is going to be losing um
and another yeah another way that a5
occurs is when the king is over here
eventually you play a5 the bishop will
be undermined so
so report cannot just simplify
the queen's off the board just yet he's
got it he's got to make this position a
little easier before he does
uh speaking of getting easier with every
move they inch closer to time control
which is going to add time back onto the
clock we still have not had a move for
russia watch
we still have not had a move in ferruja
nakamura so cool your jets as my mom
used to say you'd cool your jets mister
because that was her favorite phrase
somebody calm down cool your jets no you
know coming back to the game between
um you know because you said like uh
for reserve watch but there's like a
phrase from a game of thrones like pops
up to my mind it's like
from uh hikaru's perspective you say not
today so not
not today junior yeah no it's like
you're not going to die today you know
you're facing death but you know it's
like not today not today today okay
i thought it was more of a what is it
like a happy gilmore reference to today
junior or is that billy madison i get my
adam sandler confused all the time
uh so c3 but you know what i don't get
confused
what i'm going to be doing july 9th and
10th
tell me i'm going to be commentating on
blitz champs you know who's going to be
joining me
the one and only john urschel it's been
a while since we've seen our man urschel
on a chess.com show everyone if you
remember the show that john and i used
to do together long ago john herschel is
an nfl player former all-american for
his time at penn state uh he's also a
very strong chess player he and i will
be doing commentary for all of these
guys that are going to be playing in
blitz champs it's coming in july watch
your favorite nfl stars compete for
their share of a hundred thousand
dollars to charity like we said
legendary the legend larry fitzgerald is
playing in this event cleveland brown's
wide receiver amari cooper
uh the recent top five draft pick came
on thibodeau
linebacker micah parsons and there are
others too so make sure you tune in to
july 9th and 10th blitz champs it's the
first influencer streamer celebrity
event we've done really in a while since
last year's pogchamp so make sure you
tune in all right h takes g6 has been
played
h takes g6
h takes g6 take on g6 and well
once again
richard has to keep his queens on board
what it's very important yeah very
important
and then
i'm not so sure that
how easy it will be to win this position
with
white i really don't understand how how
are you improving this position
you know what though i just don't want
to exchange the queens let's say
well queen anywhere
um
queen
princess this is kind of a dingly run i
don't know the more i'm looking at this
here's i'm visualizing it like g3 i'll
put the king on g2
i'm gonna get my rook
somewhere
i'm i'm going to get it over here so you
bring your g7 yellow queen
e8 and some
but if i get to the seventh right i can
hit the b7 where i'm protected and now
you've got to defend the pawn
okay i'm not going to sit and wait i
know but but you don't have anything
really to do right the question is like
whenever like you leave like let's say i
will play quincy five here i have my
options of playing bishop d4 as well
and okay that's fair yeah if if if queen
c5 and bishop d4 that's a battery that's
irritating because if i ever leave with
the queen then maybe a4 becomes
vulnerable right
okay
once again
i really think that uh
this is going to be a draw now i think
ding's going to win
okay
it's not just because i predicted it i
think he's going to find a way to kind
of torture this one through
also if you're looking for a game to
find your form is there any game better
than like a grinded out victory where
like maybe it should have been a draw
but you pushed and pushed
played through
we've got ding we'll win this from a
twitch chatter so the uh twitch agrees
with me right now we'll see one person
did
okay game on game on you want a is a
but all right
i think dingley run is going to find a
way to grind it out and he's going to
find his form here in madrid and not not
go quietly into the night
um big ding for the win but what do we
have like at stake
we got to figure that out what's at
stake we'll figure i'm not i'm not i'm
not doing any cosplay i'm not dressed
i've lost too many bets with weird
cross-dressing things that i have to do
on the other side of it if danny says
ding will win then he will not thanks a
lot
devil dog sir
i'm not that bad at jinxing everybody um
but figure out what you want i mean we
can all i'll buy the first round for
karaoke you know okay we'll do that okay
so that that's the bet but i think
that's um more about being objective i
think so this position is not that easy
to win i think
like the worst is way behind
i agree
yeah you're right i'm i'm i'm
i'm excited about my man dingly wren
finding his form but you're making great
points and if this bishop comes here
again you have a really hard time so
i'll take the devil's advocate view to
my own prediction real quick to just
kind of add add the points that elmer's
making just
even though we could maybe fantasize
about the rook being on a square hitting
the b pawn and maybe the queen is even
on a square hitting f at the same time
coordinating this type of thing
when black is going to be super pesky
you know consistently trying to poke and
prod at white's king
okay now they will probably repeat
because he wants to reach the time
control so quincy one rookie one queen
z2 yeah because he's not going to take
the draw though he'll just repeat
a little bit but on the other hand you
know i wanted to to explain why dink
also didn't take queen d8 at the moment
like where he had to go for the
complications in order to win the game
it's just because
he lost his psychological psychology yes
psychologically like you know uh you
start to doubt your own ability to
calculate because he lost his first game
like yesterday he will he gave a very
interesting interview to dina he
explained that were some of the moves
that he didn't really
see
like
he said that his position was probably
worse that's what his own assessment so
at the end of the game against duda
so here like you have a safe choice of
play taking on it too or of going for
like wild complications so he's
simply like his confidence his
confidence
is really shaken so no it makes a lot i
think you're i think you're absolutely
right and it's
one of the reasons why again to add more
to that that point is why
i was saying like sometimes to get back
on forum you need a grind it out victory
that maybe you shouldn't have won but
it's like that
the labor part of chess you know where
you just put in the time you get your
opponent or time pressure you do
everything you can because you just
won't be denied because sometimes going
for the slugfest right the tactical
melee it's just not something you can do
to pull yourself out of a hole right you
don't have the guts right it's too it's
too scary so
that's why i'm kind of you know rooting
rooting for it i i i love i love richard
so i'm not rooting for either player but
i'm
i'm rooting for uh for a push here and i
think if dingley wren finds his form
it's it's an interesting interesting
storyline of course so more drama
yep
reports says i don't want that drama in
my life thank you mary j
thank you mary j blige that's a song we
could sing karaoke no more drama in my
life
report does not want the drama in his
life he wants a draw in this game not
drama
um chad loves the drama they said i made
a bad bet because the bet was danny buys
the drinks no the clarify
either i buy the drinks or she does
that's the bet so maybe i said it wrong
but the drinks are the bet
um but can i also add to this one that i
can choose one song for you to sing okay
okay that's like slight deal okay that's
uh that's the most important thing
um
that makes sense some madonna songs like
are coming your way yeah what what i
wonder what chat thinks what what they
uh what they think is gonna happen in
the game what they think that song will
be
that that almira is going to pick for me
okay you want chat to pick the song
okay let's uh let's get well could they
yeah okay chad pick a song that's the
okay that's going to be the bet so but i
want to be for both sides that's to be
fair okay so chad picks a song that you
have to sing and a song that i have to
say so are they going to vote like how
how are we proceeding we'll have to
figure that out right and we'll we'll
have to be safe and all the things that
might be to the second rest day we'll
give it some time we're going to be in
madrid for a long bleep in time okay so
we will make this karaoke thing happen
chat you're going to pick a song oh gms
hey robert did you see i outed you for
singing driver's license earlier
l-o-l-l-l if you sing britney if you
make me sing britney spears you will be
entertained okay okay britney spears is
very nice
all right um
i just wanted to make fun of robert
every chance i get i love when he's here
okay zing is
thinking you know he's thinking he's
getting down under time pressure by the
way we we're sitting here talking about
ding can't really lose this game but i i
think this is a big moment where he
might get so nervous no he does okay
good yes let's go dingly wren i don't
want to sing britney spears we want we
want elmira to sing what is it justin
bieber i'm seeing suggested we'll see um
oh no there we go i think we're finding
elmira's kryptonite
i was i was what i was about to say is
with time pressure approaching ding's
lack of confidence we've been talking
about i was worried we were going to see
that sort of old-fashioned draw offer
with the repetition but no he plays g3
he's going to put the king so here's my
here's the way i'm visualizing this g3
king on g2
if i can pull that off and and at the
right time put my queen on f4 the reason
i like that square forget where the
black piece are now is because i'm
guarding the a pawn
and i'm hitting the f pawn
if i get
that position and my rook is free to
roam that's the position i'm visualizing
for the win but bishop d4 exactly right
but now here comes rookie two like queen
g1 and then and then king g2 okay bishop
c5
right
so it's going to take some time maybe i
play queen f3 first
right wait wait wait wait no no no wait
bishop d4
queen d1 can i take one a4
wait you cannot
oh well you play queenie two because
rook do you like rookie two queens one
and they could say
this is a good line to show
this was this was the problem not even
bishop c5 because maybe it allowed like
25 okay so so dingley run plays queen e2
but it does it doesn't change
okay but now where does where does
report go the problem is can he can he
put pressure on the pawn and then you
just don't have time
can i go queen before
queen b4 yeah that's what i was
highlighting yeah i think i think you
can and i think
now i have travel
okay
between
c2 to protect the bone but yeah i like
this one
you protect the pawn
threaten rookie four but it's not really
a threat because remember now my bishop
is on d4 like i'm not forced to play
bishop c5 maybe i can play e5
you know it's it's such like
such a nice square for the bishop on d4
and whenever you will threaten to um
to play let's say rook c7 or
rook d7 i will play bishop c5 bishop d4
you're just gonna
i mean you open up more squares so you
know kind of long-term defense maybe you
don't want to but elmira's point is
now the bishop can be protected and
block the d file and then if i try to
switch to the c file you go there and
block so
yeah it's maybe this is the way to hold
yep
trying to set up the perfect way to hold
ding is trying to think
of the perfect song to sing i mean the
perfect move to make
um
[Music]
he's still thinking you know so maybe
that's not so obvious
six more moves to make he has three
minutes for we
man quincy
is there a chance we see dingley brent
blunder in this time pressure and and
and something really crazy happened the
problem is it would have to be the
blunder of the most epic proportions to
create losing chances
i don't think i don't think we'll see
that but
but boy does he want more time on his
clock he just wants to get to a position
that hasn't changed too much but he has
an hour to think about it so he's got to
reach move 40 to get more time
again farouza has not moved against
akara nakamura
queen c3 is on the board i think
what yeah since c3 so again hikaru
played c3 we got 28 000 of you i know
people are anxious i'm just on twitch
more than 10 000 of you on youtube hi
everybody i love you i love you
i love you
um
no i was i was actually talking about
this game because i'm looking at the
image and the queen is on c3
in life yes okay so in our analysis
position
hikaru is still pacing by the way
farouza hasn't moved
in more than more than 30 minutes i
think
yeah
he is a he is a focused boy right now
yup man 19 years of age
he would say he would say i'm not a boy
19 years of age he would be right but
all right here we go we got action
dingley run plays work to d one he has
one
he's got one minute and 23 seconds
everybody so e5 is the very natural no
what do you think danny
it doesn't matter if the queen is on c3
or
b4 e5 and
stabilizes the position i i feel that
it's a very important move to make here
sorry yeah
agreeing and
focused waiting so queen to c6 ha
that's a checkmate threat on h1 ladies
and gentlemen don't you miss that
it's also an irritating time pressure
move to play look at that wait a second
then
dingley wren is like you dirty dog way
to get more time off my clock
does it mean he can win the a4 pound
okay queen g4
queen g4 laughs in the face of danger
he'll bring his king to e2 thank you
very much
maybe five now okay that's yes
report is is
okay that's a bailout move okay so he's
going for a draw well ladies and
gentlemen okay darn it smarted i'm
singing something okay now it's time to
get serious chad you better pick a
decent song or we are gonna have issues
bring in the lawyers you know we're
excited
they have to agree that what you didn't
know is i already knew that chat would
never agree on a song so i will never
have to sing
chat will never agree
if they don't unanimously spam the same
thing then i shall no i'm kidding all
right uh it's a draw and wow did that
end anticlimactically or what just like
that
dingly wren says this time pressure is
too much for me
almiroskinko is right
no it's not even that i think he sensed
that the position was becoming dangerous
especially after this queen g4 e5 you
know like
a few moves you are going to lose your
a4 pawn you know if you cannot play king
g1 queen a4 is possible so um
rook d4 was simply necessary then yeah
no it's it's it's totally fair and we're
having a good time hope everyone is
having a good time too we're just having
some fun but no that was a really
instructive game
you know dingley wren had the chance
right we talked about it
the chance was all the way back in the
position
do you want to have a last like the last
glance at this position
just the last glance at this position
and again it's it's hard to qualify it
as a missed win because we understand
how hard that position was to play but
when dingley wren did not take on d8
with the queen
and uh well let's see quincy it once
again
yeah hold on i'm just given a second for
all of us to get caught up here we see
ferrugia has still not
moved after c3 from hicaro the karwana
judah and game is
moving along in an interesting way
caruana actually down a pawn now but
with a very active king so that's
fascinating but
yeah if we can if we can head back to
the uh the big board here we'll keep
farouza on cam but just want to bring up
the the big board and
show exactly what dingley wren may have
missed in the game again it was it was
not queen takes e2
that ultimately went to the end game we
saw where the exchange was simply
not enough to win it was right here
whether but i'm here to talk again about
the psychology the fact that dingley
wren just isn't feeling it right now
right so going for this crazy position
where
you know you might get mated
he's scared even though objectively
white has to be winning here there's
just but this is hard to play
maybe
okay yes bishop f4 is probably premature
before because you will have queen d4
check okay so yeah like i mean it's
scary but if you just like keep making
like forcing moves
eventually the checks run out this queen
is is coming back
okay you know we want to get back to
ferruccio's game with nakamura
we know dingley run drew but we didn't
have a look at the end game
between fabi and uh young sister
justin trudeau
i want to go back to this game though
real quick just to make sure that
we we give it the appreciation it is
because uh
it has been how long
already remember i told you that phobia
played the four he really wants some
squares for his king so
right now he sacrificed the pawn oh wait
you know my phobias again yes okay no
yeah we'll get there yeah um
all right so furuga still hasn't moved
and that's why fans we're gonna we're
gonna follow elmira's direction and head
over to caruana duda because i just
wanted to make sure we're checking in
because this is this is the matchup that
people are freaking out about and and
farouza may be struggling to find a
clear win or he wouldn't be thinking for
so long but all right i'm here take it
away so
just go back to f4 okay when he went i
think that's where we stopped here
okay f4 so what happened a4
you see you're forced to take here with
white because otherwise we're talking
about the idea yeah the dimension yes of
course so
uh he took
and then
a thematic clearance sacrifice if you
will
clearing the c4 square for the bishop
and once again maybe this was almost
forced because knight c392 was a threat
also oh that's interesting
knight c3 knight a2 this is this is one
of those it's like an in-game study
almost right where it's not even
necessarily a this is like a rescue
position
really struggling but c5 is the best way
to maintain the balance
well maybe that was not the strategy i
don't know like
it's it's a very complicated engine so
let's have a look c5
he wants to get some squares yes for his
king knight c5
bishop c4
you can't you can't give up the pawn so
you got to go f6
but then i take
which by the way this all makes sense as
to why
duda took here first
so there we go we we we've paid off paid
off the the debt of that line everybody
the reason duda took first is because
that's the only way to actually win the
pawn now no matter where the king goes
to guard this guy you take so
so that's why duda took
first and f4
and then took with the knight
and so now this is this is where we
stand
no now you can play king d4
okay we have the king and d4 and the
board and
so what to do here
can you play king g6 simply to protect
the knight
and bishop c4
and if you go here do i pop in
maybe then i can play g5 and okay maybe
it's still a draw i think i think we're
likely headed for a draw in this one i
don't know wait
g5 he'll take
you gotta wait no first after this take
and then push
okay my king is still in the square no
no
i was afraid
that you are going to
yeah
we're gonna we're gonna end up with a
draw both kings here
so now if you go here i go here
you go here
i think i can play king of six yeah but
why do i want to play f6
what when when i played bishop c4 maybe
you you assume can you play 96 check
maybe i don't know
okay there's not enough clearly not
enough material in this position yes i
mean before no no
f6 i don't like the move f6 can i play
96 here
okay i see
but you have to calculate you know
by the way this position is on the board
so elmira and i are currently analyzing
currently analyzing something that will
probably occur to be honest
maybe it's just a draw so king 4 knight
c5 king d4
i
i think it's a pretty decent chance
because i don't want to play f6 maybe
it's still a draw but okay f6 bishop f7
but this is this is going to be a draw
okay
justin bieber's
baby
is apparently what i'm singing
okay
uh okay well
i i'm trying to recall that song
yes like
i have like this we
we have our crew singing
the song for you
yeah you're excited about that song okay
i'm then i'm excited about it i guess um
so
perugia is what
i think this one's going to be a draw
ferruja's in the think tank that's going
to be the last game going and take us
take us home will
will the youngster
find a way to get the victory his first
victory in the candidates
or will karu hold we're going to find
out as round three for the 2022 feed a
candidates we are live from madrid
continues in a few
wanna play chess online or learn how to
improve join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
considered by most as the rising
superstar in chess alireza farouja makes
his candidates debut here in madrid
the only teenager in the tournament
furuja is the youngest player ever to
break the 2800 rating barrier
born in iran but representing france
farouza strikes fear in his opponents
with his array of surprising tactical
shots
alireza qualified for the candidates by
taking first place in the fide grand
swiss he also followed up that
performance with a strong finish at the
european team chess championship
coming in with heavy expectations
farouza has a more than reasonable
opportunity here to become the youngest
winner in candidates tournament history
[Music]
with that the teen prodigy would take
one step closer to potentially knocking
magnus carlsen off his championship
perch
[Music]
good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to the opening ceremony of
the world chess championship candidates
tournament
[Music]
hello
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
new zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botez gambits has alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com
insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
[Music]
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
look at that beautiful chess garden the
chess garden i visited that before the
tournament started almira
it was awesome there's a big old giant
chest you see the giant chessboard the
pieces aren't there but there's a
giant chessboard that's another thing we
could do we'll talk about karaoke we
could we could visit the chess park okay
and play a giant chess game
what do you think
game
game on okay i like that well you know
it's more more things to do on the rest
day
we are back inside the playing hall of
the beautiful palacio de santonia the
palace of santona
is home to the feeding candidates here
in 2022
welcome back to madrid everybody
international master danny wrench here
alongside almira scrubchenko almira this
has been an interesting day
here day three to say the least well
it's given me a headache all these end
games are giving me a headache you know
and i understand why i well ali rezai is
spending so much time because
even now this is still not very obvious
to me you know like
what are we supposed to do here it is
you're right and uh
the bella the bell and kaya miss amigos
hello friends
my friends all around the world uh hope
you hope you enjoy that i i never i
never get older the spanish guitar so
you guys might get tired of hearing my
voice just find a way to split the audio
and kill my voice and raise the guitar
up that thing is jamming
miss amigos um but okay you said it's
giving you headaches it's giving all the
reza a headache right now because
it's so funny so
hey car who played c3 and got up very
confidently at the time we weren't
really thinking about it right because
this this position has been headed
toward what we think is going to be a
win for farouja it looks very hard to
stop the kingside ponds
but
maybe hikaru sees something that the
rest of us don't that this is this is
not so easy because faroush is thinking
maybe there's a reason for that
so let's say
we take on c3 first like yeah and
obviously are we ready to yes
we need to
yeah i mean
i think there's a reason he's thinking i
think you're right i think we should
dive in here and just try to figure out
why is ferugia taking so long here in a
plan that we thought maybe was more
clear
it's not so simple so probably like half
of our audience is already asleep you
know
half the at the uh they're the audience
is not asleep we've got we've got a lot
of people tuning in everyone's excited
for this result this is the battle we've
all been waiting for can we just like
celebrate that farouza and nakamura are
finally playing over the board classical
chess um
okay we'll look at it b take c3 first
yes let's see what's wrong with b take
c3 why
knight takes e3 taking c2
that's just something very simple so
probably knight g5 but right
i understand that hikaru wants to keep
you know this option of playing b4 when
we will bring our like king to the
center so b4 and then a3 a2 something
like this yeah let's trade off the pawn
so let's see can we play king d3 here
immediately or well no not right away
because knight of four champions yes
once again so yeah like played this move
first i think okay like bishop g5 of
course
this is the line we looked at the last
time we were at the board which by the
way everyone was probably like 40
minutes ago because
ferocious been thinking but e5
oh i think i just realized one idea if
you play kd3 do i have knight f4 check
ah you mean i think i do because the
king and pawn a game is winning for
black
so you cannot say what a crazy idea
of course okay what a crazy idea and and
black is black is actually queening
so e5 actually
makes it hard on white to come forward
and if you play king d2 okay let's say
king d2 what can you do here
can you play uh
b4 here
because he cannot no i don't think you
can play before because you can't ever
take it because of knight f uh no but i
want yes bishop f6 is still at fit but
can i create uh
no
we need to i want to create another
press function let's change the live
position
which is still on the car wanna do the
game just so just so fans don't get mad
at us that the live position there we go
um
yeah now we've got
this analysis so continue you think you
can get away with beef no just to check
this one before a3 so how are we meaning
here like
okay we simply stopped the pound yes
like yeah just no no
even if you take it
i think if this if this counter play
disappears now my king
just
so this doesn't work okay let's see and
remind everybody again of the basic
tactic in case you weren't here what
happened if this knight is not guarding
f6 white is winning on the spot with
bishop f6 check and then you get a queen
so just never forget that tactic in the
back of your mind it's why the knight is
frozen on d5 in the center
so this doesn't work okay yeah b4
doesn't work
let's say uh what what
e4 okay that's another computer doesn't
like that either why i do not know like
man oh it's the same idea we saw before
there's the diagonal
ah you simply need to bring your bishop
not here
but like here and then you go slowly
okay but e3
where do you go now you can't go here or
here
because of knight f4 so i have to go
here okay king c2
yes this is probably winning as well but
how are you winning
um
before
okay you need to take
probably not yeah but i feel like all
these things are just kind of a matter
of you know i just got to get my king to
a safe square and
and i'm bringing the bishop to a
diagonal
can i go here
and then here well yes
or here
there is no way okay knight d3
and i still i still cannot go uh
i'm threatening bishop yes of course so
you can't go here to try to stop bishop
e1 because now we go back to this side
oops sorry sorry i moved my king first
but
apparently i was careless that shows you
how dangerous the zen game is i was
careless with one move and look at this
oh you can play king takes g6
that's the idea not the bishop so knight
d3 was possible or you no i didn't put
my king on the wrong square i think
knight d3 i i guess king d1 maybe yeah
king 21 no apparently that also fails oh
e2 check and then knight f4 okay so you
see so this is so the only winning move
is king c2
and then if the knight goes back i go i
guess i should have just gone to d1
right away okay so king c1 was just a
mistake it just allowed knight d3 but
king d1 works
but it's like a
it's a study actually this is a study
well it is a study and it also again
shows us why farouja has been studying
the board now for more than uh more than
a minute uh this is this is not an easy
position to play
and
again hikaru knew
that something was up when he played c3
and i think that you know we were we saw
a very focused kind of a nervous right a
very deep in think hikaru nakamura but
it wasn't like he was just twiddling his
thumbs there he was working super hard
right and it shows you that he that he
was thinking about something because as
soon as he played c3
he knew that perugia's work was cut out
for him so
all right well ollie richards got to
figure this out his work is cut out for
him and so we're going to let him think
about it and remind you again who this
rising star representing france is he
has a very bright future in classical
competitive chess and all kinds of chess
let's let's bring up our chess.com
profile once again
considered by most as the rising
superstar in chess alireza farouza makes
his candidates debut here in madrid
the only teenager in the tournament
furuja is the youngest player ever to
break the 2800 rating barrier
born in iran but representing france
farouza strikes fear in his opponents
with his array of surprising tactical
shots
alireza qualified for the candidates by
taking first place in the fide grand
swiss he also followed up that
performance with a strong finish at the
european team chess championship
in with heavy expectations farouza has a
more than reasonable opportunity here to
become the youngest winner in candidates
tournament history
[Music]
with that the teen prodigy would take
one step closer to potentially knocking
magnus carlsen off his championship
perch
will he knock will he knock magnus
carlson off his championship perch
who knows
it would be maybe similar to when
kasparov knocked off karpa from his
perch is that a comparison elmira well i
think it's a perfect comparison
um
well first of all do you remember danny
the first match gary kasparov played
against anatoly karpov
uh
because that was that was still the the
knight
yes okay yeah that was still the match
that would that was played according to
the ancient version yeah no that is it
is a match that every chess player
thinks about and goes what were they
doing that was it was a match that
lasted months it's insane go ahead yes
but that's because this was you know uh
well uh
we should probably talk a little bit
about the history of the world
championship matches because not always
they were played like only
like now we have 14 games you know
before they were talking about rapid tie
breaks
yes because before for example they were
playing uh till
well for the first one to win six games
and you know so uh it could last for
match four months so that was why this
match i think was stopped after six
months yep
and then they changed the rules but
that was it well well they had to change
so again uh and i see the chat coming in
yet the gary faces sorry everyone is
commenting on the gary face
so i just have to call it out yes we we
picked a pick of gary
we picked a
pick of pickled peppers for gary maybe
he's smelling pickled peppers and that's
why he looks like that uh but i'll
mirror no this is this it's crazy
that match six months
like let that sit in everybody a
six-month chess match one that had to be
stopped due to health concerns of
anatoly karpov um and there's all kinds
of stories about that that he was maybe
taking some substances to help himself
have energy that he shouldn't have been
or something like that and needed some
needed a break so that his
energy could
so how worthy you should be of this
title that's that was my you know my
question yes
and uh well we have another ferment
because modern chess is is really
getting even more physical than it was
before yeah
so
at the end of the day uh
the next challenger will play a match
against the world champion in a
games match
and then you will also have a tie break
because b4 of course
one well i think this is one one
important element why do we have a
tiebreak now because before the world
champion was simply keeping the title if
if the match was drawn
you know yes it's very different very
different yeah and by the by the way
elmira as of right now the the seconds
that just went by farouz has been
thinking about this move for one hour
an entire hour
i mean i know chess matches used to be
six months to decide the title but this
position
is uh is also grueling
because it's been an hour for ali reza
paruja
in deep deep thought and again he's
probably like what he's looking at right
now everybody is not even the chess
board that we see he's looking at the
matrix he's deep in code you've got
lines of green code and morpheus is
fighting neo
and uh you know he is the one suddenly
the code aligns and i don't remember
what happens next but
this
and the red queen
by the way where do you think a car
who's been for an hour chat
like can we get some
that's that's a fun time where do you
think hikaru has been for the last hour
there's a bar right around the corner
outside of the palacio de centonia i
will tell you that
um
or he's off eating lunch yeah yeah
um make a move
yeah hey carlo actually knows what no no
just us he's pulling his hair down you
said that make a move you were talking
about how like pulling your hair out
right and so you see you don't have to
have long hair to pull your hair out hey
cara could be eating lunch hikaru by the
way is a bit of a foodie for those who
don't know that about about mr nakamura
a friend of mine i've known him for a
very long time i remember he took me to
his favorite sushi spot last time we
were in florida you know the car's a bit
of a foodie he loves nice food places
loves the research loves figuring out
well
because you know that i manage a
restaurant so
he loves pineapple cocktails go ahead no
i'm just telling that
next time you're in paris like basically
that's why i've been uh
off from the chess tournaments i am
managing a restaurant so okay really
it's a guess
i didn't know that okay some more things
about almira we didn't know we're
learning about the players with our
player profiles
we're learning about elmira running a
restaurant someone just told him hey
buddy put down that pineapple cocktail
head on back to the board b takes c3 he
immediately plays knight take c3 and
he's up again
wandering about
he is he is a confident nakamura right
now
and uh
again
i'm
i'm just like really impressed right now
i don't know that he's gonna hold this
but it
it would seem the longer the engine
thinks elmira the closer that eval bar
is getting to equal
well i can see this of course but we
still didn't figure it out we we didn't
figure it out but but we don't have a
clear win in mind right now either
necessarily so king c2
okay i think that this game is going
yeah this game is getting closer and
closer to job we'll we'll stick right
here for the ending because
nakamura is going to take us home
this game is about to have
a handshake
in peace in t minus ten seconds
ten
nine
eight
seven i said ten seconds if you draw six
five come on make me make me write three
two oh they didn't offer just offer the
draw
okay
um but it's uh it's a draw
he just look at that a3 allows the fork
flight king c3 uh he makes him i was
gonna say do it the funny way favi come
on fob you'd be like danny that's the
stupidest bleep and bleep i've ever seen
all right well there you go uh
i am i am wrong on my prediction
yet again
at one point in this day elmira i
thought i was on pace for four for four
actually now i understand why we're not
allowed to wear a white on the show
oh yeah look at that you see yes
now of course when i have this image you
know we have clear instructions
of the colors yes
caruana and judah
have played a few times i don't i don't
necessarily know that they're super
close friends but they're just engaging
in the in the normal top level player
banter
right this is because the reason they'll
banter about the specific game right now
mirrors because
right now they're analyzing the game
itself which is not opening prep it's
not what their strategy was coming in
those are the things that you'll never
see but unless the players dislike each
other which some do but unless the
players dislike each other they will
pretty much always engage in some level
of hey in the critical position i was i
thought i read fabiano's lips talking
about this f4 idea that so maybe dude i
missed it as a way to equalize i don't
know what do you think
well
it's not so clear to me
for the moment but i think that's
[Music]
maybe
more to the
the openings ideas like if
they were talking about the f4 opening
idea no not like i well i cannot read
their minds but maybe c4 and like
instead of knight c6 i don't know
interesting i i felt like they were
talking about the endgame one because i
assumed that they wouldn't be talking
about anything they brought from a
preparation standpoint uh but okay
as we see everybody
three games are in the books amir
trace
three draws today three draws today
uh we have one game left we have two
more moves already having been played on
that board oh i wasn't paying attention
so faruja has now played king c2 and
hikaru immediately puts that knight back
on d5 remember it has to guard the f6
square
okay so we cannot play king g3 we know
that we've established we've established
the things that furuja can't do
so
how are we going to continue here
once again
did you start with bishop h4 first or
king ji2 okay king
you wanted to play bishop g5 and i
wanted to play king d2 here but you
might be right actually why can't we be
more aggressive for this idea we haven't
looked at that yet but then well you
said e5 you know like even even after
bishop g5 e5 it's the same
but there's something
there's something to inducing the e pawn
maybe i don't know maybe not maybe not
um
we have to to make a move anyway there
is no other move for black king king h8
and there's no re there's black can't
play knight oh yeah i i forgot my own
idea of course mission of sex yeah okay
so there's no
black is still frozen so unless i'm
blundering you know with king g3 you
cannot you cannot play
knight f4
yeah
so don't
but can we start with king g2
king d2 like not with bishop g5 but king
d2 you know just
without e5 not bishop h4 not here so you
just want this right away okay
so we
you play d5
[Music]
i cannot play
king e2 so
he said
i was thinking you know
we have like this is a study-like
position so we have to find it suktsvonk
it will only work like uh
if you find it so if we will if i'll put
you in a position where like any move
you will make you'll lose yeah
let's have a look is it possible
no
yeah what elmira is saying i think is a
super instructive way to approach these
types of positions in your own games
because
if you what we're doing is is really in
some ways not the right way to do it
we're like analyzing and guessing moves
what you have to do what the players are
doing
is trying to just visualize it's like uh
you have to think about where you want
to go before you get in the car right
what is the goal city right where are we
driving to and
so if we're visualizing something where
black has the pawn all the way to e3
let's say and
and you can't advance any further so you
can't play b4 in a position because if
you move the knight i'll have bishop of
six and you can't advance the e pawn
because i'll take it so you get a
position where there's zugzwung
and then all of a sudden black has to
make up zorg's wong by the way is the
german the german word that literally
translates to english as move compulsion
meaning you have to make a move that
loses the position
the problem i have with that elmira is
if the king can always shuffle from h8
to g7
right
unless there's a way to to break down
the blockade of the knight and and pawns
sort of holding squares
i don't have a zugswung in my head right
i can't visualize a goal position for
for for russia that's winning
okay but then
let's say here
what do you do
can can i play kingi one
okay
so to be here i guess we could visualize
okay if we just put the king somewhere
there is a win for sure don't get me
wrong but it's but how do we get there
so kingy one
black just sits tight no maybe like you
can also use my idea of playing b4 here
exchanging ah you cannot take on before
once again
i love every time hikaru walks in the
background chat says a wild hikaru
but before and a3 then you know you
cannot take
a3 a while hikaru appears
black is putting so you cannot take on b
okay so that's why you cannot play kinky
one of course you could maybe come back
and maybe you're still drawing
but okay
yeah so you don't want to do that
okay
this is why hikaru was so thrilled when
he saw c3 perhaps what he visualized is
he knew the king was going to be trapped
if you ever if you ever try to run at
some point i'm gonna play b4
and push him baby
look at the car in the background he's
getting his grocery shopping done
he's getting his he's getting his
laundry probably taken to the lot the
laundromat we all have to do laundry
while we're here in madrid
um because we're going to be here for
way too long do we have like a super
powerful computer
what is the violation what is the
assessment okay we cannot make a king
move we have to make a bishop
to bishop bishop g5 this this was your
idea and then okay let's say e5 well
because at least here i'm threatening
king d3 okay e5 anyway okay
and what can we do here
oh wait okay no no
and then black and white this is just
crazy
the for the foresight for hikaru here
look at that farouja's dejected i think
he's
he's frustrated
frustrated with the uh
well i think well the more we look at it
and
he's he spent how much time on
on his
yep
two moves at one point he was an hour
and a half up an hour and a half up on
the clock now he's a half an hour behind
um
and
he's struggling to find a victory and
again the longer we let the engine think
almira the closer that eval bar comes
that's what i'm saying we don't we have
stockfish 15 which is the neural net
version running cloud this is the
strongest we can get unless we're like
you know pull out the jet engine
whatever like as far as in our from from
all practical purposes
the computer is
the computer is as good as it can get
and the computer the longer it thinks
thinks that it might be a draw you know
what the longer i sit here the more i'm
thinking that i could go for some faster
moves to be played and not just these
long time controls
like the kind of fast moves they're
going to be played at the third annual
chess kid youth speed championship will
feature eight of the top youth players
from around the world in a series of
blitz matches you might think that
sounds silly at first but let's not
forget alireza perugia first turned
heads
in the junior speed chess championship
he played on chess.com
almost five years ago
so when you tune in to these events with
the youngest players in the world some
of the best and brightest for the future
you might be looking at future ali reza
faroujas i think jeffrey zhang won one
of our first ever chess kid national
championships that i organized back in
back in 2011. take that fun master mike
that was before we even hired you buddy
just kidding love you love you mike
anyway you can catch all the action june
20th at twitch.tv chess kid with your
host fun master mike uh ketty ted
salvasvili as well and uh wfm maria
rodrigo so amir i know you haven't
played in these online events we're
going to solve that next year we're
going to get you in
but basically that uh i haven't played
in many online events at all it's not
it's like
uh
i really love like over-the-board chess
and uh during the pandemics i well
i didn't know who i was anymore like
i wasn't in online chess no i didn't i
didn't play at all like i played maybe
yes during the pandemics like i played
maybe like a few tournaments to support
women's chess yeah and that was it so uh
coming back to the food you know so
so what kind of food do you like back to
the board um elmira knows who she is
again over-the-board chess has returned
um
so what like you were talking like
coming back to the foodies like you said
that hikaru okay
so what kind of cuisine do you like me
yes everything there's nothing i don't
like okay there's there's not a
single type of cuisine that i
do not eat
some of the candidates actually
well came to
my restaurant they played some plates
of course really yes which ones fabiano
okay richard
uh
well that was also live on erin okay you
know the hospital i had no idea about
that so
we can also play blitz there
yeah my apologies for that everybody i
was
i was not in the live position on the
analysis position but um
at this point i might i might have been
looking into the crystal ball there
because i'm not sure that there's
anything better than the lines we've
been looking at with bishop g5
um
i'm pulling my hair you're pulling your
hair out um i don't know what to do
but maybe they're
like it's such a safe if this is a draw
okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna do some work all
right all right time to sit up and maybe
i want to figure this out but before we
just decide it's a draw i i think i just
had an idea okay tell me
i think i have a plan okay so i'm going
to start with bishop
h4 or bishop g5
and on e5 i'm going to go back to d8
okay
i know what you're thinking i will
king h8 i think and just right i need to
keep the status quo king but here was
one of my thoughts was
if you
play b4
actually i lost my thought
okay because my point is we can't ever
run if we run yes you need to keep your
king close to the pounds yeah if we run
then there's
okay not right away there's no
seven first so i want to say because you
have to guard you have to guard f6
maybe no maybe you don't okay then i go
back
no i don't see any difference
if i step too far we know this is a
landmine square you can't go to e2
because of the check you go to e1 and
then finally again here comes b4 smart
it
and if you take it
it's just just
debated
sheboygan wisconsin it's uh it's black
who wins
so how do you make
progress
um
i had another idea so is there any way
that they can play bishop g5 bishop h6
and to make you move the bomb
can i took swanky u
in this way bishop
and now can i do something here
okay that's interesting because now all
right so we're actually onto something
here because again to create zug's wong
you have to take away your opponent's
options you have to make them make them
make forcing moves to eventually maybe
reach a position you know where they've
gone too far at the very least in
elmira's plan we've now corralled the
king
in a way that he stalemated so if we can
force black to do something he doesn't
want to do with one of the other pieces
because the king has no legal moves
maybe there's a chance so but on the
other hand like you're threatening to
well to win the g6 man
so um
97 and logistics
yeah
because that's the problem with the
bishop so that's actually a really
instructive point for everyone wondering
about this
this is why this isn't a threat because
the moment you're not threatening bishop
f6 the knight is actually free to move
so you're actually threatening both
knight f4 and 97 for the record
um in both of those moves black is
suddenly with chances
all right so you have to keep your
bishop on g5 yeah you have to keep your
bishop on g5 in order to or or at least
this diagonal
sorry not that diagonal
all right
okay he's going forward okay he plays
bishop g5
i
like i said i think i was predicting the
future i think hikara will come back and
quickly play the movie five if i had to
uh
fight together he is back from lunch hey
buddy hope you got all your groceries
done
um
there's a shop on the corner that had
surprisingly fresh peaches i had one
this morning it was delicioso
delicioso it was uh i'm not kidding
actually
e5 played instantly again hey caro is
like i got this bro
hey carl's foresight to understand that
this was going to be a tough nut to
crack
is absolutely mind-blowing and just
changing the storyline of the day from
brilliant preparation by ferugia which
did indeed get him an advantage there's
no debate that that he's the one playing
for a win here but as you look at the
board and as we just beat our head
against the wall
they're literally literally beating our
head against the wall there's there's
nothing here for okay
yeah i think that well hikari he's so
expressive
so like we're
what we are watching actually is a real
show you know we have chess games we
uh but we also have a drama but we have
a like character play like so
oscars
we've got we've got so much we've got
acting we've got drum we've got chat
we've got votes on songs we're going to
sing at karaoke we've got hikaru
off in the wild i wonder what he's doing
maybe he's preparing for his next
performance at the chess.com rapid chess
championship
we're taking a bit of a break for the
candidates if you didn't know that but
the rcc can returns july 2nd seven weeks
remain before we ultimately decide who
the 12 will be that are invited to the
150 000 final
who's going to lock up their spots
before the knockout rounds begin you
catch the action every weekend it is
literally every weekend except right now
during the candidates so
all right we're going to take a very
quick break don't go anywhere when we
come back we're going to come right back
into this we see the moves are being
made but this is our last break likely
so don't go anywhere we return to madrid
for round three of the feed a candidates
in just a few
right on your phone
you don't even need to download an app
just open any mobile browser and head to
chess.com events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results
and so much more try it for yourself at
chess.com events
[Music]
this club is called amigos del retiro
friends of the retiro the retiro is uh
the most big and important park in in
madrid it's a very important part in the
city because it's right in the center if
you want to play chess you don't know
the place this is a maybe best one in
madrid
[Music]
and
the defending champion jan napomnishi is
back at the candidates affecting his
second straight bid to challenge for the
world chess championship
one of the more experienced players nepo
brings to madrid an aggressive style
that is both challenging to face and
entertaining to watch
two years ago nepo made the most of his
debut in the candidates with a round to
spare he won the event in convincing
fashion
that's all he needed yon napomishi is
the 2021 world chess championship
challenger
that victory led nepo to a world
championship match with carlson and also
secured his return to the candidates in
madrid this year
despite being one of only two players in
the field to have won the candidates the
expectations for nepo are not
particularly high this time around
however his confidence from having won
here before in addition to his years of
competitive experience may offer him a
shot to turn some heads
if nepo should pull a major upset and
face magnus carlsen again the two know
each other well
nepo has competed against carlson for
decades ever since the two prodigies
were 12 years old
[Music]
this is going to be a real time
breakdown of danny wrenches games all
time on chess.com uh that's cool
oh
in the last month i am playing 83.12.
i'm less accurate than them in every
stage yeah man that that's the angle you
should okay do the more game review okay
yeah thanks a lot okay so tuesday sucks
i gotta stop playing cats on tuesday oh
it's because it's final tuesday
[Laughter]
look how many blunders there were back
in december 2020 and now december 2021
1600 don't look at this number
look at look at this number
best let's go to
uh tactics
mates
[Laughter]
probably need to work on these ones yep
every single rook fork that has
presented itself to me i have found no
one has a higher percentage of rook
forks than i do
that's correct
these are literally the night forks that
you i missed knight d6 it you saw it
just now what is wrong with me
i could have done here and then taken
this pawn and i'm winning because my
pawns get held together that's probably
the coolest part about this feature like
these positions against his pass
rook there for rookie too
and he plugged his maiden one
oh my goodness i'm awful
[Music]
[Laughter]
do
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
[Music]
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
palacio de santonia
look at look at the beautiful art elmira
well that's all i'm looking at the
beautiful art what do you think about
i'm counting the angels there's
something about naked baby statues am i
right amira
i don't know what do you think
chess
i don't know
speaking of young people
he's not a naked baby
but he is the baby amongst these eight
competitors i'm sorry i'm gonna lose it
are we live uh we are live i'm so sorry
indeed did you think i was kidding when
i said something about naked baby
statues
i was hoping you were gonna give us a
breakdown of naked baby statues
okay it's for some reason when you put
wings on them and give them a bow it's
okay to just have a bunch of naked
babies everywhere you know they turn
them into angels and we're all just
supposed to play along any hooters uh
what we have here is ali rozafaruja
no longer a baby
he is a he is a man child a beast
among men this guy is uh
shout out to peter griffin that's a
blunder i i've made a few um
but uh no he's he's a monster for many
years to come we're gonna be looking at
that guy so you better get used to it
regardless of what happens in this game
elmira but i feel like the longer he
thinks
the more we've just hit the wall i've
turned the engine on we're okay from
here
from here we're just gonna look at what
the engine says and see if there's a way
to figure it out by the way king e1 is
on the board
uh
wait wait wait but did we try king d1 in
this position
he just did it
and the computer instantly says b4 is a
draw yes but we
as the late and great emory tate would
say after that move you know what the
computer said
zeros
no sorry but we know that before like
you cannot take then you simply have to
bring your king closer so before you
cannot take a b
a b because three look look
now i'm with you i'm just like i'm just
i'm
can i drop an f-bomb i'm flipping bone
blown away by hikaru nakamura in this
game
the moment he played c3 elmira the dude
got up he spent a total of maybe three
minutes at the board in the last two
hours like he knew it was a draw before
stockfish did
right
i know sometimes he can bluff or
whatever but everything about this has
said like he knew it was a draw for
rouge it took an hour
kind of came to the same realization and
now we're about to see hikaru nakamura
hold against great preparation
from the youngest the youngest beast in
the field
well that's why i still think that um
well
even if we are facing such a
technological progress these recent
years that this state of technological
singularity is not well at least they
hope is not here soon yeah it's because
this is a proof
human human will the willpower right
it's willpower you're saying is still
greater than the machine so you're
saying when skynet becomes self-aware
and launches the missiles we hikara will
be our john connor
no i was thinking more about the um
uh 2001 space odyssey
this one you know just like and they're
playing a game of chess yeah you know
halls
yep um
i think purusha is is aware that there's
just
knowledge now do not play a takes b4 oh
wait no you can't play a takes before
here because bishop c1
there we were looking at similar
positions on there and the bishop was
here and then it was losing ah yes okay
so he can't take and the reason
everybody is because on a3 bishop to c1
a2 bishop b2
and what will happen is
wait no you don't play a2 at bishop c1 i
think you immediately go for the pawns
because now you're not threatening
bishop f6 yeah he instantly played
knight f4 hey card knows this is a draw
no oh he takes there because there's
knight b4
was there another one
no okay no he would okay so it's the
only one okay
i can't keep up
so
but you can
why can't you take on a3 it's still a
draw knight c2 and then you go for the
bomb
yeah that was brilliant elmira let me
ask you something
if this is the first meeting between
these two over the board chess is back
nakamura is back over the board he's not
just a streamer anymore we know farouja
is going to be the future for a long
time
what do you think this is a little bit
of the future well i could get used to
this type of battle between these two
guys what do you think
a little taste of the future
this game is uh
well it's just
it's a living proof that you know
they're at their best now probably
peorosis will improve of course but uh
once again hikari is playing some
brilliant chess
like if he managed to defend this
position
so um
[Music]
yeah
this is a draw
so you're saying you could get used to
this
i think i think i think chat could
probably get used to this this has been
a battle for the ages ali reza perugia
brought the heat
he left nothing at home literally he
brought home preparation brought it all
to the board he was better at one point
i think we we thought this was going to
be a winning end game wait but king g2
is such a tricky move of course you have
to go knight d5 and go for the bounce
back you have to go back yes
yeah you have to go back in a hurry
actually that's that's maybe the only
move
because if you play a2 bishop b2
and you're
and you lose you lose and and if you
play king g7 if you play keems
look he already knows it
what are you doing here car none of us
have figured it out yet hikaru slow down
so that we can figure it out too hikaru
let us play
all right he could play king just seven
he can simply he's already figured out
of course
sometimes you can be
a real
jerkface icaru obviously i'm saying it
in teasing because you just figured it
out faster than the rest of us and now
now we're all figuring it out
an hour and a half after you did that
this was a draw
this is simply
probably one of the most
intense drawers that i've ever seen
seriously yes this is an absolutely epic
battle
all the way until the literally you
can't play any further this is a table
based you're all legal draw i can't
checkmate with a knight farouza is
smiling and
okay i think kikara was saying he
thought he was winning if he if he did
something different than allow c3
i'm speculating but
i am entertained
for all those of you who photoshopped a
car nakamura's face on russell crowe
thank you you'll get your diamond
membership but the answer is yes i was
entertained
it's a picture we cannot hear the
players analysis
i don't know i don't know that's
something we can pull off getting audio
of that room so i'm not even going to
request that because my producers are
going to literally strangle me if i if i
make that request but um it is it is it
would be it is cool i just wish i had a
professional lip reader
can we have somebody out there do some
bad lip reading videos of chess come on
there's a professional lip reader out
there you guys have all seen that
channel where they do bad lip reads of
nfl
start doing that and chess.com will buy
your channel and pay you lots of money
because what i want right now is for
someone to do a bad lip reading
he's like oh you want some sushi yeah
i'd love some sushi
like oh okay cool i know a great place
yeah i do too in fact i was thinking we
could order the spicy tuna
yeah spicy tuna is my favorite but don't
forget the vegas roll
ah vegas roll yep
uh-huh
yeah vegas roll yeah vegas i like it
i like the volcano world too
yeah
by the way that's our own maria emerald
over the background shout out to maria
we love you we love your work
um
okay yeah no for sure but sometimes
you've got to go places with a noodle
dish too hey carl just said
i agree i also like noodles
you have a lot of hidden challenges okay
if someone starts doing a bad lip
reading channel for chess i'm not
kidding chess.com is going to pay you a
lot of money we're going to hire you
we're going to buy your channel so i you
can sign me up now like so when you're
whoever you are out there
i've had this idea actually for several
years and i've learned it's actually a
lot harder to do
you really have to be a great lip reader
but that is a that is content the world
needs so there you go
the challenge has been made
all the games for day three have come to
an end
and they were all drawn they were all
drawn which means i was wrong go figure
we had four draws in the books at the
palacio de santona in madrid spain
and this is how
they won mary you're i mean okay do i
even have to ask the game of the day
no no
go ahead give us your final thoughts on
just how epic that furuja nakamura first
ever battle was
well this was absolutely
well this was an epic battle of course
and
let's remember how it went they went for
the name soviet defense you know
i literally calm opening the beginning
you know so then
fuja simply sacrifices a piece for a
long-term compensation
hikaru
finds the only moves i think in the
position to transpose it to a like to a
slightly worse end game
and then defends it till the end like a
computer yeah this
this is not human actually this is just
the perfect defense yeah
no and again and just to add to that
because i want i want to give a thought
on each of these games they they all
deserve a quick thought but it was it
was the way he did it almirah like
played c3 gets up
and we're sitting here this whole time
like okay we know we we switched over to
dingley runs game with with uh with
young chris
now i'm spacing out with with report
right we we spent all this time
everywhere just expecting foruji to move
and in hindsight now that we've got this
sort of you know 20 20 vision everybody
are you not entertained i mean that was
mind-blowing he knew it was a draw and
then he played instantly for the rest of
the game like he just held the position
like it was like it was freaking nothing
i can't believe it it was uh well but
once you figure this out then everything
becomes you know clear it's really it's
an evidence so
yeah
well um do we want to let's quickly just
give a small recap for those who may
have tuned in late of the other three
games i will i will say that again
uh so for ruja nakamura was a draw as we
said we just mentioned dingley ran a
report in hindsight was maybe the game
really with the most potential chances
but a very very hard thing to judge
dingley red for not playing the
dangerous queen takes the eight so we
have another draw
carwana and dude i was personally a
little disappointed and i'm saying that
for my friend fabi because i just i had
this hype in me i mean remember the
beginning of the show i was like all
right
english attack by fabi here we go but
duda right credit to that young guy
maybe we have a new future best night or
player in the world nbl watch out right
right rajabov and nepo sorry not really
given a thought on that because it was a
bloodless draw we love you guys but of
course we will i'm sure we will see
better fighting games in the future so
okay um
quick draw
it's what it was so standings now as
they sit after three days elmira i know
you're counting the seconds till the
rest day but
real quick we look at the standings and
uh what do you biggest storyline of the
first three days before we talk about
what we're going to do on the rest day
and get the bleep out of here
well first of all i think that um the
first three rounds showed us like
what is the player's form
so it it became rather obvious for me
that jingle iran is struggling you know
in this tournament for the moment so
does the more rajab and they're for the
they are at the bottom of the
wall of our standings so it's very
important so yandy pomneshi fabiana
carona you know they're
playing very well
both won one game in this tournament and
we know how difficult it is to win at
least one game
but everything is still possible so they
are they are followed by young sister of
duda alive
richard raport and hikaru nakamura yep
hey car the only person with uh dif with
the same digit in all three categories
there a win a draw and a loss um it's
kind of a funny looking stat there so
he's got the picket fence so
also won his game yesterday so yeah
like he is
having one decisive game under his belt
well these are the standings as we said
after round three we're gonna even
though we're moving to a rest day of
course we're gonna
yeah we're gonna preview the matches for
tuesday
and uh
round four after our well-deserved rest
day for both us and the players i'll say
it i'll say it we i would i would
challenge someone in chat to tell me a
different sporting event that is harder
to commentate on than what are we at now
mira elmira uh we're at uh
almost eight hours of being live
well i have no idea i mean like nba game
is three hours right an nfl game is
three yeah i mean three hours i mean
like this is exhausting and i cannot
wait for the rest day i'm not ashamed to
admit it but okay real quick yes let's
have a let's have a look what's the big
matchup we're circling for tuesday
first of all dinkarana
not because you know fabi will maybe
even try to play for win you know ding
is out of form but look at the score
he's leading at the
personal uh well encounters so five to
two
and also another score report has a zero
three result against hikar yeah that
that's that's interesting both american
players actually might
push with black in the fourth round
this is a very interesting that's that's
an interesting game for sure and we also
have do their jabba so they just have
one jaw
yeah
i i think
i think the report nakamura like i i
want to unpack that stat i'm going to on
the rest day because i wonder how long
ago were those games what color was he
caro he has black has he gotten all
three wins white so i'll unpack that
stat a little more uh but the other
thing to mention again about the dingley
wren uh versus five minute car want to
match up is we learned the context of
that when hammer was here that a couple
of those victories came when they were
very young so so that's also good it's
obviously a lopsided score in the favor
of the highest rated player coming into
the candidates but but there's more
there than meets the eye and napandashi
and ferruccia right i mean
again
ferugia hasn't lost uh in the in the
event he's he
played the fantastic chess today against
icarushi also hasn't lost the only other
player to get a win besides caruana so
and deuteron i don't know what to make
about that matchup because look they've
only played one game they drew it right
um
it'll be it'll be really interesting to
see
um
see what duda brings with the white
pieces that's for sure right and you
mentioned how this is this is revealing
in the first few days of what what are
the players form i think right now
rajava maybe is is the one who's maybe
struggling the most with form i know
dingley wren also had that loss but
does that make duda a little more
aggressive with white we'll find out
right i think that dude is always
aggressive with what just
he doesn't need another reason you know
to be aggressive with white so yeah he
was always aggressive so
well amira
thank you thank you for holding it down
we did it we got through the first three
days we have a well deserved rest day i
hope that everyone has enjoyed this
right there the palace of santona
what a great first three days we've had
here
another great view of that naked baby
take that naked baby
take that naked baby in will you
everybody just go ahead and
take a look at that naked baby and
we are going to see you on tuesday as
round four of the 2022 feed a candidates
kicks off we are going to enjoy the rest
day in madrid i hope you do as well
until then enjoy and we will see you on
tuesday everyone
[Music]
you